if you want to take your go programming
skills to the next level this is the
course for you experienced go developer
akil sharma will teach you how to build
10 projects using go the projects go in
order of difficulty starting with a
simple web server
so in this video we learn how to build a
very basic golang web server the
prerequisite to this video is that you
should have golang installed on your
system
and you should have a very basic idea of
how golang works like packages trucks
and interfaces
and uh you can watch a video on how to
install golang if you don't have it on
your system and it doesn't matter if
it's open to
mac or
windows the steps that i'll be covering
in this video will be similar for all of
them
so i i'm on my windows laptop and i've
opened my up my powershell uh which is
basically a terminal for windows and on
mac you'll have terminal on opendo
you'll have uh your bash or your
terminal again
so
you once you've installed golang on your
system you'll have
a folder called go so that's where you
want to be you want to be inside that
folder called go and inside this folder
you want to be inside a directory called
as src
inside this src directory
uh we'll create a new directory called
go server
and we'll go inside this directory
this is where we
create our code
so i'll open this in my code editor
which is vs code
so now that i'm in my code editor i'm
going to go ahead and create a folder
called static where i'll keep my html or
static files and my main dot go file
where all my golan code will reside as
you know when we start writing any golan
code we have to write package main in
the beginning and then we have to
import some packages from package main
so
one
uh of the packages that i need is fmt
then i need the log package then i need
net slash http package which has most of
the functions that i need to create a
web server and routes right and then as
you know for every golang
code we have to have trunk main which is
where most of the control of the
operation lies right now i'll switch
over to my draw.i o board and show you
what exactly we're building
so i thought before we start building
any of the functions it's better to show
you uh what we're building so we here's
our server file and here are the three
routes that we'll be building today
one is the root route which is just a
slash then we have slash hello and then
we have slash form
when we hit the slash
route or the root route we'll just
open up index.html file
and then we have slash hello
uh which will just uh call function
hello function and just print hello to
the
screen and then we have a slash form
route which will have a form function
associated with it and then that will
open up a form.html file for us right so
we have to create index.html and form
the html files right now
and then we have to write these
routes inside our funk main and then we
have to create these functions also
inside our main.go file right so now
that you have a 10 000 feet view of what
we're doing it'll just uh everything
will make a lot more sense so now let's
uh switch back to our vs code
back in our vs code you have seen that
we had worked till this point till funk
main now it's time to create two files
index.html
form dot
html in our static folder in index.html
we'll write some very basic code we'll
say html
and then we'll say
head
and
sorry we'll say
title
here we'll say static
website
and after the head we'll place a body
tag
inside the body tag we will have an h2
tag
and we will again say static
website and that's that's about it
in our form
we'll have
slash doc
type
html then we have an html tag
we'll have a head tag
inside the head tag we'll say meta card
set
is equal to
utf-8
slash right so that's what our meta tag
does
and then we have our body tag
which will have a div
it will have a form method
is equal to post
right so we want to
post
the form
and then we will have slash form
right
and then
we have our label
uh i'm i'm assuming that you already
know uh html so i'm not explaining a lot
of things
right but anyways this is the name
field that we want the user to input
right so we'll have input
name is equal to
name
and then you have type is equal to text
and you can also skip this part if you
don't really uh you know want to
bother about html
and then you have label then you have
address
[Applause]
then you have your input name is equal
to
address and type equal to
text
and value
nothing
right and then you have your
end code type is equal to your submit
button
value
submit so a submit button which will
have
submit written over it
all right
and this completes our form
that we want the user to fill right and
now we want to start wiring up our
main
logic which is inside the funk main
so inside funk main
we'll have a file server
which is basically
uh a function that we get inside the hdb
package that we just imported so let's
say file
server where s is capital so make sure
you say that
and here
uh
you have a short form assignment
operator which basically declares and
defines a variable right so with colon
and is equal to
and then you have http
dot directory
dot static
slash static i meant
so we're telling
uh golang that we want you to check out
the static directory
and now golang automatically knows that
it has to look at the index.html file
because uh
as you know php golang node.js all of
them look at the index.html file right
that's what they're trained to do as
servers
and now you have
a handle
function inside your hdb package
right
and so i want to start handling my root
route which is just the slashed out so
how do i handle it i say
send that to
the file server function that i just
created which is you know just on top of
this
and then you have your http dot andrew
funk
which handle funk is another uh
what he called function that we get
inside the http package and now i want
to handle my
slash form route and you have
form handler
right so we'll create the form handler
function shortly
and then you have another handle func
where we'll handle
our slash hello function
right slash hello route that which we'll
call the
hello handler function
so far so good i've already shown you
what slash hello and slash form are
supposed to slash form will show us the
form which is from.html just the slash
will serve as the index.html file which
i've shown you how it will do that and
slash hello will just print out hello
to the screen and we'll have to create a
function called hello handler for that
and
now let's
also
print out what will be printed out when
our server connects
so server.port 8080
and
right so if you want to put new line you
have to use printf which is inside the
fmt
package that we've just imported
now let's handle
our
server
so we
uh you know use the listen and serve
function inside the http package so as
you can see hd packet is very important
and this will create the server so this
is really the heart of the
software that you're creating
right so they can be
uh the error can be there or it could be
nil so one of these two values will be
assigned to err which is the error so
now let's handle the error if it's not
equal to nil
then we want to do something so we want
to log dot
fatal
error and this is where we used our log
package
to handle or to you know log the error
so so far so good with the
main.go now we want to start creating
our main functions so first we'll create
the hello handler
and func
hello
handler
this usually has two things so one is w
and the other is r
right so w is
http dot
response writer
so as you know with any api or any route
you'll have either a response and a
request
so request is something that the user
sends to the server and response is what
the server sends back to the user
so we'll keep that value in w which is
the response and for the request that
the user will send
which will be in http dot request
this star is a pointer so r is basically
pointing to the request right
so yeah i'm assuming you have basic idea
of how pointers work even if you don't
uh
it's okay i think you can just follow
this video right so as soon as we wrote
funk uh hello handler you can see the
squiggly line below hello hundred went
away because now it's uh it knows what
to do when it uh you know encounters
this route now let's start writing out
our function
so url
r is as you know the request so when the
uh user sends a request which will be in
the form of like let's say slash hello
right so what you want to see is if user
dot if the r url dot
path
is not
equal to hello
now we're sending the uh the request
which is slash hello to the hello
handler but let's say by mistake
something comes here so now we want to
check if uh you know the path is not
yellow handler then we'll do something
we'll say sleepy dot
error
w slash
44 not found
and
http dot
status not
found
all right
and we'll just return from the function
and then
if
r dot
method
not is equal to get
so we want only uh
like when you type slash hello in your
browser right that default by default is
a get method
right
and we don't want people to post
anything to slash hello we want people
only to get and in the sense just print
out hello right that's why we're saying
that if it's uh
not get then again you'll
return an error http dot error
which will be w again
and method is not supported
then you have http dot
status not
found
now again status not found is again
inside http packet so you can see how
important that is
and then we'll again return from this
function if this is the condition
but the ideal condition would be that we
want to just print to the screen which
is
f
print
f
so fmt by the way has a lot of these
uh
you know functions like printf print ln
fprintf right you can check them out and
they're all for very different things
and so we'll say hello
and that's what our hello handle will do
now there's this quickly line below form
handler
so that means we want to write a form
handler function
so let's start doing that so we'll say
funk
form handler
w http dot
response
writer and our
asterix http dot
request
now uh you're going to be using this
very often so just
i mean it's the same syntax so
uh you can keep it copy paste it
somewhere and then just keep copy
pasting it that's completely all right
and
again we'll have the same thing if error
parse form so you want to
parse a form right
uh we want people to submit something in
their form their html file and there
will be a post request and they will
then that will parse the form
error not equal to nil
basically if there is error then we want
to say print
fmp dot
f print f
w
error okay
didn't we look done so this is just
basically printing out the error
and
here we'll say f print
if
[Applause]
w comma
post request
successful which is the ideal scenario
which is where you want to be
and we'll say name
is equal to
so whatever we'll fill in the form right
you remember the form so whatever we'll
fill in the form
uh
we want the values to be taken into
these variables so r dot
form value
name so we want name from the form to
come to
uh name
and then we want
address
to be equal to
r dot
form value
address
and we'll say fmt dot
f
printf
w comma
name is equal to
percentage s
new line
comma name
and then we say fmp dot
f
f printf is basically printing it on the
screen
print f
comma
so whatever the the user has written so
we're just going to basically
um
printed out here now uh
you must have seen that there was a
squiggly line below and a name and then
once we used name out here the squiggly
line went away because golang tries to
tell you that you're you've defined this
variable but you're not using it so
that's an error in golang and this
doesn't happen with javascript and you
can have like millions of variables that
you never end up using and that's a
problem right
uh so that's a nice thing about golang
that it catches all of that
and then you'll say address so now the
squiggly line below address is also gone
away
now this completes our function
so let's uh head over to the
um
powershell and check it out if it works
so back inside our terminal or
powershell we're still inside that
folder go dash server where we've
written all our code
and now we're going to
run a command called go
build which will create a binary
executable file it'll be a dot exe file
because i'm in windows
and um
now i can run
go run main dot go so
we have given our main file the name
main.go but you could have named it
anything else but main.go is the usual
accepted standard right so that's why we
named it main.go now we're going to run
that code
and it's going to say starting server at
port 8080 because that's what we had
written if you remember in our funk main
uh it's it's given me so it's showing me
a pop-up which is asking me for my
permission for my firewall so i'm going
to allow access you might not see that
in your in the screen recording software
probably now we'll have to head over to
our browser to see what's happening out
there
so let's go to our browser
and here we'll open a new tab
we'll say localhost 8080 now you
remember we have three uh routes we're
handling three different routes right so
one is the route route which is this
just the slash then we have slash hello
and then we have slash
form.html right so we have those three
uh routes that we're handling so slash
we're handling
uh using file server and then we're
handling hello using hello uh hello funk
handler uh the function hello handler
function then we're handling slash form
using the
uh form handler function right so in the
diagram if you see this right slash
hello slash form and then with slash we
want to open up the index.html file we
just written static server and that will
be printed to the screen and then we
have slash hello where we just want to
print out hello to the screen and then
we have a slash form where we open up a
form
from the html file and then we'll have
we'll fill up the form and then we'll
you know post to the server and print
out something to the screen again
all right so let's uh start off by
checking out the slash route and see
what happens it says static website
right which is exactly what is written
inside the index.html file and if we say
slash hello
uh the hello handler function will be
called and you will just print out hello
uh to the screen and then if we have
form
dot
html
i'll just enter my details here and
submit so remember it'll say posts
request successful because that's what
we had written in our code right inside
the form hillary function and after uh
you know you submitted those details
it's just going to print out those
details to the screen that's all it does
so f printf name and f printf address if
you remember writing that right so it's
just printing out those values
to the screen
that's what our simple web server in
golang does in this video we'll build a
complete crud api using
golang and we'll have something called
as a movie server which will give us the
list of all movies and we can create
update and delete as well
that's what crutch stands for and uh
this diagram is a 10 000 feet view of
what we'll be building so that once we
start coding you won't have any um
confusions right of what why we're doing
certain things
so there won't be a database that's why
i put a big cross here that we are not
going to use the database we'll instead
use trucks and slices to actually
perform operations on the data inside
the server itself and uh we'll be um
serving it on localhost 8000. we'll be
using gorilla mux and gorilla mux is an
external library so i'll show you how to
install it as well and
so we'll have five different routes so
we'll have get all route we'll have a
get by id route create route update
route and delete route and that's
something you need to remember because
uh once we start coding you'll
understand why i have shown you this
diagram so every single route will have
a corresponding function so if it's a
get all route it'll have a get movies
function if it's get by id then you'll
have a get movie function uh without the
s and then if it's a create route we'll
have a create movie function and so on
for updating delete as well right now
there are two types of endpoints slash
movies or slash movies by id and we have
to use them depending on
what we're doing in the sense if we're
creating then obviously it's slashed
movies if you're updating then obviously
the id is required so it has to be slash
movie slash id right
then there are methods so
there are get methods for get all and
get by id we'll use get method for
create we'll use post for update we'll
use put and for delete we'll use the
delete method
and we'll be using postman to test all
these endpoints
using all these methods right so um
what we'll start doing now is we'll
start first we'll create a
directory for uh keeping this
project and then we'll start writing the
code and then i'll take you to postspan
to test all the apis so the prerequisite
here is that you need to have golang
installed on your system
uh now i'll see you on the powershell
so now we are at our powershell for
windows we have powershell for ubuntu or
mac you'll have your terminal uh is the
same thing and the commands that i'll be
writing here will be exactly the same
for uh mac and ubuntu as well so you
don't have to worry uh now the
prerequisite like i said is that you
should have golang installed in your
server on your system i meant and that
means that you'll have a folder called
as go
in your system right so you have to go
inside the go folder you have to go
inside src if you don't have src then
you can create src but you'll definitely
have been in uh package i think so you
can create the src folder and now you're
inside the src folder right as you can
see here
uh now we'll create
a
directory called go movies product
and we're going to see it inside this
directory
right
and like i
mentioned in the beginning of the video
that we'll be using gorilla marks now
gorilla mux is
not part of the main package that you
get with golang right so it's an
external package
so uh the way to install that is using
goget
and you have to put the github.com uh
link for the same right so
the link for gorilla is gorilla slash
mux and then
github.com then you use go get to get it
and then once i hit enter
it's going to install it or in my go
moviestrad folder
now i'll
open up my code editor window you could
use notepad plus plus i'm using vs4 in
this video so i'm going to open up this
folder in code plus in vs code like i
said and i'm going to try and shift
to the
visual studio code so i think now you
can see vs code on your screen as well
and
here we'll create a file called main.go
now this video is a beginner friendly
video so i'm not going to have different
folders and a very complex project
structure which will have routes and
controllers and models and database and
all of those files
and folders because that will uh you
know
i'll have to configure the go path i'll
have to configure
the relative routing and all of those
things so
i don't want you to be confused if
you're a beginner so
if you've just learned golang and you
just want to get your hands dirty with
building a server and building a rest
api this is the right video for you so
i'm going to try and write everything in
the main.go uh file right so so that you
don't get confused and this is also why
i'm also not using a database and i'm
using just structs and slices to
actually manipulate the data inside
golang itself
and so let's get started so as you know
that when we write the main.go file the
first thing that we have to write is the
package main right so and then we start
importing the packages that we need
so i know that i'll be using fmt because
i'm going to be printing out stuff like
your server is connected and that kind
of stuff i know that i'll be using log
because i want to log out the errors if
there's any error for connecting to
the server and then i'll be using
encoding json or by the way all these
are part of the package main so you
don't have to really uh you know worry
so encoding slash json uh i need this
because i want to encode uh
my data into json when i send it to
postman and then i need
math slash random
we'll be creating
uh so let's say the user adds a new
movie to this movie server so we need to
create a new id for it and that will be
created using math.math random so that's
why i need that and then i obviously
need net slash http because this allows
us to create a server in golang so
that's it's quite important obviously
and then you have your string conversion
uh because the
id that i'll create using math.random
will be an integer and then i'll have to
convert into a string so i'll use string
and string convert and i'll use itoa to
format the the integer and then um
you know convert into string
so and then i'll have the external
library that we just installed which is
gorilla marks
so you'll say github.com and slash word
class remarks now you'll get a quick
line for all these packages because
uh you have imported them but you're not
using them so golang knows that and
golang is going to trouble you till the
time you start using those packages and
which will be quite soon for us so we'll
start using them soon now uh if you
remember i told you that we won't be
using a database we'll be using structs
and slices right
struct is basically like an object in um
in javascript if you view javascript or
java or any other language it's like an
object and you're going to define you
are going to have almost like key value
pairs and you're going to define uh you
know the types of data inside that
so i'm going to have a struct of type
movie and i'm going to have
uh start of type director
okay
and
movies and directors are going to be
associated in the sense that every
movie has a director
that's how they're going to be
associated so movie will have multiple
other things he'll have
an id
which will be string right and then you
put this character which is
i think called carrot not sure this is
directly below the escape button on your
left on your keyboard and then you say
json
and then you say
id
within double quotes
then you have isbn which is basically
just a number uh assigned a unique id
assigned to a film
and then you have again those characters
and then you have json and
isbn
it's right struct here then this quickly
like hopefully go away
and then you would have the title of the
movie obviously the movie has a title
right and you'll put string here and
then you put a json
and then you'll say it's
title
then you have to say director
star
director and
json
and
star
is a pointer as you know
uh so that means if i create a struct
call director
it will be associated to movie struct
and with director what i'm saying is
that director will have the same values
that i'll define inside the director
right so these are strings idea has been
entitled strings but director is a type
of director which is the struct that
i've defined which i'm defining right
now and
director will have first name
which will be a string
json
and
hostname
and we'll have a last name
so again djson
right so when we send this data using
postman we'll be using isbn id title and
director in small
with small
you know what do you call it
small caps
same with first name and last name
that's why we're defining json like this
so that we're able to encode and decode
the json when it comes from postman
and so we've defined our two structs and
like i said movies are associated to
directors right every movie has one
director
and then we'll have our
so we'll define
a variable called movies it will be a
slice
of the type movie
this right so because we'll be using
movies very often now you'll see why
uh i won't
try to explain it i'll just show you uh
instead so we as you know every golan
code every go file has
funk main
right in funk main
you will have your
uh so
in golang i'm sure you know that you
have colon is equal to which declares
and defines the variable at the same
time so you'll have much dot
new
router
new router is a function inside the mux
library inside correla
so r is now your new router router
and then you'll have r dot
handle
funk
and you'll have
uh five functions here
so let me take you back to
the
yeah
chrome
and show you those five functions so
we'll have
uh five routes as you remember one two
three four five and we'll have five
different functions right
so
inside our uh funk main file itself funk
main function itself we'll have to
define these routes and functions
so let's go back to the code window
i'm not sure if you can see it
yeah so now you can see it
so i'm back at the code window and now
i need to create five different routes
and five different functions right so
first route is the movies route
i'll get
movies
get movies will be the function so if i
hit the get move slash movies route i'll
need to take it to the get movies
function which i'll define in some time
till the time i don't define it it's
going to give me a squiggly and say that
you don't have this function
and the method i'll be using here is get
you've seen this on the diagram that
i'll be using get method for getting all
the movies right then you'll have our
dot handle fun
slash movies
slash
id
and get
movie
so as you can see there's no s here it's
get movie get a singular movie
and methods again is
get
then you have another handle
funk
slash movies
and methods
is post
then you have r dot handle i'm not
copying and pasting r dot handle from
this line uh i'm typing it again and
again because i want you to type as well
and that will ensure that you have some
muscle memory
and then you'll be able to write code on
the fly really quickly and you won't
make a lot of mistakes so it's always
good to write it again from scratch
so you have a function here called
update movie
then you have methods
and say put
and say r dot handle
funk
slash movie slash
id again
we have delete
movie
dot
methods
delete
okay
so we have the functions we have the
methods and we have the routes so all of
that makes sense
and
to start the server what we'll say is so
first we'll have to print
starting
server at port
8000
slash n
right
and i'm going to say
i'm going to log out if
the server doesn't start
and i'm going to put i'm going to use
the
listen and serve function inside the hd
package that i have here http package so
to start a server it's very simple in
golang right all you have to do is http
dot
listen
and
serve that that's all you have to do you
have to write the name of the
port
so i have to put this code in front of
it because localhost colon8000 right
uh we'll be hitting that address when
you start the server so i have these
five functions
get movies get movie so i have to create
all those five functions and i have the
method set out here
now before i do any of that
when we go to our postman and we'll hit
the server right when we hit the api
uh slash movies and we want to get all
the movies in the beginning
there won't be any movies
so that uh we don't want that we want it
to have at least a couple of movies
right so that we know that the server
the api is working perfectly otherwise
we'll never come to know
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take movies struct uh this slice of
movies right that i just created here
that's what that's what i was saying
that i'm going to show it to you very
soon so you don't have to worry about it
so we have the slice called movies and
i'm going to append a couple of movies
to it
and by the way all the operations that
we'll be doing in this and all these
five functions will be around
uh this slice called movies because
we'll be storing a lot of these
different movies uh and the type
obviously is this this is an entire type
right or you can call it a class or an
object or whatever this is an entire
type and then we'll have multiple movies
of this type the complete structure
right and then you have
uh
movies append and then you have
movies
right because we want to append to
movies and you want to append a movie to
movies
right which will be an object just like
this it will be an object a struct and
we'll have to define all these things
like id isbn titled and all those things
so i'll say id
1
also isbn
4 3 8
2
7.
let's say
title
movie one
and for director
the syntax is slightly different
okay
so you'll say
director
and then you'll say ampersand director
because we want the reference object we
want the reference of the address of
director right which is
this out here that's how we'll be able
to use the pointer director
so if you've used pointers in c or any
other language you'll just know that
ampersand is to give you the address and
percentage or so the aztecs is
used to access that address for the
pointer
and then you have uh the directory which
is
first
name
john
and last name
so i have one movie i will create
another movie append
movies
movie object
and it will have
an id
oh just a second essentially some issue
yeah
so it will be id
2
ispn
4 5 4
[Applause]
then you have your director again
first name
so what should be a good first event
last name
let's keep it steven smith
and last name
because
smith
i'll actually keep
the s capital
even with
yeah steve s capital i think
so like i said
we have our movies so when we now hit
the get movies function at least we'll
have two movies that will show up right
so we'll at least know if the api is
working and the server is working fine
and now let's start creating our get our
movies function
what i'll do is i'll create the get all
movies function
then i'll create the delete function
and then i'll create the get movie
function create function and update
function the update function is
uh
it will look a little complicated to you
it will be the most intimidating so i
want to calculate it last so that you at
least get used to the syntax before that
so let's create get
movies
okay w
http dot
response
writer
comma
r
star http dot
request
so we point uh passing a pointer of the
request that you will send from your
postman to this function and w is the
response writer so when we send a
response from this function it will be
w right
so we'll say w dot
header
dot set
basically we want to set the content
type as
json right so we want to work with json
the thing is that um the struct uh our
golang stack needs to be able to convert
the json coming uh into it into uh you
know
its own format so that's why we have to
set this content type and then we'll say
application slash
json
and then we'll say json.new
encoder which we got from here encoding
json right json this is the same json
json.new encoder
and you're going to encode w basically
the
response that you want to send to it you
want to encode it into json and dot and
code
and you want to pass the complete movies
slice that you have so like i said you
know whenever we
uh when we're whenever we create slices
we're just going to append um
you know a new movie
to the movie slice that already exists
whenever we want to update anything
we'll be uh traversing inside movies and
we'll be updating something inside the
movies slice as well so movie slice is
quite central and when we all obviously
when we return uh the list of all movies
we'll be returning or resolving
basically the entire movie slices at the
same time so this is why the movies uh
slices at the center of uh this entire
operation that we're doing right now
uh so you've seen how now you know how
you can get all movies right so you
basically uh want to you know encode
into json and then you want to just
encode movies and send
the json of all the movies of uh
the slice
which has the type struct which is
struck movie right so all of these
movies you will be able to send
to the front end or to postman or
wherever
now we'll create the delete function
because that also looks a little
easy right
and then we'll get into crea get one and
create and delete functions so let's
delete them
now when you want to delete a movie
you'll be passing an id of the movie
so we'll say w
http dot
response
writer again
and r star http dot
request
you'll have w dot header
dot set again the same thing
content
type
and you want it to be
application slash json
and now i'll get some params right so
the id that i'll pass from my postman
which will will go as a param to uh this
function create movie
and that param uh which will be the id
will be present inside
mux dot vars and inside the response
sorry the request which is r
so it will be part of the request right
the pointer to the request i'm sending
out here
so in params now i have the now i'll be
able to access the id
so
what i'll do is i'll
range over
movies
ranging over movies if you used
javascript it's very similar to like for
each basically
so all you're doing is you're just going
over all of the movies and you want a
put you want to find a particular movie
and uh now what you want to do is if
item dot id or the id that you pass so
you'll say that delete uh the id uh two
in the sense the movie with the id2
right so the id which you now have uh
right access to which
will be params
id
so you know that we got params we got
the id that you sent as a request to
this function will be inside params and
will be inside id so you'll have access
to that particular movie uh that
particular id i mean and um
and inside movies you will go
uh
through all the movies one by one and
each of the movie will be inside items
so item that with item.id you'll be able
to access each of the ids of the movies
of each of the movies right so if
uh
the item dot id of a movie which is
inside our uh
movie slice is equal to
the id that you just passed as a
pronounce to the request
then what should we do we should
take the movie slice
and we should append
basically we want to delete it right so
we appending it
i'll show you how you can delete
something by using append
so we'll say movies
and index
so for range for a range function right
you have to pass index an item
index is like you know i is equal to one
well this very much like javascript like
so so for index you have i so i uh you
know starts from zero and goes to a
particular value and item is actually
the item so if you used a for in loop or
a for off loop you would know that you
can access or iterate over the exact
items itself
and in go like you can do both at the
same time
and you'll have movies
index
plus one
and
dot
so what you're doing here essentially
is
whatever id that's matching right now
that you want to delete
it's going to basically take that
and directly append all of the other uh
you know data which is basically index
plus one all of the other data is going
to just append it in that place in this
place
so that means this movie now won't exist
it's the id that you just passed with
the index it won't exist because in in
place of that the entire movie's uh
you know uh index plus one after that
all the movies that were there they came
out here right in this place
so the movies uh movies that you want to
delete now will not exist so that's how
you delete a movie right using a pen
now we'll get
a particular movie
by using get movie function
so we'll create the get movie function
and again we'll have w http dot
header
dot set
and again your
content
type
comma
application slash
json
then
just the same way we did with a delete
movie
uh you will get params the id in the
params right
in the same place exactly where
r where r is the request that the user
sends and
mux is the package that we're using for
creating these routes and vars is
inside mugs right which helps us to uh
get access to the
all the things and uh requests so
basically the params
and uh then we'll loop through the
movies one by one so if i want to get a
particular movie from the slice of the
movies that i that exist uh with me in
golang
all i have to do is i have to go through
all the movies and then find that one
and then
encode into json and send it to the
front end or to postman right
so
here
we'll again use the for loop just like
we did in delete movies
uh but there'll be a difference here
instead of index we'll write the blank
identifier because we don't want to use
index because we won't be using index
right and if you don't use something in
golang you have to use the blank
identifier otherwise golang will give
you uh those squiggly lines and give you
an error that you've defined this
variable but you have not used it
right that's why we have to use this
uh blank identifier now we'll range over
the movies and we'll say if
item dot id
is equal to is equal to parents
id
right so
inside params i have passed an id so
it's going to try and compare that with
item.id because it's going to range over
all the movies one by one and each movie
will be inside item and so we'll have
the access of id inside the item and
that will compare with params or id that
just passed
and if they're equal
then you just have to return it that's
all you need to do you don't have to do
any other operations so you say
new encoder
w
dot and code
item
and then you'll just return
now uh
i'm sure now you can see why i showed
you the delete function
uh before
the
get movie function
right and that's because
in delete function we we used the range
uh but we didn't have a blank identifier
if if i would have used a blank
identifier directly then you would have
gotten confused so that's why i want to
show you the delete function before now
in delete movie once we delete the movie
i think it's better to
uh also return all the existing movies
after you've deleted that movie so what
i'll do is i'll uh
try and return the remaining movies as
well so i'll say new encoder
w dot
encode
movies
just like i did in get movies right
json.new encoder
w dot encode movies
right and then get moving we're just
sending one particular movie which will
be the item as you know that with range
you can access each movie using the item
right so we're just sending back one
movie whereas with delete movies we're
sending back all the remaining movies
with get movies we are sending back all
the movies
so get delete get movie
i'm sure these are clear now
now we'll take a look at create movie so
we'll create
create
movie which obviously is the most
important function because you want to
create
movies it's going to be a post method
response writer and
r
star http dot request
the spelling of response is wrong so
it's giving me a squiggly line
response
it's best to keep uh
looking at this quickly line so that you
can
handle all the errors
during while writing the code itself so
now you can see that i none of the
functions have a squig line anymore
except update movie because you've not
defined it yet so that's why there's a
squiggly line there
and we have used all of the
packages as well so those quick lines
have gone except math random and string
convert that we'll be using in update
movie and update movie is obviously the
most uh
intimidating function so i have not
shown it to you yet
and uh that's why we look it at the last
and now we have create movie
error
dot set so this is something that we do
every single time right
content
type
comma
application slash
json
then we'll define
we'll define a variable called movie of
type movie
and you'll soon see why
and we'll create a blank identifier
again
we'll
decode our dot query so uh while
creating a movie we'll send something in
the body we'll send an entire movie like
this an entire movie like this we'll
send it in the body in postman so we
want to now decode that body right we
want to
decode uh that json body and we'll say
decode
and
right so we'll get that value here in
this and movie right
after decoding it
i will say movie dot id
so this is where we'll use your string
convert and your uh math.random because
you want to create a new movie all right
so to create a new movie we also need to
create a new id which will be completely
random id so what we'll do is we'll say
random dot
which is a function inside random math
random library package and we'll say one
one two three four five six seven eight
you can put as many zeros as you want so
i want to value between zero between one
and this
uh maximum value
to create a random value right and then
i'll
have to now format it into string so
i'll say string
convert
dot
ito a which is a function inside string
convert package
and
that's how i'll get a new movie id
so i'll say movies is equal to append
uh
like we saw how uh with delete movies
you could append right and now with
create movie also you want to append uh
just like we did when we created a new
movie we want to append the new movie
that has just come to movies that's all
we want to use it's very simple so we'll
say append and we'll see movies comma
movie
because the new movie that has come out
come from the body is now inside uh this
movie which uh you know uh we decoded
from json into now a format that is
readable by golang and it will now look
like this it'll look like a struct
right so that
like we said movies comma and the entire
movie so that's what we're doing here
essentially we're just saying movies and
comma movie that we just received from
uh
the body that the user just sent from
their postman and now which has been
converted
into a formatted by calling right
so uh
really simple now since we have appended
it here now we want to also return
this movie that was just created just to
tell the user that hey you know i have
created this movie so you don't have to
worry
encode
and movie
so the movie is now created
now comes the most intimidating
function which is update movie function
i'll start writing it out
update
movie
and here uh we'll be passing an id right
so you know how to get the id right
you'll get it in params which will be
inside mux dot
vas and inside r right the params will
be there and then we'll have to again
range over all the all the movies
and then what we'll be doing for
updating movies is we'll first delete
that movie uh for the id that you'll
send and then we'll just simply add the
new
uh id that uh
uh the new movie that we'll be sending
from postman so this is not obviously
the right way to do things when you work
with databases uh but we're just doing
it here since we're not using a database
we can get away with that we'll just
delete the id of the movie that uh the
the movie with the id that you send from
postman and then we'll
uh
uh you know just add the new movie that
you'll send the new structure in that
same place we added there
so
uh i hope that makes sense or maybe i'll
should i just write some pseudo code and
so that it becomes really clear to you
so first what we'll do is we'll uh set
our uh
content type which we always do right
and then the next step will be that
we'll get access to our params then
we'll
loop over
the movies or we'll range over them to
introverted movies
then what we'll do is we'll
uh delete
the movie
of
of uh
the id sorry with the id
that we have sent
suppose we'll delete it
and then
we'll simply add
a new movie
which will be
so instead of actually updating
uh that particular record in a database
we're just deleting it and then just
adding a new record from the body that
you're sending
which is nice little hack and something
uh that you shouldn't do when you work
with actual databases it's just to show
you right now
so this is the pseudocode
one by one let's start writing out code
then right
so now
we want to set
json content type
how do we do that
we do that by w
header
dot set
content type
exterior
and we will say comma
application
sorry application
slash one
and then we want our parents right so to
get parents we'll say params
dot
where's r we've been doing this till now
now we're going to loop over uh the
movies
and we're going to delete the movie and
then we'll add a new movie so we'll do
all of those three things now at the
same time
so we'll say for index now we want to
use index in this case so we won't use
this blank
uh
identifier because you want to use index
we'll say it's equal to range
movies
and if
item dot id
params
id
what should happen
so like i said we'll first
so we'll delete over the movies uh using
range
and then we'll find that uh movie in our
movies slice then we'll delete that
particular movie with the id that you've
sent so if you found it with the id that
you've sent now we delete it so we'll
say movies is equal to
fn so we'll write the exact same line
that we've written in delete movies to
delete it so we'll say
in a inside a pen we'll use the exact
same syntax so let's say movies
and
index
comma movies
index
plus one
let's say dot dot
right so let me see if that's what we've
written
earlier
yeah there were no mistakes earlier so
it's the same thing
now we'll say where
moving of type movie now because we want
to append that movie so that's why we're
going to uh try and follow the same code
that we've written for create movie
and we're essentially going to almost we
can copy and paste this whole thing but
i'm just going to write it again right
so
so like i said you know we are adding a
new movie the movie that we sent at the
body
so we'll say equal to json dot
new
decoder
so the id that we have passed so this is
the only step that's different from
create movie right because
we want to have it in the same id we
want to use the same id so let's say
movie is equal to append
movies
let's say json.new
encoder
w
dot
and code movie because you want to
return
uh the movie to the user to tell him
that hey
i have done what you wanted me to do
i'll remove these comments
since now you already
know how this is supposed to work
now
one thing that we've not done inside
update movie is
w
http dot
response
all we have to do now i think is right
return here and then we're good to go
i don't think there are any
issues or errors here so i can
go ahead and compile this code maybe
right so
let me take you back to the powershell
uh how do i yeah so i'm back in the
powershell now
so i'm inside i'm still inside that
folder go movies crud and as you can see
i have that main.go file so all i have
to do now is go build
i've built it
and now we have to say go run
main dot
it's going to now start the server and
it's going to ask me for firewall access
maybe you don't see it in your screen
because it's a pop-up so i'll say allow
access
so yeah so now it's running on server
8000
uh
now let's go head over to our
so let me see if i can do that or i'll
have to maybe pause the video
and then show you post man yeah yeah i
can show you postpartum yes i think you
could see it now
uh i'm using obs so it's difficult to
switch between tabs actually in obs
screen recorder
uh now i have created this folder called
rough just for my own use uh you can you
can probably create just a new folder
and inside this i'm going to create a
new folder called
go
movies
inside go movies i'll have
a request
the request will be get all
then i'll have a new request get by id
i'll have a new request again
it'll be
yeah
create
then update
and
delete
so forget all all you have to do is http
slash localhost movies
right
so you have to write
http
double slash localhost colon 8000
slash movies that's what you have to
write
and let's hit
the server and voila the server is
working
we have got our two movies that we
created
in our posts in our vs code right
because we didn't want this to be empty
so we had created two movies using
append and in our funk main so these are
those two movies
let's get a movie by id so i'm going to
take
the same
route
here i'm going to put slash one because
i want just
the first movies like i'll get
uh just the first movie as you can see
right now i want to create a movie
to create a movie i'll
just say
uh i won't give the id obviously because
i uh golang will create the idea and so
on and i'll go here and say the body and
i'll say raw and i'll say json
and now right
i'll just try and call i'll just copy
paste this one little
from my get all i'll copy and paste one
movie here in the body i'll change the
id i'll say seven else this i'll change
the number something else let's see
movie seven
and the name here i'll say
okay
sure
so it has added
that movie called seven but it's not
sending me that
uh
movie seven
it should have sent me the 27 here
so there's something wrong we'll have to
oh sorry i'm still on get so remember to
switch to post method here right so when
you say send
it gives you the movie that you just
created which is this movie 7 right and
id there's no point of sending id
because id as we know it's going to
create on its own so i was wrong when i
did that
so even if i create one more it's going
to create one more id with the same
values so now when i get all
i'll see four different values right
now let's try and edit one of these so
let's update
uh first let me just copy this whole
thing here
and switch this to put and then we'll
put the id of one of the movies here
let's put this id here and update
right and then we'll have to say send
something in the body which will be the
new movie
the new movie
can be
copied from here
and we can change some of the values
like we'll put it
on
and i'll just say s because i can't
spell shot maker
say something else here isbn
and
so let's see what happens
so yeah the movie has been updated
the movie seven had first name akil
sharma now it's just has arnold so even
if we
get all we'll be able to see that the
movie seven has uh so there's one movie
with atletico there's on one we with
arnold s because we had created two
right in the beginning
now let's try to delete this
so i'm going to first copy this thing
and put in delete and then i'll put the
id
i'll go back here i'll get the id from
here
so now it's returning me the
movie that has been deleted which was
movie seven on test so now when i get
all
i
i won't see that movie hopefully
i'm still seeing that movie
actually
why is not working
oh sorry it's on get i'm i again i made
the same mistakes i have to uh use the
method delete for it
so don't make the same mistakes that i'm
making all right so now there are only
three movies so it's returned me all all
the movies uh that are now left right so
there are only three movies left even if
i say get all
there are only three movies left let's
delete one more
let's read this one also so that only
two movies will be left
so yeah only two movies are left now
right so remember to change the method
when you're using postman we'll be
building a bookstore management system
using golang so we'll be building some
cred apis and these are beginner
friendly you'll be using mysql database
we'll be using the gogorm package to
interact with our database
and then we look at json marshalling and
marshalling and the biggest change here
is that we'll have a proper project
structure in the sense we won't be
writing all of our code in main dot go
file we'll have a proper project
structure which i'll explain to you
shortly
and then we'll be using gorilla mugs
so with project structure this is what
we're going to do we're going to have
two main folders in our project one will
be the cmd folder the other will be the
package folder the cmd folder would only
have the main.go file and the package
folder uh will have the config folder
controllers folder models folder routes
folder and utils folder so we'll have
six sorry five
uh different folders inside the package
folder right
inside config we'll have app.go file
uh which will help us to connect with
our database in the controllers we'll
have book controllers which will have
the functions that will help us to uh
you know process the data that we'll get
for as response and also the
request that we'll get from the user and
the response that we need to send so
we'll process all of that in the book
controller in the book models in the
models folder we'll have book.go file
which will help us to create those
structs and models that will be used by
our database
in the routes as you know we'll just
write our routes and which i'll get into
later on in just two minutes i'll show
you what the routes are and in the utils
we'll just have uh for uh some code for
marshalling and marshalling json from
our
response and our request right and then
these are the routes that we have so
we'll have
uh slash book slash route
uh twice one will be for post and one
will be forget and these are our
controller functions that i've mentioned
here so uh if you post on the slash book
route uh
sorry i think this needs to change this
will actually be get
and this will be post
all right so if you get on our slash
book route you will
we'll call the get books controller
function if you post use the post method
on our slash book route we'll create a
book right we'll have to send something
in the body and we'll have to
uh use our uh json master link and much
link to uh you know get the data here to
the database and then uh we'll if we do
get on slash book slash book id which
which we'll pass the book id so we'll
get the book by id so we'll have to
create function to get a book by id then
we'll have our put
method for updating the book right and
on the same route slash box slash book
id
and then we'll have our delete uh method
on slash book slash id route which will
give us the delete book uh
the function and controller functions so
that's our entire uh
you know introduction on what we're
going to build and how we're going to
build it
the next steps include where
i'll go to my
overdue terminal i'll start these uh
different folders i'll create this
complete project structure and then
we'll open our vs code we'll start
creating these folders and these files
and then we'll start writing all of that
right and before that in our ubuntu
we'll also have to install the packages
that we'll be using so uh
in many of the videos that you'll see on
youtube you'll also you might see people
first including those packages in their
uh
files while they're coding and then
they'll
use go mod id or something like that to
install the package that they've used
but in our case what we'll do is we'll
install those packages beforehand and
then we'll include them in our code it's
just something that i prefer and i also
recommend you also do that
so that's that's the introduction and
let's get started
so as you can see i've opened up my
terminal uh since i'm on ubuntu this is
a terminal if you are on windows it will
be a powershell and if you are on mac it
will be a terminal again the commands
will be the same it doesn't have to uh
the commands won't change
so i'm going to go ahead and go inside
the folder where i write all my go code
where all my go programs reside you can
do the same and i'm going to go ahead
and create a directory for the new
project and it will be called go
bookstore in my case
and i'm going to go ahead and see the
inside
uh
the go book store and now since we are
here
we'll have to install a couple of
packages right so
before we install the packages we'll
have to create a go.mod file which will
uh crea store all the packages it's
almost like the package.json file if you
are from a node.js background right so
it contains all our packages that we'll
be using in this project so we'll first
do go mod in it and
even if you're not storing uh right now
inside a github account i just recommend
you use github.com and slash your name
or any other name and then slash the
name of the project which is bookstore
this gives us like a relative route or
then or an absolute route based on which
we can you know include and import
different files into our main.go file
so it has created our
go.mod file okay and now we'll start uh
importing the package that we need so
the first package that i need
is the gorm package which will help me
to interact with my database
jinzoo slash form so jinzo is the name
of the guy i think just created gorm
so we have added gorm
and now more specifically i need
uh the mysql package inside uh
guard because gorm uh is a is an orm
right it helps for for golang and it
helps you to interact with sqlite and
postgres but for this example we need
mysql so we're going to go ahead and
install that and then uh we need to
install
uh the
gorilla mux package since we need to use
that for our routes so i'm going to say
go
get
github.com
gorilla
slash mux
so we've installed gorilla mux as well
now as per my knowledge uh these are the
three packages that we will require but
as we go along uh you know i might find
that we need more packages so uh it's
not a problem we'll install them uh as
we go go ahead so from from what i see
what be building right now i think these
three should be enough probably
uh so let's get started with the actual
code now that we have our packages in
our go mod file
uh go mod file also helps us to uh you
know go build which will create the
build or the exe file which will uh
execute on our
uh machine exe if you have windows and
dot deb if you have uh basically it's a
binary file if you have ubuntu and so
we're going to go ahead and open up our
vs code editor so i'll say code and
space dot
and that will open up my code editor
so as you can see i'm inside my vs code
window and now i'll start creating the
folders that we had seen in the diagram
and you may have noticed that there's a
time
delay between when i switch between my
google chrome and my
vs code and my power shell or my sorry
my terminal and that's because i'm using
obs to record these videos and it's not
very user friendly in terms of helping
you switch between the tabs very easily
so kindly bear with me so let's start
creating the folders quickly uh as i've
shown you in the
in the diagram we have a cmd folder and
we have a pkg folder right these are two
main folders inside our pk inside our
cmd folder we'll have a main folder and
inside the main folder we'll have our
main dot
go file where all the magic will happen
right the main controller the main
control
of our entire project and inside the
package uh folder we have config
and we have our
controllers
then we have so i think by mistake what
i've done is
i've created controllers inside uh
config
so i have controllers
and then i have models
and then i have routes and utils right
routes
and
details
so as as you've seen just a second back
that i had created controllers inside
config by mistake and that's a very
common mistake by the way and uh that
will happen to you if you're not very
careful so please make sure that inside
your package folder all of these
different folders are at the same level
inside the package folder right they're
not inside one another yeah that's a
very common mistake by the way so let's
start creating our files inside uh
config we have app.go uh inside our
controller i i by the way in the diagram
i'd already shown you
uh the name of the files as well so we
have controller.go to control.go and
then inside models we have our book dot
go file and inside our routes
we'll have
bookstore
routes dot go
okay
and inside our utils uh the name of the
file will just be
utils.com
now
you know there's so many files right
here so we need a strategy on where to
begin and where to end the program at so
how do we start coding how do we begin
this whole uh journey of uh writing so
much code right it can be confusing it
can be daunting it can be overwhelming
uh many times so that's why i have a
small strategy for you that will help
you understand everything really well
what i'll do is i'll start with the
routes
so i'll create the routes first and uh
that will help you visualize the
routes where the users
will hit you know from their front end
or from their postman the user will hit
on those routes right so we'll start
with the routes and then what we'll do
is we'll then write our app.go file
which will help us to connect with our
mysql database then we'll create our
utils file so uh app app.go which is the
config file and utilize files are very
small files so
they won't confuse you too much and the
routes file is also very small and then
we'll create a main.go file the main.go
file all it will do is it will just uh
you know tell golang that here in
bookstore dot routes is where my all my
routes reside so all these files will be
really small uh then we'll create our
models file which will be slightly
bigger and then our book controller will
have a lot of code so uh we'll tackle it
at the end because after the routes the
control will go to each of the functions
in book controller file
so this is the book controller is what
we'll tackle at the end and before that
you'll get a little bit of
an idea of what we're building so it
things won't be very confusing for you
that's what i'm uh at least trying to
attempting to do so uh as you can see i
started coding here i've written package
routes and then i've said uh started
importing the packages that i'll be
needing
since this is my routes file uh
the one package that i most definitely
need is gorilla mux which will help me
to create the routes in the first place
and
the other package that i need is not
really a package but i need my
controller file here
so
first just see what this is then i'll
try to explain to you what's happening
so i'll say akil slash go bookstore
slash pkg and slash controllers
so this will help me import my
controllers folder and uh
in turn the file inside the controllers
folder as well right now if you're from
a node.js background you will be very
confused when you look at this right so
this is uh this is an absolute path
whereas with uh node.js you're used to
something like this right so you'll say
controllers
and that's because routes and
controllers are both in the same package
called pkg so you would say that okay i
just want to import controller so i'll
just say like this right
but that's not how it works with golang
golang has absolute parts and once you
get used to golang you'll understand
that that's kind of the right even if it
looks lengthy but it's kind of the right
way to do things right because uh this
uh the
github.com go bookstore uh till here is
the path that we created which was like
the absolute part that we created for
our project when we were initiating the
go mod file if you remember
and package.controllers is where you
know we'll come inside package and then
it comes and controls this is where the
controller's file lies and that's what
we want to use so it may take you a
while to get used to this absolute
routing but uh but once you get used to
it uh i'm telling you you won't go back
so i i am a no just developer i was not
just developer i can say for a very long
time but once i started using golang
i can tell you there is no going
right because uh golang is so so much
better
so you have registered bookstore so i
want to create a function called
register bookstore routes and this
function will have basically all my
routes and
this the routes will help me to get the
control to my controller where which is
where i'll have meet the meat of the
logic
so i'll have router
marks dot router
right and here
is where
in this function is where i'll create my
handlers so router dot
handle
func right so if somebody comes to my
slash book slash
right so i'll say controllers dot
create
book
so i've shown you the create book
function
right in the diagram i have not written
the from function till now but i'll be
writing this function in the controllers
file
and this is why i needed my controller's
package on top controllers file on top
right because if somebody hits the book
uh
route i want my controllers.createbook
function to handle it and the method
uh you know is going to be post here
because i'm trying to create a new book
so i'm sure that's very clear
and then we'll create another handle
funk
and it will again be slash book slash
but this time i want it to
say
get book you'll get the list of all
books for me and the method
in this case
as you know
will be get so on top by mistake i had
put two h uh for methods i i removed one
of those
so just make sure you don't make any uh
you know typos or any spelling mistakes
then we have another handle trunk
where we will handle
as you have seen in the diagram before
the uh you know the scoring part started
we'll have slash book and
inside this we'll have our book id
right
and then you have controllers
dot
get book
book by
id
all right so that's the function i want
to get one book by id and dot methods
you know the method would be
get in this case
all right
so i think all clear till now now we
want to create the two more routes
they will be same slash book and slash
book id will be there but there will be
our put and delete functions right so
i'll say router dot handle
func
sorry
[Applause]
and here also i think the us capital it
should be a small queue
and then you have slash book slash
book id
and then we'll say inside my controllers
file i'll have a function called update
book
okay and then
the method for this will be put
and similarly for our
delete route as well book slash
book id
and we'll have controllers
dot
delete
book
dot methods
and we'll have the delete method here
right so
so far all looks great
right everything is uh working out
pretty fine for now
so we have written our routes
uh package so if you read this far then
you should be proud of yourself i think
so now like i promise you we'll write
the
app.go file which is the inside the
config
folder right
and so we'll come here and we'll
uh give it the name
config package config sorry it's not
capital
package
config
all right
and here i want to import just two of my
packages and
they will both be related to
talking to mysql so the first package
will be jinzu
slash gorm
which is my orm
and the second package
will be the more specific one which is
dot github.com slash
jinzo slash gorm
slash dialects
slash mysql so if you go and look at the
documentation for uh
the corn package you will notice this
blank character here and then space and
then the uh
link right so just make sure you do that
as well so once we have imported these
two packages uh the mysql package and
the gom package
now is the time to create a
variable called db so the the whole
point of this file will be to return uh
a variable called db which will help the
other files to interact with the db
right so we'll say star born dot
db
and then we'll create a connect function
the connect function helps us to
open a connection with our database and
the database in this case as you know is
uh mysql database right so we'll have d
comma e r r uh the if there isn't so
i'll write some statement here and then
if there's an error the error will come
inside err if if there's no error and
the database connection has open it will
come inside d right so i'll be able to
access
the connection using d so i'll say
gorm.open which will help me open up my
connection with the database
right and here i'll write something so
i'll i'll say
the name of the
database that i want to use mysql
because gorm helps me as i had said talk
to sql lite and postgres as well but in
my case i want to use my sql
and
here i'll say the name of the user and
my password
and
my
the name of my
table
simple rest
and
and then we'll write some little lines
here which are required by mysql so uh
if there is is uh you know an error
right which means that if error not
equal to null which means that if there
is an error so we'll say panic er r
and here we'll say
db is equal to d
right so
whatever was in d here that we received
we'll transfer that to now db
variable
and
we'll have a get db function which we'll
use in other files
and
it just returns
deep so like i said you know the purpose
of this file is to return um a db
variable that will help us to talk to
the database other files can talk to
database easily
now
uh as you can see i have not written
some code ahead of
this part right so
for mysql to connect we have to write
some things after
my username my password and the name of
the table so that needs to be care set
is equal to utf 8 just make sure you
copy this exactly and you have parse
time is equal to true so this is some
requirement by
mysql right so you have location
right
so these few lines you have to write
and then your app.go file is complete
now
the next
code that we'll be writing will be our
utils dot go file
so when whenever when we start writing
our book controller we will be using uh
you know we'll we'll need data that is
unmarshalled data so we'll we'll receive
some requests from the user right and it
will be in json but we need to unmarshal
it to be able to use it in our
controller so we just need to write a
one one very small code here to be able
to unmarshal uh the json that we'll
receive from the request so it's going
to be very simple
we're going to call it utils package
utils and we'll
import a couple of packages one is
called encoding slash json
right the other is called i o slash i o
util
and the third is called netslash http
right
and here
is where i'll create my
function
and the function is called
parse body that will help me
uh to pass the body uh especially in the
create function in the sense when i'm
when i'm trying to create a book
uh you know the create book function in
my controllers
i will receive somebody in the request
right so i need to parse that body
because that body will be in json so i
need to be able to unmarshal it so i'm
just creating one small function to do
that
right so i get
the request and a pointer to it and i
take that in r so i'll be able to use
r to access the request that i've
received from the user and i'm sure you
know what a request is you know request
has that body that we're sending of the
uh
the book right
and then you have x and you have
uh interface
so i'm sure uh you know you know basics
of how interfaces work
so we'll say body and error is equal to
ioutil dot
read
all
all we're doing is just reading the body
right and if there
is no error so error double equal to nil
then we'll say error is equal to
json dot then we'll start unmarshaling
it basically
on marshall
there's a single l
right and we'll say
byte
and body
comma
after body you say
comma x
so just one thing guys the x
is a small x not a capital x by mistake
i written here capital x just make sure
of that
and
then error
not equal to
nil
and then we'll just return
right so even
uh this
looks like it's complete
right
and so your utils file is complete and
your
bookstore routes file is complete
now we want to start concentrating on
our app.go file
yeah sorry the adword file is also
complete so now we want to start
concentrating on our models file
right which is slightly uh more advanced
so
but let's start anyways right so we have
package
models we'll call
it and then we're going to import as you
know
we'll import our gorm package first
github
dot com slash
jinzu
slash form and there's one more thing
that we need to
install or import and that will be my
config file that i just created right
because the config file helps me to
connect with my database so i need that
here so i'll say github.com
[Music]
right
so let me just
be sure that
yeah this the routes required
controllers and
the app.go file required gorm
and the models required config yeah so
i think yeah so we're on the right track
so we'll create a database uh the
variable called db
gordon.db you've seen this already in
the config file
and we'll create a struct
called book
structs basically are based on models
and
a model is something that you know gives
us a structure to help us
store something in the database
so in this case we'll have name
because every single book will have a
name right and then you put these back
two backticks inside that you say gorm
then you say
json
name
let me say author
and you say string again so name of type
string and author of type string and
then you say gorm sorry you'll say
json
and you'll say here
author
okay
and then you'll say publication
and string
backticks again json again
and
publication
so let me read through it and make sure
everything is fine gorm json alright
author and publication right name author
and publication so we have three things
and uh
so usually almost like almost always you
will find this that we have to
whenever we working with databases we
have to edit our database so if you've
seen the golang to-do list video that
i've created so a few days back you must
have noticed that init function
so here also we need to have an inner
function that will help us to initialize
the database in the first place so
config.connect this is the function that
we created together just some time back
where which is the connect function
which helps us to connect with the
database that's inside the config folder
you know that already and db is equal to
so whatever we get from that um
uh you know config file
uh by calling the getdb function which
we have created together just some time
back get db function inside app.go as
you can see this is your getdb function
which returns just the db which
uh you know we had connected to the ddtv
right
and
so
that's what you get here inside db so
here also you have a db variable where
you're just storing the dv that you get
back from the config file
right
so till now i think everything should be
highly clear and then we'll just
auto migrate it with a book
an empty work
okay
so all good till now
uh now
you know the control
first is in the routes
right here in the routes
and then the routes basically give the
control to the controllers
and the controllers will give the
control to the
book.go which is basically the models
right so that's how the flow works in
the sense the user interacts with the
routes and the routes send control to
the controllers where we have all our
logic which will write in some time and
the controllers then have to
perform some operations uh with the
database now the the operations of the
database have to reside inside our
models file which is book.go in this
case
so that means we'll have to have a
different function for the different
controllers that we create so we need to
have a create a create book uh function
here we need to have a get all books get
by get booked by id and delete book so
we need to have all these different
uh functions here
right
so
uh now we have two options one is that i
start creating those functions directly
or i create the main.go file and then
that will give you more clarity and then
we create the functions that are
required for database right so i think
i'll create the main.go file so that you
have a little more clarity so let's
create the let's go on main.main.go file
and then we'll come back to the
uh
book.go file as well
now the so yeah so we have one more
option one is that i start creating the
controllers and then once we are writing
the function the controllers then i'll
start creating the model functions but
that may confuse you so that's why i
want to create the model level functions
first which talk to the database right
and then we'll have a corresponding
function to that in the controls so that
i think i feel at least from my opinion
that that will make things very easy for
you so anyways that let's write out our
uh package main file
inside our package main file we'll
import log because i want to log out if
there's any error we'll have nest slash
http so as i told you earlier that in
our main file all we're going to do is
we're going to create the server right
which will be which will will also
define our local host that's the first
thing that we'll do the second thing
that we'll do is we'll tell golang where
our
uh routers reside so basically all that
main.go file will do is tell that you
know bookstore.routes has our
routes so please look there
because i don't want to write all my
routes in the main.com file right so
that means i need my
gorilla mux package here
slash marks
sorry there's slash here
and then i need my
uh mysql package here
github.com
dialects
slash
mysql
and then there's something else i need
here i need to import the routes right
so i know that the routes is inside uh
package
folder inside that is routes folder so i
need to again use my absolute path which
will be github
dot com slash hill slash go
bookstore
slash package
so let me make sure if in my
uh yeah so here also it's correct
package config
right so yeah so we have google
bookstore slash package slash routes so
we need the routes here like i said and
now you know that inside uh a main dot
go file you always have funk main
so let's create the function
which will basically have
mux dot new router so we're creating an
r variable with
which will initialize the router here
and we'll say routes dot
register
register bookstore routes and we'll pass
r to it
so if you remember in our routes
we have some a function called as
register bookstore routes
here it is registered bookstore routes
and we are passing the router to it r
which is the router that we just created
inside main.go file we are passing it to
it and then we are
handling the functions using
as you know controllers
functions right so the r that we are
passing here becomes router right which
is of type mux dot router
so i hope everything makes sense now if
there was a confusion earlier that i'm
sure everything is making a lot of sense
now
so http dot handle
comma
r right and then you say log dot
fatal
so like since this is a slightly big
project in terms of different files and
project structure so i uh you know it's
very important to know what's the
order in which you want to build the
files right so if if i would go in the
order that's comfortable to me then you
might get confused and so that's why i'm
having to pick an order which i will
make a lot of sense to you right so
you'll have listen
and
so which helps us create the server in
the first place right and these brackets
i'll say localhost
nine zero one zero
and comma r
so uh by now i'm sure you know that
listen and serve is a function that
helps us create a server and we pass to
it this which is uh the the post port or
the address on which that we want to
start the server and it's inside the
http package which we have here
right so and if there's an error it's
going to say log it's going to just log
it out right
so that's our main.go file now let's
come back to our models file which is
book.go
so
uh i'm going to start creating all the
functions that i need to talk to my
database
uh
things might look very
i won't say very what things might might
look a little confusing to you right now
but when we stop when we finish writing
our book controller file it will make a
lot of sense to you so the routes from
the routes the data uh you know the
control goes to the controllers like i
said and the controllers there will be
different functions that i've shown you
in the diagram that will have
uh like you know create book and get
booked by id get books right uh all of
those functions will be there and then
those functions will again to in order
to connect with the database not to you
know uh make changes in the database
they have to go through these models
right so we we have to write these model
functions and that's what i'm creating
right now out here
we can do this like i said after we
create the controllers as well but
it may get confusing for you so that's
why i want to you know write these right
now
so we'll have a create book
function
and we have something called as a db
right which we have created here on top
db so db is what helps us to talk to the
database so db.new record
now new record is a function that exists
inside garm that's why we're using god
because we don't have to write those
queries for uh mysql the query part
gordon will write which is an orm which
helps us to talk to
uh the database we have to write these
simple functions like create a new
record those kind of things right so
we'll say dv dot create
ampersand b
right where b
is something that we'll receive which
will be uh of type book right and what
we're going to return is also of type
book so that's why we have a star book
here so we are going to return b
of type
book right so we receive something of
type book which is b so we create that
and then we also return that same book
that we created so that's why we have
star book out here as well
now i want to create
the get
all
books function
that will help me clear all books so
return all the books that i have in my
database
and here we'll have
books now i'm using a slice here because
i want to return a slice or a list of
the books that i have in my database
right
so we'll create a variable which is
books which is of type slice book
where b is capital just make sure b is
capital
and then all you have to do is db dot
find
books
and then you return
books right so you'll be returning the
list of books which is slice
right
now i want to create a function for
getting
a book by id
so that means it needs to take an id
first obviously that's very clear which
will be of n64
there's no space between ninten64 my bad
and
so these two things have written star
book and start start gom.db don't worry
about that right now i'll explain to you
as we go along
so we have where
get book of type book
okay and db
is equal to db dot
where
w is capital by the way
and
id
equal to
id
right so we are basically running a
where command in mysql where we are
saying that where id is equal to id
right then find that book
find
and get
so not only are we going to just return
uh the book that we found right now from
the database but we're also going to
return the db uh variable as well so
that's why we have the book that we're
returning get by id the book that we're
returning
with that particular id in our database
and we're also returning the db uh
variable that we had created which was
of type coord dot db right
and then we have a delete function
func
delete
book
id again is int 64
and there is book before it
book of type book
so
db.where where it helps us to find the
book with the id which which i've just
shown you some time back
question mark comma
id
right so uh and get get booked by id i
take an id where d was small now in this
case i'm taking id reduce capital
and then i'll say dot
delete
and bracket book
and then i'm just going to return
the book
so these are all the
uh
database functions i have now here there
will be a big doubt for you
you will be wondering why is there no
update uh function
why don't we have an update function
because uh in this video the way update
will happen uh in the controller will be
that
uh we'll find the the book the id that
you'll send as the from the the user
that the id that we'll receive so we'll
find that book first
and then we'll delete that particular
book and then the new data that the user
has sent us to be uh updated so we'll
use that to update uh the book and
created basically a new data so we don't
have uh an update function as such in
our
you know models we're just going to use
uh get and
delete and then post create basically
we're going to use a combination of
those three to update a file in our
database so uh it may sound uh confusing
to you right now but uh once we build
our controller uh file everything will
make a lot of sense
right so let's start building our
controller so we have package
controllers
and then we're going to import the
packages that we need so i i know that i
want to use
encoding slash json package
and
the other packages that i need i'm just
making sure that the video is still
recording because
because you know obs
obs has a lot of problems and then i
want to use the fmt package because i
want to print out things to the console
then i have my
github.com
gorilla mux that i want to use dot com
slash
gorilla slash max that i want to use
right
and i want to use my net slash http
package
i want to use string
convert package
and i also want to use
now i want to import my utils and my
models so by both my utils and my models
are inside my package folder so you know
how to do that right github.com
go
book store slash
pkg slash utils
right
and
com
then
uphill slash go
book store slash pkg slash models so i
have both my utils and my models right
now we'll create new book which is a
variable of
type models dot book
right so in
in our model file which is book dot go
we have created a struct of type book
right and that's what we have been using
all this file
so uh
of type book is what we are creating
here we're creating a new book of type
book right so model when i say model i'm
referring to uh the models sorry with an
s i'm referring to my models
file and i'm referring to the struct
inside uh the book struck book call
inside inside my models file right so
new book is of type book which is a
struct and which has all these different
things it has a name and author and
publication right
and it's called new book
i'm explaining to you
uh
this slowly because
controllers is where people get confused
right
so first
uh
yeah so here we have our five functions
which is get books and create book and
get booked by id and update and delete
so the strategy that we'll follow here
will be that we'll create the get books
function first because that's the most
easy in my
uh x in my
you know from my perspective at least
uh from you know at least what i think
is the get books function is the easiest
so we'll build that first so whenever
you're building a function
a controller function you know that you
have
two things you have a response writer
and a request
for request you put a pointer to the
request that you receive from the user
and then so we have a request in r and
our response in w so whenever uh the
response that we'll send to the user
will be with w so we'll have to return w
basically and then we'll have new books
models dot
get all
books
now uh the model functions may not have
made any sense to you but here it will
make sense because what we're trying to
do here is uh we have uh
you know new books and in that we'll
store models dot get all books so models
dot get all books is this function that
we just created together
model.getallbooks
right which will just basically find all
the books and send a list of the books
back to the user right so now back in
our books controller
we have a list of books inside new books
and then we want to have a response
json dot
marshall
new books
so we want to convert it into json right
whatever we see from our database so
that's why i use the marshall function
and then we'll use
in the header we want to say
content
type
comma
json
w dot
right
header http dot
status okay
okay so basically it will give us a 200
status okay means it gives us a
uh 200 and then
we say w dot right
which is the main thing now which
uh you know helps us to send something
to the front end or to postman which is
the response the response
is basically
a json version of new books that we
found from the
database
so we're just going to write a response
which will basically json right and the
list of the books that we found in our
database
that's all it is
and now the second easy function in my
opinion
is get booked by id so let's create that
as well
so funk
get book
by id
w
http dot response writer
and comma r
http dot
request
all right
so we'll get access to our r which is
our uh request right so inside our
request obviously will be the book id
right so we want to access our request
and we want to access the book id inside
our request
so book id
is equal to
vars
and book id
so we'll have string conversion dot
parse
paint
book id comma zero comma zero
so we just want to make sure that
the book id that we've received that
could be in string right mostly it's a
string and we're just passing it to int
using the string conversion package that
we have imported here
and if there is an error
error not equal to nil
we'll have fmt dot print ln
error
while parsing that's what we'll return
and then we'll have book
details
comma
the blank character
and say models dot
get book
by id
and id
right
so
we are getting get
uh booked by id models.getbookbiod right
which is a function that we created
together if we remember let me take you
to the models file and show you
so inside the model file inside book.gov
we have get book by id
so we will be returning two different
things like you know we'll be doing the
book and we'll be returning the db uh
variable
right and since i don't want to use that
use the db variable right now so that's
why i'm using the blank uh
character here because i don't want to
use it in golang if you don't want to
use something uh it's better not it's
better to use the blank character
because if you define something and
don't use it golang is going to give you
a big error so just make sure you use
the blank character here right
so
uh
yeah so i'm going to get booked by id
i'm going to get that inside my book
details uh variable right
and
now
i want to start thinking about the
response that i want to send to my user
which will be
very simple it will be just
json.marshall and book details
so to my user i have to
send a json response
right because i get something from my
database i have to convert it into json
and then i want to send that to my
user right so that's why i have to
marshal it into json
so now let's start creating my header
that i want to set
and will be of type
content
type
give type json
and w dot
write
header
http dot
status
okay
and then you have your w dot
write response
okay
so i hope this is making sense till now
so inside our right header uh we are
sending status okay which is 200 that
everything worked fine
and
we are sending the response and inside
the response inside rds which is the
response we just have a json version of
the book details basically the book that
we found in the database based on the id
right
so i am sure all of all of that is
making sense if things are not making
sense to you then you just you know
watch this video slower or you just type
it out with me just quote it quote along
with me i hope you're coding along but
maybe once more you can code long and
then uh you know things will start
looking becoming clearer to you and if
you still don't understand then you can
just you know put a comment in the
description in the comment box below
uh for the video and then i can probably
help you out
so you have your response writer
comma r is your http dot
request
so this is a quite long video
right so if you've reached this far then
you should be
really proud of yourself
model stock
book
[Applause]
all right so utils dot parse body
now we'll receive something from the
user right as a request and now we want
to pass that
uh
into
uh so we're getting that in json we want
to pass that into something that our
database will understand so that's why
we are using parse body which is a
function that we created together inside
the utils file right
so we're going to say r comma
create
book
all right
and then we'll say
b is equal to
create
dot
create book
so
create book
right
is a model of type
uh is a model uh inside the models you
have books right so create book is of
type that basically and then when we say
create book dot create book so i'm
referring to the create book function
here
this one that's what i'm referring to
out here okay
so we'll have create book.trade work and
then i'm gonna i now have to start
thinking about my response
my response will be json.marshall
inside that i passed b
so b is something that was returned to
me by my
create book function inside models let's
look at what it's returning to us so
it's returning to me the same model that
is the same object or same
it just created inside the database so
it created something inside the database
and it's just returning to me the same
exact thing so that's what i have access
to which is b in this case
so it's basically the same book that was
sent to me by my uh user
as a request
right so in the response i'm just going
to convert that into json so from uh in
the beginning we received json and then
we passed it into something that the
database would understand we sent it to
the database the database sent us that
same uh you know
record and then that record we are
converting that into json right now to
be able to send that to our
user to postman basically so we'll say w
dot
write header and then we'll say http dot
status okay
w dot
right
and we're just going to write our
response
to the uh
postman right
so create book was also uh
i feel quite straightforward now we'll
work on the delete book
function func
delete
book
so which will have w
http
dot so let me just check if the video is
still recording i'm not sure
yeah it seems like it's still recording
anyhow
so in our delete book
uh function
so as you are seeing right now that all
of these functions are talking to
another function inside our models right
so same similarly with delete book we'll
be talking to the delete book function
inside
our model which is book.go
so let's have responsewriter and comma r
which will have a pointer to
the http dot request that you'll get
from the user
and then we'll use vars again
to be able to
uh you know access
the request that we've received from the
user
and now we want to access the book id
where's
both id
right
and then we have
our error
so string convert
so basically if you're not
understood by now this we're doing the
exact same step that we were uh doing in
the get book by id so because we need uh
to access the request then we need to
access the book id then we need to
convert that into hint which will uh you
know do by string convert.parse and
package and then we'll also print out
the error if there was some error
right while passing so we're doing the
exact same thing steps there's nothing
new here
parse hint
and book
id comma 0 comma 0
and if there is an error which means if
error is not equal to nil then we'll say
fmt dot
brain talon
and here we'll say error
while parsing
all right so
that's great till now
and then we'll have book is equal to
model start
delete
book
id so you know this function write
delete book which we have created
together in the models
file delete book it takes an id and it
just deletes the book and then returns
the book that it just deleted right so
the book that has been just returned to
us will be inside the book variable
all right
now we have to start thinking about the
response and how we have to send it to
our user inside postman so we'll say
json.marshall
the book that we received from our
database function right now that needs
to be converted into json
so and now we'll start creating our
header and we'll setting set or header
content
type
comma
pkg
location
slash json
w start right
write header
http dot status okay
w dot
right
and this is the response the last three
steps are the same for almost all
functions there's nothing new there
now there's only one function left to go
which has obviously the people find it
the most complicated function
which will be the update function
and it will
have some aspects of
all of the different functions that we
have seen till now it's also the biggest
function so update book is the
biggest function and uh
let's get started i mean that's why i
always covered the update function at
the end because it can be confusing to
people so that's why we have already
seen delete book create book get booked
by id and it will just have a
combination of all of these functions
right so let's create the
update book function where u is capital
and b is capital
w http dot
response writer comma r which will be
http dot request
right so i'll go till here
no confusions
so we have update book which is of
models
dot
book
pretty similar to our create book right
the same same code we're writing out
here
details dot
parse body so whatever you have sent in
your request
as the new body to be updated in the
database for that same id that's what
we're going to parse and we're going to
take from json into a into a
uh we're going to unmarshal it into a
format that golang understands in the
database understands
so that's what we have done here
now we want to
get our id which is what is equal to mux
dot
vars
so like i said so it's a mixture of
the post the create book
function and the get by id function
right
so book id
let's go to vars
and we get access to book id
so till here uh we wrote some code from
the create book function
and here we have started writing some
code from the
get booked by id function right the same
thing the same part we have to repeat
here
so id
comma err i'm not going to copy and
paste it because uh i always encourage
you to write everything so that you get
very very comfortable with the code
right
parse hint and book id comma 0 0
and if
there is an error which is error not
equal to nil
then we're going to print out
fmp dot print ln
say error right
right
so
completely the same till here right this
this whole part is exactly the same
and these two lines i just showed you is
the same from create book
so till now i think there's nothing
confusing at all
so now
let's get the book by
id
right so we need to find that book if
that book even exists in our database
only then we'll update it right
so let's find that book about details
db
equal to models dot
get book by id
and we'll pass
capital id there
if
update
book
dot
name is not equal to
empty string it's not empty
and book details start named
okay so let me type all this out and
then explain to you what all this means
and if
update book
dot author
is not equal to
empty
then book
details dot
author
is equal to update book dot
author
right and then f
update
book dot
publication
is not equal to empty string
then
book details
dot publication
is equal to update
book dot
pub location
so
in our book model as you had seen
there are three things right name author
of application
so when we have to create a new book
right
then while creating the new book
uh
you'll have to have these three fields
name author and publication
so we are assuming here in our
controllers that the request that we'll
get from the user
it will have
uh all these three properties name
author and publication
so we'll take the request that we got
from the user inside update book and we
have uh you know parsed it
right so it should be utils dot yeah so
this is a big mistake here that i've
made it should be utilized parts body
and not just parts make sure you update
that as well right so let me check if
everywhere else i have not made that
anywhere else i've not made that same
mistake yeah i have not so it's parts
body little dot parts body and
uh
everything else looks to be all right
okay so we are assuming that that update
body after parsing has three things name
author and publication so we found that
uh body as we found that book from
inside the
database using get booked by id function
because we have when whenever we pass
whenever we call the update function we
call
we pass the id and we pass the body the
new body
for the new details which need to be you
know
set inside the database now
so we'll have name author in publication
and for book details
right we need to start setting
uh those three things so now book
details is something that we get from
our models get booked id so get booked
by id by passing the id we get a book
back in
return
and now we are setting the details for
that particular book object right so we
said book data's dot name now that will
become equal to the
new name that we have sent as part of
the request that we had also passed
right
and the author will also now become
equal to the author of the update book
you know which is basically the request
inside that we have passed an author so
that will be become the new author and
similarly the publication will also
become the new publication so all of
that detail is now inside the book
details
record which we now want to save in our
database right so we since we have
updated it now we want to just
save it so updating is taking place
inside our go link it's not taking place
anywhere else so we just found it by id
we now updated all the details and we're
just going to go ahead and save it again
right so dot save details
now we want to send some response
to our user as you know it has to be in
json
so we're going to send the book details
which we just updated right so the
updated things is going to go to the
user
so header
and dot
set
content
type
comma
pjq relation
slash json
then w dot
write
header
http dot status okay
and w dot
write
response
so we've even sent the response to the
user
and so we have written our
uh update function delete function
create book get booked by id and get
books so i think
all of the work is complete so now let
me just go between all my files and see
so main.go file is complete
config file is complete controller is
complete models are complete routes are
complete and utils are complete
so all of this makes sense and now it's
time to start testing and start
fixing if we get any errors or bugs and
also to check how to work with our of
these apis in our post plan so let's
head over to postman
so we are back in our terminal because
now we want to start trying to run that
code that we have written the entire
bookstore api
so uh
as you can see i'm inside my google
bookstore folder right
and it has cmd and package you can see
that i want to go inside my cmd package
and it has a main
folder so i want to go inside my main
folder
this has that main.go file now main.go
file is the file that we need
to be able to run the go build command
if you run the go build command anywhere
else it won't run because it needs the
main.go file
now when you run go dot go uh space
build
i'm expecting to see a lot of errors
right
and uh
you don't have to worry if you see the
errors because that's a part and parcel
of being a developer
so you will have to
uh
you know get used to solving those
errors that you get so as soon as i
press go build it's going to give me
some errors so right now it's giving me
only one error but once i solve this
error i know there will be many more
errors right so right now it's saying
that
in book dot go
file at line number 11 it cannot refer
gordon dot model so i kind of
know where the error is now i'm not
going to edit all all of this out you're
going to solve the errors with me so
that you become better as a developer
so you can uh you know identify so it's
saying uh book.go file
and at line number 11 is going to say
gone dot model is not there so all i had
to do was put a capital m here and now
it won't give me the same error again
or so i expect
so if i say go build again
it's giving me like i told you so this
error is sorted but it has given me so
many more errors right so the first
error it's saying is it cannot refer to
an exported name mux.vars
so let's go head over to line number 47
in our go book controller
line number 47
[Music]
yeah so vars
uh vars has to be capital v right so
that's why it's not able to access
so we'll say capital v
and
that error should at least go away right
so this error will go away
and then it says label book id defined
and not used which is line number 64.
so yes it's saying define but not used
because i missed the is equal to sign
here
and i have a feeling that all of the
other uh errors
because they are much later into this
same function so till line eighties here
till nine number eighty from 65 to 80
i'm seeing all these errors and i have a
feeling that they're all because of this
is equal to sign that i've missed so now
i'm going to go ahead and
go build again and let's see if there
are any more errors yeah so there are
more errors it's saying uh
go 71 3 undefined book details so
let's find out
so these errors are on line 71 74 77 and
79 and 80.
let's look into the code what could be
the issue here
so 71 74
and all of these lines
and the error basically saying that book
details is not defined
so i can see here that i've written
books by mistake
and not book details so once i fix that
i remove that extra s
hopefully these errors should go away
and there could be new more errors
no so there are no new errors
when i ran go go build uh there were no
new errors and it created this main file
here for me
and now i can start to
uh run this code
and i can start showing you
uh from postman so you can say go
run main dot
go
it it won't say anything that means that
uh
it's started running on your postman so
now let's head over to our postman and
i'll show you how
to work with each of these apis that we
i've opened up my postman window so
postman is a tool that helps us to test
all the apis if you don't know what
postman is you can go ahead and watch
any video from youtube
and uh
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a collection here and i'm going
to call it bookstore
my server is still running so
inside my bookstore collection i have to
create
a request and i'll call it
get all
all right
and then i have a request called
create
then i have
get
by id
i'll have
update
and
finally i'll have
delete
[Music]
so for
get all
i need
localhost
9010 where this project is running
and slash
book slash
okay
and if i get all
i get an empty array and if this is what
you get then your server is working
perfectly fine you're getting the right
result because right now we don't have
any books so we get an empty array
right and so that's why if we had don't
have any books we have to create the
book in the first place
so we will create the book using the
post
uh or create right so we'll say book
slash
and then we'll use the post method we'll
send somebody now remember in the body
we have to send json
and json will have
three fields one is name
the other is author
and the third is
make sure you get the spellings of
author and name in publication right
what is publication
so name of the book is zero two one
and author is peter
thiel
publication is penguin i think
so you send it
and you get
a response
which basically shows us that everything
is fine and we get status 200 okay which
we have only sent we wrote it right in
the code
that is that header
status okay
and let's create another book let's call
it
startup way
by eric
rice
and i don't know what the name of the
publication is so i've created two
different
books
by the way both of these books are
amazing if you're planning to start your
own company i highly recommend you read
these books
and so you when we run the get all
uh api again
it works perfectly fine right we get
both the books that are there in our
database
and now let's get by id
so we have one book with id3
and we get that zero to one
and one book with id4 and we get that as
well
perfect
now we'll update the book by
which which has the id4
and for the body i'm going to again
select raw json and i'm going to
simply copy and paste
this here
and let's change the publication to
orion
so it's updated the book and now the
publication
should have been oh sorry i have to read
put here
the publication will become orion
right so
don't forget to change the methods here
right
and for create the method was post and
for update it is put
right i hope that makes sense
now we can go ahead and delete this book
and for that i'll need the delete method
in my postman
when i send that
you know the book is gone
hopefully
so now there's only one book remain
which is which has an id3 which is
basically zero to one by beta theta
so all our five apis working perfectly
fine and
if you have completed this video and you
have been able to uh code out till this
far
uh congratulations in this video we're
building something very interesting
we're building a slack bot that
calculates age uh using golang
without any delays let's get started so
uh the prerequisites to this video are
that you should have a slack account
right obviously that's how you'll build
a slack bot right so you should have a
slack account you should have a
workspace in your slack and you should
be the admin of that workspace only then
uh you'll be able to build a bot right
in slack and then you have to come to
this link api.slack.com
apps and this is where we'll be able to
start our apps so i'll say create new
app and ask me two different questions
from scratch or from an app manifest so
in this case i'll be building and
building a bot from scratch i'll call it
the
agebot
right and i'll
give it my
workspace
and now uh
we have to find socket mode on the left
is the third button on the left right
socket mode and we have to enable it
and we'll call it socket token so this
will generate an app token for us x app
so when it says xapp it is your app
token and it says xob it's your bot
token right x2 xb it'll be your bot
token so you can make a note of this you
can copy this i won't copy it right now
i'll come back for it later on in the
video
uh so this is your
that was your app token and now let's go
for our
uh event subscriptions which is the
third uh button so the fourth button
from the from the last right and we have
to enable our event subscriptions we
have to subscribe to what events and uh
let's add some events right so events
are basically uh that or something that
our bot uh would be subscribed to so
these are socket events so i'll say app
mentioned whenever somebody mentions my
bot and i'll say
message history and i'll say message.im
right it can read messages
and then messages.channel messages.mpim
right so these are the
uh events that i think my bot uh would
need to be subscribed to uh
but then there's always you can always
come back and tweak them later on if you
by mistake if you leave out any and you
can always uh you know this is mostly
uh you'll get these by trial and error
right so i've built more than 50 slack
bots so
i know and and this is a tip for you as
well that it's always better to add more
events than less because and and also
now uh what we'll do is we'll add uh
oauths and permissions so come to this
uh option above event subscriptions so
oauth and permissions also you have to
add some uh permissions like scopes to
your uh bot
uh these are very similar to your event
subscriptions so here also it's always
recommended uh with even subscription
and with uh oauth information it's
recommended that you add more than you
need because uh most of the errors that
you'll face when building slack bots
would be around uh your bot not having
enough permissions or authorizations or
authentication you know those will be
the kind of errors that you'll face so
it's better to always
uh you know add these so that you don't
have to like deal with a lot of errors
right later on so i'll just add some
regarding chat right and
uh
let's say channels read
right and then say
um
i am read and i am right
these are the items are basically direct
messages
mp i am read and npm right also i'll add
right and i don't think i need any more
um
permissions for now but if i have any
errors then i'll come back here and i'll
add those permissions right and now the
problem with building slack boxes
sometimes they that you don't even get
an error and your ad
you're
uh you know doesn't respond properly or
and it doesn't give you the behavior
that you're expecting it to give you and
and those problems are mostly revolving
around scopes right so there are so many
errors on stack overflow when you go and
you won't find answers to those problems
because uh those most of them are around
scopes those aren't even errors like
people would be saying my slack bot
isn't working and those kind of issues
right so those are all around scopes i
can tell you that from experience
anyhow what we'll do now is we'll
actually click on install this to
workspace
and it'll ask me for some permissions
i'll say allow
so that means now age bot is uh
installed to my workspace
and it has given me a bot user oauth
token right so i need to make a copy of
this as well
uh so now what we'll do is
since we have our
credentials in place
now it's time to
actually start uh
building the bot in golang right so i'm
in my uh directory where i keep most of
my golan code and i'm going to create a
directory for this particular project
called slack age bot
sorry for the wrong spelling of age
and i'm going to go inside
directory
and here what i'm going to say is i'm
going to go mod init github dot com
slash
uphill slash slack
i'll say um
slack age bot is the name of the project
so this is an absolute link that helps
me to
import other files in my project and in
this project particular project we don't
have multiple files we are going to only
get to have the main.go file but if this
was a bigger project then this would
have been very very uh helpful and also
using github.com
uh you know helps helps a lot because
later on if you have to push this to
github and then use it as a package in
your own project later on or somebody
else has to use it as a package in their
project it's very very useful so this is
the best practice uh you can always
innit your
go programs like this
so we'll init and it is taking some time
i don't know why
okay that's done and there is one uh
external package that we need so i have
to run the go get command and the
package that i need is github.com
shoma
lee one one slash slacker
all right
and uh
just to be sure i'll say go mod tidy
okay
and
so we have added the the package that
you want so if we ls right now we'll see
our go modern go some file which is
perfect which is exactly what you want
so now what we'll do is we'll
open up our code editor
which is
uh vs code in our case
in my case uh you can have any other
code editor that you want but vs code
works best for me so i'm going to use
obvious code
and now we'll start writing our code as
you know uh
the main file in a go program is called
main.go and the first thing that you
have to write is
package main then you have to import
some packages i know that i'll be
needing the context package i know i'll
be needing
fmt to print out stuff and log is
something that i'll be needing i'll be
needing
os package
and
the most important thing that i'll be
needing
is the external package that i
installed right so i'll say show molly11
now if you're uh
yeah so if you're uh
coming from a javascript background so
what i did there with goget command is
simply
uh you know uh npm installer it's it's
exactly equivalent so it creates uh
those entries in your go modern go some
file which is almost like your if you're
from a flutter background it's almost
like a pub spec yaml file or popsicle
dot log file and if you're from a uh
node.js background it's from it's like a
uh you know package.json and
package.json.log files you know that's
what these are it's very very similar
concept right
and uh so what we're doing here is we
are going to
uh
write our main function funk main
and in funk main i'm going to set my
environments right so i'll say
uh now you can you know set your
environment in an env file but i'm not
going to do that i'm just going to uh
you know
use my os uh package to actually set
environments and i'll say
slack bot
token
okay comma and here i need to copy and
paste my
slack bot token and then i'll say set
environment
slack app token right so far so good
and now what i'll do is i'll just uh go
ahead and get my
tokens from the
slack
uh this is my bot token so i'll copy
this and i'll paste it here
this is my what token
all right
and
here is my
yeah i'll and to find my
main token i have to come here
this is the socket token that we created
that is our the xapp one that is our
main app token
so i'll say
i'll copy and paste that here as well
so far so good
and now we have to create
a bot
right so we'll say
bought
an assignment operator or the walrus
operator whatever you want to call it
slacker dot
new client
and
we'll say os dot
get
paid environment
this is slack
port
token
and we will say
comma os dot
get
environment
slack app
tool
now uh you don't have to have uh you
know set environment get environment you
can directly pass
the
tokens here directly right inside the
new client uh function but why i'm doing
this is because this makes your program
more extensible so later on when you
have to
extend your program and uh you you have
those environment files or you have a
production environment where you have
these tokens
or you're using some program that
manages all your
credentials
then this comes in very handy so i'm
just getting you in the habit of
you know going
the right way from the beginning
so here we'll start to go routine which
will
uh
it doesn't do any much it just prints uh
command events
so we'll say
command
events
by command events i mean uh the e like
let's say whenever i pass a command to
my slack bot uh so whatever it does or
whatever the the way it handles the
event at the event itself it's going to
print it out right so this means that
print command events needs to be a
function which we have not created right
now so let's create that function so
we'll say func
print
command events
and we'll say analytics
channel
and chan creates a channel and we'll say
slacker dot
command event which basically we're
passing here right
and here we'll say
for
event
we're going to arrange over the
analytics event analysis channel
and we're going to print out a couple of
things so we're going to print out the
timestamp as in when the command was
received by slack right and the command
itself and the parameters that we have
passed to that command and the event
right so let's get started so we'll say
print
ln
and here i'll say
command
events
and then i'll say fmt dot
println and i'll say
event dot timestamp like i said we need
the timestamp
fmp dot
rent ln
event dot
command
and fmt dot print ln
by the way all of this is uh totally
optional you don't have to do all this
like i'm printing out uh in my
console whenever any event takes place
uh in my
program but you don't have to do this
given dot
event
and then
just an empty line we'll put them into
line
print ln
okay
so far so good
now comes the real
uh
function the most important function
but before that we need to write some
code to actually stop our bot cdx cancel
context start
with
cancel
and context
dot
background if you're a golang beginner
i'm sure you already know what context
does and what differ is differ basically
make sure that uh the cancel
uh
is
you know uh all like played or or this
function is called towards the end like
when this function is about to end right
so that's what therefore does
and error is equal to bot.listen
your bottle listen to the context
if
there is an error which means if error
is not equal to null
you're going to log out
the fatal log.fatal fatal is a function
that logs out the error
so we have used our log package that we
had here we've used our os package to
set the environments we've used our fnd
package to print out stuff and all we
need to do now is use the slacker
package
right
uh
now let's create the program
that we need to create
so that program is
bot.com so we have the what we've
created the bot here right
and here we need to say
bot dot
command so this is where the magic is
happening
my year
of birth is
and you pass a parameter inside here so
this with these two
uh angular brackets is the parameter and
you'll say ampersand slacker dot
command definition
and this is the description of the
command
so we'll say
you know
iob
calculator
and just give an example
sorry example
my is
here
2020 all right so this is an example
and then we give it a handler so handler
is where
we handle this uh event using a function
which takes
the bot context slacker dot dot
context
and we
pass it the request so as if whenever we
have any functions that uh you know work
with http kind of data or socket data
you know you have to have request and
response right
and request will be slacker dot request
and response
will be slacker which is the package
again dot
response writer
so uh slacker dot request lack of dos is
responsible we are using the slacker
package here
all right
so everything makes sense till now
i hope everything makes sense to know
it's giving us one error i don't know
where the error is
but anyhow so let's create this error so
we'll say here
is equal to request dot
param
here so whatever here has been passed
so when the user says my yob is here
this uh
param
uh we'll get into a variable call here
right now using this
and then we'll have a variable called
yob
so we'll say string
convert dot ato i here we'll convert
into
here so now this means that i need
another package called
string convert because this is not
native to golang this is a this is
a package in the golang library right so
we have to get string convert
as well
uh
so uh
so far so good so we have our
here in yob
and then if error not equal to nil
we'll say print ln
error
okay
and then we'll say age not equal to
sorry a is equal to
2 0 2 1
minus
y
to calculate h all you have to do is
year of birth has to be subtracted from
the current here that's going on right
now it's 2021.
if you didn't do this right if you don't
use string convert and atoi function
you would have this uh in a string
format and you won't be able to subtract
it here golang won't allow it
so to have a number of took uh to get a
number from string you have to do this
and only then you can perform a
subtraction operation right because
golang is a statically typed uh language
you can't
subtract a string and a sprinter and an
end so we'll say sprint f which formats
our string for us age
is
percentage d
comma h
we'll say response dot
reply
r
so in age we store 21 minus yob which is
the edge and then we format it out like
this with this text and then we reply
this
now i'm getting two errors one is this
so we don't have this package it's
saying
somali
double one we should have had it because
we added it
um
i did add it actually
so let me
say again go get
github.com slash
somali
one one
slash
slacker
it says it has added this package then i
don't know why my
uh vs code is acting up and then uh it
doesn't seem to have any more errors
this is the only error that says uh
there is
there could be an issue with the
spelling though i mean uh now there's no
squiggly line so everything seems to be
all right
um
and then it's giving me a red squiggly
line out here
i don't know why
let me check
so it says bought command
okay yes so my mistake
uh this function definition we can't
close it out here
this needs to be closed somewhere out
here
and here there needs to be comma
now uh
[Music]
there shouldn't be an error now and yes
spelling of command events is wrong
so i've collected that as well
now it's a question about of
i think
counting these
brackets
so i'm just going through it again i
have written the description
i have the command line
the description
and there's the example there's the
handler func
uh request response
then i have the year then i have iob
uh print line age 21
sprint f response reply
everything seems to be all right to me
but uh it seems there's still one error
right so it says in the even dot
parameters there's an issue
yeah that's because the spelling of
parameters is wrong
and now as you can see we don't have any
issues
i'm using a golang plugin that helps me
to find these errors
without actually running the code so
which is very helpful
now what we'll do is we'll say go build
to see if there are any errors there
there seem to be no errors it has
created the dot apc file for us
and uh what we'll do now is we'll head
over to our
uh
slack channel
and here
we will uh
be expecting our
bot once
uh we start the bot right we start the
program
and so let's do that let's actually
start our program so
go run main.go
so it says connected to slack with
socket mode that means everything should
be fine
and so here i'll say agebot
and i'll say agebot
my yob is
1990.
so it says the slackward says that you
mentioned each board but they're not in
this channel so i'll say invite them and
then
uh agebot automatically replies age 31
awesome right so you'll say age bot
my y o b is
1995
let's say age 26
isn't that awesome
so i hope you learned a lot in this
video and
uh you were able to uh you know
understand how to actually apply your
golang skills and how to build a slack
bot right and how to get the tokens from
slack how to add those permissions and
how to enable socket mode all of those
things are really important in building
a slack watch and also this kind of
function and the package that we've used
slacker right that makes making a slack
bot really easy in this video we're
building something very interesting
we're building a slack bot that can
upload files on a slack channel right so
the prerequisites are that you need to
have a slack account obviously and you
need to be the admin of a workspace
basically on slack and then you have to
come to api.slack.com apps now if you
have built slack bots before and you
just want to
know about how to upload files then you
can skip the part where you know i'll
show on how to uh get your bot token and
your app token
and you can skip directly to the part
where uh we start working with golank
or otherwise you can stick around and
see how we need the we can get the
bottom right so uh we're on api.com apps
we'll create new app from scratch
i'll call it filebot
and the workspace is worldtech create
now
i need socket to be enabled
so i'll click on socket mode the third
option
i'll enable it
and i'll call this token the socket
token
generate
so let's generate a token for me
and i don't need this token for this
video i just need the uh what token in
this video
so what we'll do now is we'll actually
go to
even subscriptions and we'll just enable
it as well
even though we won't be using events in
this video but we'll just enable it
anyways
and then we'll go to our oauth and
permissions all right so let's
give it some scopes
so obviously we need to be able to
uh read messages so let's
i'll just say chat write and channels
read
and then
i need files read and files right
and
i'll also say i am reading i am right
now uh if you've watched my other videos
on how to build slack bots the other
videos then you know that i always
recommend going for more scopes than you
need because a lot of the errors on
slack stack overflow around slack bots
have been caused because because of
authorization authentication and
permissions issues right and they all
revolve around the scopes so it's always
uh
good to have more scopes than you think
you would need because
sometimes the slack bots don't even give
you errors so that can be very
frustrating sometimes right so we'll
have remote files read and remote files
share and write also i'll take those as
well
so remote files sorry not remind us
right but remote files
the remote files right and share
okay
now most of these we may not even use
but we are still like i said you know
you're still keeping them
so we have all these uh scopes and it
might so happen that we uh you know um
we might need to add more uh depending
on if our bot is able to perform the
actions that we're expecting it to uh
perform so it's asking me for some
permissions i'll allow it
okay and now you have your slack
watercolor i won't copy it right now but
i'll come back for it
all right and
uh
the other thing that you would need is
your slack channel
id on which you would interact with your
file bot
and i'll show you that as well all right
so now what we'll do is we'll head over
to our powershell or uh you could be on
your mac terminal or ubuntu terminal
doesn't matter the commands will be the
same all right so i'm in the
in the folder where i keep most of my
column code and what i'll do here is
i'll create a directory called slack
file port all right and i'll cd into
slack file bot
and i'll go mod in it
and slap
file what
this is my absolute link if you if
you're very new to golang this is your
absolute link with the help of which
you'll be able to uh refer refer other
files in your project in this project
particular project we are going to have
only one file main.go but if this was a
much larger project uh then we would
have to uh you know write multiple files
and github.com because once you upload
your project to github you might want to
use it as a package in your other
projects right so it's always a good
practice to have your absolute link like
set up like this so this is a good
practice we'll go mod in it and
it has created a go mod file so if ls
you'll be able to see your go mod file
right and then uh you need a an external
package to be able to work with slack so
we
are going to import that now if you're
from a javascript background you would
recognize this as your npm in it and you
would recognize this as your npm install
so don't we are just installing an
external package
so we will call it github.com
right so this person uh just like us
this person had given github.com link so
that you know now we are able to access
his
library very easily
into our project so we will get that
so it has hopefully added
the
slack go slash package
and what we'll do is
just to be sure we'll also run go mod id
and says all match no packages no issues
everything works perfectly
and now what we'll do is we'll open up
our code editor so i'm using this code
you could be using any other collateral
no problem
and
just
another pointer i'm also using a
golang
plugin in my vs code that helps me write
better code so i'll leave the name of
that in the description box below
but even if you just search for
extensions uh golang extension you'll
find it it's not it's not something very
rare everybody uses it so we are in our
vs code and i've opened up a file called
main.go which is uh what the main file
in golang program is called in case
you're new to golan the first thing that
you write in a golang program is package
main and then you import some
libraries and then you have something
called respond right so these are the
things that are uh the most important in
a
golang program and uh
i know that i'll be needing fmp to print
out stuff so the format package has uh
things that are required to print out
stuff to the terminal
then i know i need the os package to set
and get my environments and i know that
i need the external package that i just
installed called slackgo to
help me talk to the slack apis right
now slack go is a rapid library that
somebody has written around the slack
apis in golang so that we can call uh
the funk the golang the slack
apis as functions rather than as actual
api so we don't have to make network
requests to the slack api because
somebody has already
written wrapper functions around it and
we just have to call those functions
uh using this library right so that
makes our job extremely easy and then
you can uh
create a variable called api and it will
have slack dot name
so using this package now slack and
we're creating a new connection we are
calling it
and here we will get uh
you know uh something from our
environment and it will basically be our
slack
token
now uh ideally you would have an
environment file right or if you're in
production environment you would have uh
that those the environment set up to
have these variables but since we don't
have it
set up what we'll do is we'll actually
set our environment right now using the
set env
you don't have to do it you can directly
pass your bot token here but i do this
because this makes the code uh very
extensible and you can
extend it later on if you in case you
want to go to production
uh like i said we don't want to go to
production right now but if you wanted
to you
could
because we're keeping everything
uh modular right so uh here we'll put at
what token and also one more thing that
i need
uh like i said is the
channel id on which uh the bot will be
able to
uh
write the upload the file okay
so here i'll have something called as
channel
uh
and this will be my channel basically
it's also string
and os dot
get environment
inside that we'll have our channel id
all right
and then i'll have my file
file arr
string
and here i'll put the name of my file
you know whatever i wanted to be
so
now let's go back to our uh
google chrome and get our slack bot
token and channel ids
so
slack bot tokens this is my bot token so
i'll copy it
and i'll paste it here
okay
and now we'll have our
channel id
and i need to get to my channel id
so this i wanted to post it out also on
the general channel so i'll say
i'll right click on the general channels
i'll say
open channel details
then towards the end you'll find the
channel id which is
this
okay
and then i'll go back here and i'll
paste it here
makes sense
so now we have set our environment for
our slack buttock and slack and channel
id
and
we uh
sorry
yeah and then
we have our
uh
you know
uh variables api channel and file which
have the api connection with slack and
then
uh the channel and then the file that
will be
sending out uploading basically
and now we'll create a for loop
so uh right now we have only we'll have
only one file here but we could have
multiple files right so we have to uh go
over all of the
files that exist in this variable in the
slice right
so in the slice all the files that are
there we'll say i plus plus
and
say programs
slack dot
file
upload parameters so this is a function
that
slack
gives us
and it will have two parameters
okay and
we'll take that into of our own variable
called params so the two parameters are
channels
where i'll
pass the channel
in which i want to
upload the file and i'll pass the file
itself
which will in this case be
file a r
i
right because we are looping over file
arr which
uh in the for the sake of this video
will have only one file but you could
have multiple file here files here like
hundreds of files and then you could
loop over them and then you could uh you
know send them here all right so put a
comma here because it's giving me some
formatting errors
so
i'll
say
api dot upload file
with the params
all right so i have my param set here
with channel and file and i'm going to
call the function called upload file uh
in my connection the slack api right and
i'm going to
uh take that into a variable called file
or it's going to return an error to me
and so i'll check for the error so if
error is not equal to nil that means
there is an error i'll print it print
out
fmt dot
printf
i'll say percentage s
new line
comma error
all right and we'll save it on
and then
we'll print out
the name and url of the file so let's
say
name
percentage s
url
percentage s new line
so
this is a very short simple program
and
even though i've added
slack i don't know why it's giving me
shoes
[Music]
i don't know why there's a
squiggly line and
shows one error
even though i had actually
got my
import the package
so this sounds
this looks a bit off to me
uh but yeah everything else in the
program looks okay to me where uh let me
just go through it again so that uh you
know we're able to minimize
uh the errors
so there's the channel
id and slack dot new
slack
oh yeah so here we have to just uh pass
the file so you can copy any file that
you want and i'm going to just copy and
paste a file called
zipl
uh dot pdf
all right so i'm going to pass here
is that apple.pdf
but you could have any file out there
and
after that everything else looks
pretty all right to me
so i don't know why there's a squiggly
line here even though i've
installed the package
what i'll do is i'll again run
go get github accounts like
slash slack
so i'll again add it and now hopefully
the error should go i'm not sure
yeah now it's gone weird right
anyways so let's uh run our code let's
build our code at least to see if there
are any errors in runtime there are no
errors so we will say go run
main dot go and at the same time we have
to keep our slack channel open right so
here in the general channel is where i'm
expecting the file to come up right so
i'll say
go run main dot co and let me head over
to my slack channel and see if the file
comes here
i don't see the file yet
says not in channel
so this looks like
an error to me
uh and i'm pretty sure it has something
to do with the permission so let me
uh go over to my
uh
slack
terminal and slack dashboard and see
what these
so back in my
slack dashboard or my channel
i think the issue could be that
the file bot is not part of the channel
right so what i'll do is i'll try
mentioning filebot
and so it says want to add this question
instead
isn't in general yet so i'll say add to
channel
so file bot was added by kil sharma
and
now
what we'll do is we'll run our code
again and see what happens
and let's go back see it was able to add
the file it was able to upload the file
so it works perfectly
so you'll have to add your file bot to
the channel before it can start
pushing files to this channel right
and if you see this error it's not very
helpful right so it's not in channel i
mean what the hell does that mean and
i've uh you know had so many errors in
the past like i've built more than 50
slack bots like are there on production
on you can get them on the app store at
the slack app store uh marketplace and
then uh the thing is
it's so frustrating to build a slackbot
because most of the time the errors are
around like i told you the scopes right
and
uh because you're trying to do something
and you don't have that particular scope
selected and then it won't even give you
the right error it'll just say
uh you don't have uh the authorization
or you don't have the permission
something like that but it won't tell
you uh what permission you don't have
so it can get really confusing so just
make sure you add more scopes than you
need and whatever scopes you think you
might need you can obviously add them
and don't be shy and just add as many
scopes as possible just add all of them
probably
you know it's not like you're going to
share your
tokens with anybody else right uh like
delete so for example i just made this
uh test uh uh app i'll just delete this
uh what after uh the video is over
and uh
now if you're going to into production
obviously if you're launching a slack
bot to the marketplace then obviously
you need to think about what are the
exact scopes that you need and you can
remove the ones that you don't need to
make it more secure but otherwise
while testing it while learning go ahead
and do whatever you want right in this
video we're doing something really
interesting we are building an email
verifier tool
so if you search for email verifier tool
on google you get all these different
options right hunter dot io snow dot io
zero bounce never bounce
and all these tools like let's say if
you open up snow bio and if you open up
email address verifier
all these tools are quite expensive and
some of some of them even say that well
didn't check in real time right uh they
try to sound really fancy but what's
happening here is really straightforward
it's there's nothing fancy happening
there only in some tools like let's say
um hunter dot io they use a little bit
of machine learning here and there to uh
you know
determine uh basically to make the tool
even better and more enhanced but
otherwise most of them are just using
very simple uh tools to
uh create an email verify tool so
if you wanted to you could uh simply
take this program that we'll build right
now and you can just launch your own
email wi-fi tool if you want to i mean
completely optional all right so we'll
use golang nothing fancy we won't have
bulk uh verification um
ability right now in this program it's
very simple you can extend this the
functionality of this program to include
bulk uh checking as well and in the
future uh a few weeks from now i'll
actually build a complete uh you know
like a complete solution for email
verification
all right so this is just a precursor
this is a very simple program that
you're building right now but a few
weeks from now i'll build a complete
project around it all right where you
can
uh also do bulk checking and you know
there'll be a more there'll be a few
more checks right now we're doing a
couple of checks but there will be few
more checks
all right so let me show you how the
program is going to work
i am now in my terminal and
what i'll do is i'll start the program
and mind you this program is super
simple so it won't take us more than 20
25 minutes to actually build this whole
thing right it's very very
straightforward
so if you go down main.go
it shows you these options it says that
when you uh enter a domain name right
now it will give you the domain names
name and will check for mx records spf
records if it has any fcf records if it
does then we'll give you the spf records
if it has any demarc records and we'll
give you the democratic calls all right
and by checking these then we'll know uh
if the domain is at least right from
which that email id is come out from to
which you have to send the emails to
right you'll just check the domain if
the it even has any imax records
so that's like the first stage the first
check of any email looking up or any
email verification that checking if that
domain name even has an mx recorder an
spf record as a democrat record right so
that you can know at least you know
there are mx servers set up there a mail
server set up there all right so uh here
let's say you write mailchimp
dot com
so this is like uh irony because these
guys uh help people send emails and we
are building a tool using their website
to check if
they have any
valid uh you know email records
so let's enter that it'll take a while
because mailchimp has done a lot of
clever things to uh you know
not respond straight in a
straightforward manner so i'll say that
uh the request has timed out right it
says uh this operation returned because
the timeout period expired but it'll
give you still give you the right
records it'll give you mailchimp.com
which is the domain
does it have a mx record that says yes
true it does does it have spf records
false so that means spf records uh
there's you can see this there's a blank
here that means uh since there's no spf
records it won't return the spf records
obviously does it have dmarc it'll say
true and demarcus records this these are
the mark records all right
so now you know that mailchimp.com is a
valid email people it's like emails have
been set up on this record and now you
can start looking for the names of the
people and then actually finding email
addresses of those people if you wanted
to right like i said a few weeks down
the line we'll build the entire product
right now we're just building like uh
you know just telling people if the the
email is real or not just like something
like uh you know
this this tool out here called email
hippo you
write something like you know akil at
the rate mailchimp.com
and the first thing is going to check is
what we just checked right now does it
have mx records uh spf records or dmacc
records if it doesn't we'll just say
that this email address is not valid
obviously because the domain itself is
not valid right the one itself does not
have any mx record setup
but here in this case it'll say true
because in our case also it returned
true
so i'm not sure if this is yeah so it's
saying the result is bad because yes the
email address does not exist but
uh probably it's saying that this exists
but this email
on this this person on this domain does
not exist something like that right
so anyways so you get the picture of
what we're building and now let's start
building it like i said there's no
external library used here we're just
using like the basic golang packages
that you get so if you know even basic
golang if you just completed the golang
tour if even if you don't know that
actually
uh you can you can still complete this
project so this is like a
you know simple uh
like a beginner level project so feel
free to follow along with me all right
now since this is a beginner level
project i won't explain a lot of things
there's not much to explain anyways i
won't explain a lot of things uh feel
free to code along with me if you don't
understand anything look it up on the
internet or put it in the comments below
i'm always there to help you out right
but it'll be really simple right so it's
i mean there's nothing complicated here
we're not using go routines we're not
using channels we're not using
even structs we're not using uh
interfaces nothing like that it's just
like plain simple colang all right so
let's get started
what i now want you to do is open up
your new terminal
and
traverse to the
path where you usually keep your golang
code and create a new directory
let's say like email checker tool
cd into it
and open up using your favorite code
editor in my case it's vs code
and here
there's not much in this project right
it's just main.go
so
you'll start with package main
you'll import some things
obviously we'll talk about them in a
while
and then there's yours there's your uh
funk main right the most important
function in any golang program
funk main basically calls another
program called
funk
check domain
all right
and this function just takes in
a domain
so essentially all you're entering uh
that you just saw in the demo or you're
entering is the domain name right so
that domain name basically gets passed
passed from our uh terminal using funk
main something we'll write in our funk
main we'll pass it and we'll just push
it or send it to our check domain
function which will do all the magic all
right the packages that i need here
i need buffalo
the buffer package to to be able to
parse whatever i put in the
terminal
i need fmt to print out stuff
log as well
need a net package to make those
requests os and strings
once we use these packages it will make
more sense to you why we're using it
so firstly you'll create a variable
called scanner
and you'll use the buffer package
and there's a function called new
scanner
that you'll use okay
and here you'll say
printf
and the things that we're printing out
when the program started will be
basically domain
has
mx
has spf
and if it has spf then it'll show you
the spf records
then we'll check it has the mark
and then we'll check for the mark
record
okay
so if you remember when we started the
program it just showed us these things
so that we come to know in the order
which will in which the information will
be shown to us okay
so it's exactly the same thing
and now
for you to scan
the information
you'll use scanner.scan function
and you'll
so let's say there are multiple
items to be scanned you'll
now i i know i said that there's no no
bulk uploading uh as in bulk checking
but you can check like a few uh you know
emails but when i say bulk uh checking i
mean like like uploading big csvs of
thousands of records and then checking
them in one go right that's what we
don't have but like multiple checking is
there all right i hope that makes sense
so you have scanner dot
text
so uh whatever was
typed by you in the
power shell or in the
terminal
is now basically sent to the check
domain function one by one so multiple
domains if
you know if you want to
or it's just a single domain mostly
i have tested only on single domain so
please um if you know there's a there
are problems working with multiple
domains then uh you know it's only
because i've not tested it i've just
associated with a single single domain
so start the program and just put a
single domain like mailchimp.com like i
showed you in the demo so it just works
perfectly fine for that i've tested only
for that
and then we have like i said this is not
a production level software right
i said like you can put it on your
website as a small simple free email
checker tool but don't like charge
people for it because you don't have uh
the complete architecture required for
it to be a complete production software
right
i hope that's clear
because i i get strange uh
comments sometimes so that's why i just
you know clarify all these things
so to um log out the error now if
there's an error obviously uh then we're
just logging out the error so the error
is
could not read
from input
comma error
so if you notice all that we have done
in the funk main is just pick up or scan
the user's input from the terminal all
right the domain name that you've put
and if it's not able to scan it properly
whatever domain name that you put is
going to say could not read from input
right it's going to print out an error
and what we are sending to this check
domain function is the text and that
whatever you've
posted in the terminal
and now the check domain is the is the
part where
which is basically the meat of this
entire program because this function
will have all the logic
required to actually check those records
okay
so firstly we'll define some variables
the first variable will be has mx
has spf
has d mark
all of these are boolean
then we'll have the spf record
i mean if it has an spf record then
we'll show the spf record right like in
our case when we uh did a demo with
mailchimp
there was uh this was false so that's
why we didn't have any spf record it was
blank
and if there's an uh dmark tool like we
had did for mailchimp we had democtool
we'll have remark record here and
it'll be a string
all right
now we'll all be doing here basically is
using the net package
to firstly look up the mx
so the net package already gives you
um the ability to look up the mx of the
domain that you just sent here domain is
that string that you're passing to this
function all right
and
whatever comes back from this function
we captured in a variable called mx
records
and this function if there's anything
that goes wrong will also return an
error
and now you're getting these quickly
lines because you've defined all these
variables but you've not used it
right
so what we'll do now is we'll say
if error
not equal to nil
this error basically will handle on this
line
log dot
printf
error
percentage v comma
error
and we will check for
length
and extra chords
greater than zero
is equal to
so
you looked up the mx for the domain
using the net package and there's a
function called lookup mx that you get
in that net package
and you got the mx records
or
optionally you must have got the error
so if you got the error which means
error not equal to net
you'll just print out the error
and if you got back the mx records
then you'll check if the length of the
mx records is greater than zero
if obviously if it's greater than zero
that means that mx
that this domain has mx records so we'll
set mx is equal to true has mx is equal
to true okay so this has been used
now comes the txt records
which are your spf records okay so we'll
use
net dot lookup
txt package
so here um i just want i wanted to
observe how easy these kind of things
are with a language like golang
if you want to do the same with uh
node.js for example you will have to use
an external npm right something like
that
um
i mean i'm a node.js user i've been
using it since many many years now i
have uh built multiple products with
node.js
so um i should have nothing against
node.js but actually i do so i do have a
lot of cloud against node.js because to
do something as simple as this you have
to uh you know do a lot you have to do a
lot of bending uh in case you know a
better way to do this with node.js do
reply in the comments and to share it
with me i don't know but with golang
it's super simple right you don't have
to install any external package there's
all these are you know the standard
golang packages that you're using right
now
and that's insane right a language that
has so much support out of the box
it's just killer
this is that's why you know it's the
language i use the most right now
uh so here also you look up the texture
codes which are basically your spf
records right so if uh similarly you'll
check for the error so if you say you'll
say if error not equal to nil then
you'll do something here so you'll say
log dot
printf
error percentage v
slash and comma error
and
then what you'll do is you'll
you'll range over these records so
range by by ranging over if you're very
new to golang i basically mean like
using a for loop to go over all the
values okay so we'll go over
the text records
and the right syntax for that is for
and records so
this is going to be your iterator and
this is going to be your uh every single
value that you'll have access to with
the help of range records so inside your
text records you'll range over them and
every single value inside that text
records you'll have access to it using
this variable called record and here you
could have used the
iterator like i or j or something like
that but since we don't want to use it
we put a blank character here because in
golang you can't just define something
and then not use it okay that's why you
have to use blank characters
so here we'll use the strings
package provided by golang again by
default
and you'll
use the record
record is basically every single value
like i told you from this text records
once you range over it every single
value can be accessed using record so
we're passing strings.hash prefix in
that function we're passing uh the
record
and we're checking if this uh it has
been represented like this so usually
the spf records
in your text records right all your txt
records and that you want to find or
search the spf one records okay if the
way they represented so if you go to
your let's say your godaddy or your name
cheap
you'll see that you'll you have these
dxj records and they will look like this
they'll have like a v is equal to spf
one
and so you'll
obviously
set the spf has spf is equal to true
and then you'll also
have your spf
record which will be set equal to the
record now
and then you'll just break away
from this program
so a few minutes into the program we
have already checked for
the mx records and spf records all we
now need to check for
are the
dmacc records
now to check for the democracy calls
we will again
use the net
dot
look up
txt
but we'll check for
dmarc plus the domain
domain again is that same variable that
was
passed into this function
and
here we'll say
dmarc
records comma error
so whatever is coming back from this
function
the function is lookup text that you
have already used in the net package
you're passing domain plus the dmac
record to check if you know you're
looking up the remark records using the
same function
and whatever you're getting back you're
either getting an error or you're
getting the dmac records
so we'll check for the error so if error
not equal to nil
say log dot printf
and we'll print out the error
and otherwise we'll range over
the dmacc records
to do that you have to follow the same
kind of a syntax
and here you start to say if strings dot
has prefix
record comma v is equal to d mark
one
so you're doing you're following the
same uh method process there's no change
here
all right
same process and here instead of record
spf 1 we're saying dmacc one
and if it does then we'll say has the
mark has become equal to 2 true
and dmarc
record
value is equal to the record value
and then you break away
and
at the end
you'll just print out all the results
right so you have to use the printf
method
and to print out the values so you'll
say um
i'll put the percentages later on
percentage vs later on
the values that i want to print out to
the terminal our domain has
mx
has
spf
i have this reference right domain has a
mix has this we have all these this was
just text and here we're actually
pushing out like printing out those
values
but in the same order spf record comma
has
daymark
comma d mark
record
so how many
v's do we have to put here one two three
four five six so let's say percentage v
comma percentage v comma percentage v
comma
delta v comma percentage v
so it's five now and then the last one
is six
six percentage v and this whole function
is complete
now all we have to do is test this
function and
we know that we'll get some errors and
then we have to solve those other errors
and everything will work
to actually find the errors and see if
it's working we'll have to actually run
it on our terminal so here i'll say go
run main.go
and as you can see it's working so i'm
surprised that there are no errors it's
working everything's working fine let's
try entering
mailchimp.com again
i've tried it with many of the websites
like mailchimp and sendgrid send in blue
all of those main big
uh email
sending tools
you can try more um
domain here actually any domain you try
you can try it here
so this as you know the request will
time out after a while and then we'll
get those results
and if it doesn't give you any results
then
that means there's some error with our
program
but i'm hoping it'll give some
output
yeah so we have got that output that
timeout be expired and then you know you
get your dot com true false true and you
get the d marked records
okay so i hope you enjoyed this program
uh this project this is a very small
simple project but
you know obviously
it's a nice flex you can flex in front
of your friends
you built like an email verifier tool
all right in this video we're building a
very simple aws lambda function using
golang so aws lambda is a serverless
technology where basically you create
functions and you host them on the cloud
and you only pay for usage so whenever
only somebody uses your functions only
then you pay for them so there are a lot
of use cases for serverless it's a
growing technology everybody's uh
shifting their stacks and hashtags to
serverless these days
and uh it's a very i found it to be a
very good fit for let's say if you're
building an mvp because you don't know
if there will be traffic coming to that
product right it's not a proven product
so you don't know if there's any traffic
that's going to come to it
so that kind of uh you know um at least
ensures that you don't have to keep
paying for your servers right you only
pay when somebody uses your product
um and a lot of people use it throughout
the development life cycle like they uh
throughout the product cycle life cycle
right like uh right from uh the pro poc
to the mvp to actually scaling because
the scaling uh in serverless uh using
lambdas is very easy because you
actually don't have to
uh write any like huge configs right you
don't have to create servers everything
is done automatically for you on the
cloud
uh so it's a completely managed fully
managed service you don't have to do a
lot basically right so you just have to
focus on the business logic which is
just creating your functions and
everything else is taken care of
by the cloud it's also very cheap to use
because you're not paying for the
servers right you're only paying when
somebody uses your programs or functions
so if you're building an api that's
going to be
you know exposed to the world and the
world is going to and
there are many more developers who are
using your api then aws lambda is again
a very good use case for that
now there are a few drawbacks to using
aws lambda for example uh there's cold
start wherein you know if you're if
somebody's using your lambda and
basically the lambda takes a while to
start so that's called as a cold start
because there's a slight delay there
sometimes uh so they've tried to reduce
it but it's still there i feel uh cold
start problem is still there so so
drawbacks will always be there but it's
a it's a very good technology
everybody's kind of adopting it
everybody's using it it's widely used
very popular it's important right so
it's important to learn and so that's
why i wanted to create this video uh
which is the basic uh creating a very
basic co-lang function and then
deploying it as a lambda function in aws
now uh you will find a lot of videos
where people use the gui the aws gui to
deploy a lambda function but in in my
case in this case i'll be using aws cli
because i did not find many uh tutorials
actually i didn't find any tutorial on
youtube which uses aws cli to deploy uh
golang lambda function all right so
that's why i thought
let me create one because i don't use uh
the
aws gui a lot i use the aws cli all
right so now there are two prerequisites
to this video one is that you should
know the very basics of golang and
actually even if you don't know the very
basics of golang i'll explain line by
line the whole program to you it's a
very small program so that's probably
not a big prerequisite the second one is
important second one is that you should
have aws cli installed and configured on
your laptop or on your whatever desktop
machine whatever that you're using right
so that's that's kind of important you
need to have aw cli installed because
like i said you know i'll be showing you
the aws cli approach not the aws
gui approach because that's something
that many people have covered already
right aws cli i find it to be quicker
faster and uh you don't have to like
leave your window
and if you're a nerd like me like
obviously you like working on your
terminal you don't want to
use gui right now for uh now the next
video that i'll create after this will
be a complete serverless stack that will
be creating right we will create apis
that can be exposed to the public
and those we'll create using lambda
dynamodb and api gateway that's a
complete serverless stack that's in the
video that's coming up soon
in that case since
i don't want to create very complex
config files i'll use the aws gui to
deploy the lambda functions and to
actually configure my api gateway um but
only because the config files are going
to be very very complex like yaml files
so that's why i want to do it
on the gui and not from
and not write those yaml files so that's
why uh here because uh it's kind of easy
i'll just use my
cli all right i hope that makes sense
and
even in the upcoming video i'll create
uh config files if you want me to i'll
show you how to do that but i kind of
prefer going the gui route in a project
that's a little more complicated all
right that's just my personal preference
so
having said that let's get we'll have to
get started now a lot of talking has
happened so this is my terminal and uh
you don't you don't necessarily need to
um
keep the project in a folder where your
golang is installed right like go path
and go route could be somewhere else you
can have the project anywhere else
doesn't matter because we'll be using
the uh like like we always do right the
golang 1.12 uh the
the format that came after golang 1.12
which was basically
uh you know using co mod in it right
which can initialize your go mod file
anywhere it doesn't have to be in the
root or path
so but uh usually also i i prefer
keeping it in the go root and go path
because i've been a golang developer for
a very long time so that's why i prefer
keeping it there but you can keep it
anywhere right so because i'm i'm saying
this because i get a lot of questions on
youtube saying that hey my go path is
you know configured like this where i'm
keeping my project like this is that
okay and do i need to keep my project in
guru so the answer to that is you don't
have to do all of that you can you know
keep it anywhere i i keep
my projects in the go root most of the
times because
that's how i've been doing it since very
long time before even before golang 1.12
was there right so you don't have to do
it i mean um
you know the go modern it takes care of
everything you don't have to do anything
so let's create a new directory so we'll
say lambda
yt example
okay
and so we'll cd into it lambda yt
example
and here we'll just say go mod in it
and
to initialize i'll say github.com slash
akil slash
um
go lambda function
lambda
function
three okay because i've created many
lambda functions on my
aws account so i just need to be sure
that this is a different lambda function
all together
all right now this is
my project file project name
and i don't have to keep the same name
as my lambda function that i declare in
my aws but i'm just for consistency's
sake and that's what i'm going to do i'm
going to have this name the same exact
name in my aws uh lambda console as well
when i declare the function all right
uh so there are two parts to this video
uh as in the video will be one but then
i'm dividing it in two parts like
contextually the first part where i'll
be building the golang function with you
which will be a simple function and the
second part where we'll deploy that
we'll we'll do the aws configuration
parts the second part is slightly
uh where you need to pay more attention
uh because that's where all the magic
happens and the first part is just
creating the golang
file so if you want to go quickly
through the first part no problem uh you
know just make sure that you slow down
in the second part where i actually show
you how to deploy uh the golang
functions because there are a lot of
caveats there a lot of different you
know working parts there
and uh one small mistake will completely
mess up your entire deployment all right
so
now what we'll do is we'll open up our
code editor i'm using vs code you could
be using anything else
and let me bring uh
vs code here
all right and here all i have to do is i
just have to create a main.go file and
we'll be just using one dependency in
this entire project that is it all right
so this program is going to be short and
we're going to code a bit quickly in
case you're new to golang main.gov file
is
basically the entry point into the
project and in this program since it's a
very small and simple program we have
only one file which is the main.go file
right
and
the way main.go file starts with is you
write package main on top and you import
a couple of packages here other packages
that you want to use in this file
and you have
the most important function from uh
where basically the control of this
project program starts which is the funk
main all right
and
sorry
i need two packages one is called the
fmt package and the other is called
uh the lambda packet so i'll say aws
slash aws
dash
lambda dash co slash
lambda
all right
and we need that lambda package
obviously
because we're creating a lambda function
and fmd basically helps us if you need
to go lang again fmt basically helps us
with some basic functions like printing
and all right so golang is very modular
even printing is not there
in golang so you have to import a
package
which is a native package by the way for
uh printing stuff
right
and
all we're going to say here is we're
going to say lambda dot start
and that
so lambda is basically this package that
we have imported and start as a function
that that package gives us and here
we'll say lam handle lambda
event which is a function that we are
passing to this function all right so
this means that handle lambda event is a
function that we'll have to create here
so we'll create that function and lambda
event
and it accepts some things and it
returns something right so what does it
accept except it accepts an event
so we'll say my
event
and
it returns a response
it can also return an error if there's
an error
and here we'll just basically return
response right
now let's define what response and event
are so we'll say type
this my event and my response are two
things that we'll define here
so my event
is basically a struct
similarly with my response
is again a struct so in case you're new
to golang structs are basically your own
data types that you can create which are
a combination of multiple different data
types all right so if i'm creating a
data type called my event it's going to
have
name which is a string
and json
what is your name
by the way i have more than 100 golang
videos on my channel so if in case
you're planning to learn golang do take
a look
there are a lot of different type of
projects and the way i teach golang is
that i basically
show you how to build projects and not
just teach the basics right
so it has just two things name and age
all right event
so string which is basically what is
your name and
end which is how old are you and it's
going to store um an integer which will
be the age out here all right
and your my response duct will just have
message which will be a string and it
will be
json
and
answer
okay in case you're wondering why we
have to define json like that we're just
you know defining
that for the purpose of golang golang
understands string and end it doesn't
understand json right
but what we're going to send
when we invoke our lambda function
we're going to send jsons to it right so
that's why we have defined how it's
going to look in json
so
here
in
my response you already know that my
response consists of message so it will
say message
fmt dot sprint f is a function that
helps you to format your strings
and
you'll say percentage s is percentage d
here's
old
now you have to substitute percentage s
and so you'll pass those values here so
you'll say event dot
name
comma event dot h
so event will have the name is let's say
john
and how old are you will be the age
so uh all you get in the response when
we invoke this lambda function is we get
john which is percentage s percentage
string right the name
is uh 32 years old or whatever like
whatever you want to
send here
and here
for the error
you would want to pass nil
because it passes response and error so
for the error we are saying
send nil for now
and this is what the entire program is
about i mean that's it 24 lines
even if you remove these spaces it
becomes even less but i won't remove
that space so it becomes like let's say
20.2 lines that's it that's all we're
going to test right now right so that
you basically come to know what lambda
is how it works and then once you're
comfortable with it then uh we'll build
the entire serverless stack project all
right
so
now is a good time to go back to our
terminal and we'll start doing some
operations here
now i'm obviously assuming that you
already have aws cli setup
right
and now there are three things that you
want to do
in the beginning itself now these three
commands that i'll show you here
are from the official lambda deployment
documentation so if you open the lambda
documentation for aws deployment
documentation you'll see these things
these exact same steps right so this is
nothing new uh and i'll copy and paste
these in the description box below as
well so that you can copy and paste them
and also there's and you can easily find
them on the internet so
you don't have to worry too much about
it
the first command that we're going to
paste here
is basically a command that creates a
role name
right called lambda x
which will have the right role policy
documents and that's what will basically
allow you to
access lambda
on your aws account all right uh so when
i press enter in my case it it should
give me an error saying that this has
already been set up for my uh account
ideally that's what yeah so it says an
error code
uh it already exists right now the
second thing that you need to do
is you need to go back to your function
here and you need to create a file
called trust
policy.json and this is something that
lambda requires
right to be able to trust the program
that you've created
so
i'm going to copy and paste some json
code here
and i'll share this code with you in the
description box as well
so that's all you have to do now these
two steps like i said are directly from
the lambda documentation
now there are there's another third
this is the third command that you need
to now
put in your terminal
i'm not sure why it's not coming just
one second
yeah so this is basically pointing uh to
the trusspolicy.json
document saying that this is the you
know rule policy document here
all right so in this case also should
give me an error because i've already
done it
all right
it's already exists
and now there's another another command
so there are four commands till now
right
so this fourth command also is very
similar
there's some issue with copying and
pasting that i'm facing right now
so all that these functions are doing
are helping you to basically set up your
policies and roles and permission all of
those things all right
so now that the basic
work is done
and now
golang won't basically
sorry aws won't stop you from uploading
and deploying your lambda function now
because you have already
the trust policy document
so all you have to do now is you have to
build
your main.go file so you'll say go build
main dot go
so it says that um i have not installed
this package so i'll say go mod tidy
first
this is what's really great about golang
because it doesn't make let you make any
mistakes right so you'll say go build
main.go
so it's built the
so as you can see this main right this
is the executable file which we want to
uh send to lambda now before you send or
upload anything to lambda you need to
have that file
as a zip file
so you'll say
zip function.zip and you're going to zip
the main
project right so now if i ls
they'll have this function.zip which is
the name of the file right so we will
call zip now it's possible that your
particular ubuntu terminal doesn't have
this function called zip right so if
you're on ubuntu it's very easy it's i
think it's just sudo apt install
zip and similarly if you're on
powershell or on
powershell it's also easy i think you
can use the choco installer now package
installer and on
mac you can use homebrew to install zip
and that's straightforward as in it just
takes your main executable file and
zips in into a file called function.zip
and that's the one that you want to
upload
now comes the most important
function
right
so
i'll paste this function here and then
we'll have to change the name of the
function
not sure why i'm not able to
copy and paste it easily
some issue
wait
actually i just bring out my notepad
because i need to make changes to that
uh program right so this is the entire
uh function that we want to basically um
the entire command that we want to run
right now and all it does is it
basically creates a lambda function and
it gives the function a name
and what we are saying is that this is
the zip file function.zip
and handler is basically main inside
that zip file is main executable file
and the runtime that you need is golang
1.x
all right and here the name of my
function is actually
something else so that's what i need to
just
verify
go lambda function 3 that's the name of
my function so i'll say go
lambda
function
3
all right
so i'll just copy and
paste this command here and i'll run it
everything seems fine right now
one more thing that i forgot to mention
is that this is my particular amazon
account id
you need to replace this
number with your
account id all right
otherwise this program won't work
it's taking a while
because it has to create that lambda
function also has to upload that
function.zip file so it will take a
while
and then the last command that we'll
build we'll be running will basically be
for invoking that function
so
in the meantime while this function is
running
just
copy and paste that other function here
that we'll use to invoke
so as you can see what's happening here
is it's basically this function this
command will invoke your lambda function
in my case the lambda function is called
go
lambda
function
3 right
and so this uh
part this i found from stack overflow
this is not in the documentation if you
don't do this and you pass json in the
payload because you have to pass json in
the payload right
we have to pass json in the payload
because that's how our request and
response will work it'll be what is your
name how old are you
right and sorry let me just make this
full screen yeah so what is your name
is jim and how old are you as 33 right
that's how our function is structured in
case
you don't remember
this is what is your name and how old
are you and the answers for that is jim
and 33
and whatever happens
like let's say even if there's an error
or the response will be formed in a file
called output.txt
all right and if you don't so this is
something that i didn't found find in
the um
lambda documentation decide to find from
uh stack overflow because when i was
passing my json i was getting some
errors so just make sure you write this
little you know text here
and so this is your program now if you
see here if this has stopped
you know this is basically deployed and
everything seems to be fine and it's
giving you the latest version
so your lambda is deployed
and now you'll just say control c
and now you want to just pass the last
command
let's try and invoking it and seeing
what happens
something wrong with my copy and paste
let me actually
start another terminal
i will see it into the directory
is called uh lambda
something like that right sorry yeah
user
cd lambda
and
yt example
and here
yeah so this is the exact project that
we're in and here is where i'll just
run this command
you don't have to necessarily run this
command here inside this project
directory but i'm just doing it
because of habit
so again it'll take a while to
invoke so it took about four five
seconds to invoke i say status score 200
and execute latest version which is
called as dollar latest
now how do we know
uh that everything worked fine because
we need to check for this file called
output.txt so we told our lambda that
you invoke this function and whatever
output that you get by sending this
payload into the function you write that
in a file called output.txt so that's
what the file we need to look for so as
you can see this there's a new file
called output.txt here you click on it
and you say that jim is zero years old
which is
wrong because it should have been 33. so
that means our program is misfiring i
need to just check for that now
so we'll just go through our code
quickly and see the issue
the issue seems to be
out here because there's no question
mark here so when we're
passing this here right
as a question mark or just remove this
question mark for now
for now just remove this question mark
because if we remove add a question mark
here we'll have to redeploy this entire
function by uh you know zipping it right
so for now let's just change our
invoking function and copying it
and pasting it again here
and let's see what that what happens
so we'll wait for it
it has
uh completed
the execution
now it shows jim is 33 years old right
so what's happening here is basically
it's matching this completely properly
like even if there's an extra question
mark it won't read this value right so
just make sure uh these both statements
they match
and that's the only error that i got and
everything else seems to be working fine
so that's it you know that's your
complete
lambda function
and deployed to the cloud when now when
somebody uses it or you use it only then
you have to pay for that particular
usage otherwise
everything is perfectly fine in this
video we are building a very basic lead
management system or crm using golang
and go fiber and this is a completely
beginner friendly video so if you have
no uh hands-on experience with golang
this is the right video for you to get
get your feet wet and start working with
golang
now i'll be using a very basic database
called sqlite so it will be very
difficult for you to set up or start
using okay
and uh i won't be using any concepts
that throw beginners off with golang
with like i won't be using any pointers
difficult advanced struct modeling i
won't be using marshalling and
marshalling i won't be using like
channels and go routines i wouldn't use
any of the concepts that people the
beginners find really difficult to
understand
so this is a great product to get
started the only prerequisite is that
you should have
sql lite installed ideally if you're on
ubuntu uh it's very simple it's very
easy to install sqlite just one command
i think uh apt get installed sqlite you
don't have to do much so with that out
of the way
um let's let's start uh setting up the
project
so i'm in my terminal now and it doesn't
matter how you go path is set up
we are creating a new project using go
mod so that will create the entire
package for us and do the package
management for us
so we can create this folder or this
project anywhere in our computer okay
so i'm going to create
a new directory and i'm going to call
the project go
fiber
crm
i think
basic
and the cd into it
and i'll also go mod in it
i'll just give my username and then i'll
give the name of the project go fiber
crm basic
now
go mod in it creates a go.mod file which
is going to basically
contain the list of all the dependencies
that we use in this project
so you
open this up
with i'm opening it up using vs code
you can use any other
code editor and here i'm using uh if you
if you go to your golang if you go to
your vs code extensions the first few
extensions that come up when you type
golang just install those
uh because that'll just make your
experience better in the sense they'll
rent the errors and the issues for you
by default and i've i've already done
that so
even if you don't do it it's completely
okay but if you do it then you're just
able to find those issues much faster
and easier
the way we structure this program is
going to be really simple
we just have
a database folder
we'll have our
lead folder
and we'll have our main
file now main.go file is the most
important file in your golang projects
and this is basically the entry into
your
project
and in your
lead you'll have
a lead code go file in the lead folder
in your database folder you'll just have
a database.profile
so with main.go
this is how you start the main.profile
right it's called main
and the second thing that you usually
write are the import statements for the
packages that you might want to use
and
[Music]
then the most important function here in
the main.go file is usually
or it's actually always funk main
so this is how you write funcman you
just create these two
brackets
and then you create these two curly
braces inside which you'll actually like
the function definition
and
um since i've only told you that i'll be
using
golang fiber for fiber
i'm going to go ahead and install it so
i'll say github.com
now um
[Music]
since we're using this package
whenever you want you've written down
any packages and you want to install
them you just have to run this command
called
id and you'll find all the packages that
have been defined but not
installed yet and we'll install all
these for you
so i'll go ahead and find the model for
package and install it automatically
okay
what you want to do is you want to
create some routes
so
we'll create some routes we'll say funk
setup
routes
here
and the routes
will be simple
there will be uh
get leads
right in the crm here there will be a
create lead
so we'll have app dot
post
new lead
there will be delete leads so app dot
delete
there will be
okay
and uh
now you've been calling this app but
what is this app exactly
app is basically an instance of
your file
so you'll call the fiber library like
this
and you'll say dot
new
okay
and
you'll go to the next line
you'll say
set up routes
and you're going to pass
app
into this folder
i meant function part folder
so
into this function which is set routes
you pass app which is basically an
instance of your fiber
and
by the way you've seen that this
squiggly line has gone away that means
it has done it's done installing the
five word package for us okay
now if you're passing phi app here in
this function that means you have to
accept app into this
function right so this is how you accept
it
so you say fiber dot app
i know it's there's a star here and it's
a pointer and i said there's no i'm not
going to using any pointers but this is
just one little exception okay i won't
be using it anywhere else but just to
give it reference and to it
you know refer to the app that's being
passed into this function we have to use
the pointer
so in case you don't know what pointers
are don't worry right now i'll be
creating very basic videos and
explaining pointers but for now you just
have to remember that app
has been passed into this function
and we don't uh we just want to uh use
it or call it by reference just remember
that call it by reference as in we don't
want to directly um you know use app
and uh why and how it works and what our
pointers all of that i'll be explaining
a different video in a very basic kind
of video for now just remember that you
just have to put a star here that is it
right that's all you have to care about
anyhow
so you have uh
defined these four uh these three
different things but i need one more
okay i need one more it's called just
getting one lead
dot
get
and just get lead
so how this is working is that for this
new lead you'll have a route which will
help you create a new lead and for
getting all leads you can have get leads
for getting just one lead
using an id you can have get lead
function and then delete lead function
is will be for
deleting a particular read with the with
an id
okay
so uh
[Music]
now
you want to have
app.listen
this starts off your server at
the port 3000
and
and you also want to
uh connect to the database
uh but what i'll do is i'll just define
the database first and then i'll come
here and then start we'll connect with
the database
now
you want to create a function here
called init database
okay
and you want to go to database.go
and here you want to write package
database
we'll import a couple of things
and we'll define a variable
we will define a variable to be able to
connect a connection or to be able to
create a connection with our database
so we'll call it dbcon
as a representation or reference to db
database connection
and it's going to be of type
corn dot d
now gorm is basically uh golang orm
which helps golang to interact with the
database
otherwise you would have had to write
all those queries yourself but here you
don't have to because you get the help
of gordon
and now that also means that you'll have
to import god because god is not is an
external library right so you'll say
github.com
slash
jinzu which is the name of the person
who's created gorm and then
right corn
you'll also
get the exact um
support for the exact database that
you're using so the database that we're
using is called sqlite inside corn
we have something called as
dialects
and you get sqlite
so dialects basically means language
right so uh
inside gone what what language do you
want to use so we want to use the sqlite
support language basically to be able to
connect our co-language sqlite
so what you want to do is you are
put a slash here and then just copy
and paste it here
right
and just run go mod id again and you'll
get these two packages and the script
line will go away
so always just keep running uh go more
tightly right so i just run it some time
back
and i got all the packages
so your database.go file is complete
now we'll come back to our main.co file
here what you want to do is the database
that you just created right the database
file that you just created or the
database package that you just created
you want to
import it here
so you want to say github.com
slash account slash
uh the name of the project the name of
the project is go fiber crm basic so
just
write that same name here
and slash database
this tells golank that you want to
import the database package that you
just created here in this
folder
and you just want to
import that
so once you import that then you can
access
the code that you've written there
okay so this makes the golan code
monitor in the sense you don't have to
keep everything in the same file
you can divide it into different
packages and you can install or report
those different packages into your
main.com file
and this is how i've imported
the database package that i've just
created
into the main
file
all right um
now
um
what i want to say is
in my um main file our main function
how to call a function called init
database
and i want to start a connection
so you have both we have just defined
the db connection
variable right
so you want to say database which is
your database package which we are
accessing using this database
dot db connection which is the variable
that you just created
which is of type column.dp remember
so you say database or db connection dot
close
at the end now differ uh is a statement
that you can check out it's it's a
golang
statement which basically means that
this line that we've just said that the
connection to be closed
will happen at the end when the function
has completely run everything has
happened after that only this function
this line
will run this command will run which
will close the connection right so we're
just making sure that after everything
is done after the whole funk main has
executed only at the end when everything
is done
just at the end just before the uh you
know end of the program
the last pro the last line or the last
command to run will be
this one
database connection up close
anyhow
so um
this in a database
function that you have called here
and we've defined here
we can now start
defining it properly
so first you'll define a variable called
error
and you'll say database dot
db connection just to remind you
database is our folder the package that
we just created here
database.gov package
and dbconnection is the string that we
just created so we are accessing the
database package in the database
connection string just like we did out
here
and
we also have our error and here we say
gone
dot open
sqlite3
and comma leads.tv
so what's happening here is that you use
gorm
to open
a connection to your sqlite3 database
the database name specifically is
leads.db
and you get that connection in this
database dot connection
or uh if it's not connected you'll get
an error
now
with the golang what you do is you
handle error red after every single
operation that's taking place so just as
this has happened that are taking place
we want to handle the error right here
itself so let's say if error
modification
you want to panic
and say failed to
connect
[Applause]
but if everything went well
then you want to say
connection
open
database
and you'll say database dot db
con
dot auto migrate
ampersand lead dot
i'll explain to you what this is
and at the end you want to save
print
ln database
migrated
okay
now lead right
lead that you see here
you want to define the lead now uh the
reason we're getting squid lines here is
that fmt is
not imported fmt is a package that helps
you to print now golang is so modular
that it doesn't even have the ability to
print on its own so it's there in a
package called fmp that you have to
import into your program and then you
have to use print println and this keeps
go angry light and fast
so um
you also want to have
um
yeah i think this this looks good
yeah so you want to uh now we want to
talk about lead university basically
lead is going to be this package here
that
we'll define right so firstly we can
find this package we can say package
lead
right just like package database we
defined
it's going to have some import
statements
and most importantly
it will have
a struct
now we won't have any uh difficult or
anything these trucks and you know
relationship between the structs and
modeling all of that we don't have any
any of that just have one struct start
is basically a data type that you're
creating on your own
so there are some data types that you
get with golang like string and hint and
that's all we're using we're just using
string in it in this video
so you get these kind of data types with
column write string and
but what if you wanted to create your
own data type
uh with the combination of strings
elements
and you can do that with golang and it's
called struct right so structs your own
data type that you're defining out here
and you're saying that lead is of the
data type struct and the struct is going
to have
is going to be
modeled
it's going to have name
company
email
sorry
company
email
and phone
so for a lead management system
we'll just have name company email phone
that's it
phone will be inked now what i'll do is
i'll just
create proper spacing between them so
that it all just becomes a little more
readable
and
um
that's that's about it actually
so this is how what you need is going to
look like
right so when you go back to your
main.go file
you want to now import that lead right
so right now obviously the lead file is
not complete but eventually at some
point of time will be completely
complete but you would want to import
the complete lead package into your
main.com file because you want to run
some operations on it
and um
so how do you import it you just do the
same thing just this is your main part
of the project right
uh your project is github.com i killed
slash go fiber basically because that's
how you had defined it when you was
doing a go mod in it right that's how
you initialize the project
and uh you can always put a slash here
and you can say
lead
and it'll know golang will know that
you're talking about this lead package
out here
now uh all these functions right so
get leads get lead newly deleted
functions
we can either define them inside our
main.go file or we can define that in
the lead file and keep our main.co file
lean and simple and small
so that's what we're going to do we're
going to keep all those functions in our
lead.go file and we're not going to keep
them here so that means that um those
functions will be in
a lead package and that's how you
refer anything in another package
in a lead package
we'll have these functions get leads get
new lead and delete
and the way to access them will be
like this the documentation dot
okay
now you want to define the actual route
right
so that will be slash we'll keep a
lead
right so if somebody using postman or
using um
you know girl hits this route api slash
v1 lead then he is going to be able to
get all the leads
if he uses the get
method
if you use the post method on the same
route you'll be able to post a new lead
and
for the um
get one by id
and delete by id
it'll be same but at the end there'll
also be that id of
uh
you know of the lead particularly
[Music]
cool
this is what you get right this is how
you're set up the routes
now the
program looks complete right
and
we'll head over to our
lead.go file now
so it's saying that i don't recognize
what gom dot model is it's giving you a
squiggly line that means you have to
import
the corn
i think my video had
stopped for a while
i've just switched it on back again
anyhow so with import uh you want to
import the god right so you'll say
github
dot com
slash
gen
zoo slash
now you notice that it doesn't give you
a squiggly line out here and that's
because
gold line already recognizes it because
it's already there in your co dot mod
right ginger.com is there so you don't
have to run go more tightly again you
just have you can just um
keep this or import this into any
um
in any file once you've done go mod id
once you have imported it in your
project right
so
now
you'll again get your go fiber so i'm
just going to go to my main and just
copy co fiber
because um i'll be defining the
functions to work with those dogs so
that's why i need go fiber here again
and similarly that what i need
uh in the database
the sqlite i'll just copy and paste that
also here
all right
and i also need access to the database
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
line
and i'll put it here
so soon in a while i'll need access to
the database
right the database connection all
because i have to um
for those get all leads and post it i'll
have to work with the database so i need
access to database
connections that's why i've imported the
database as well
and
now
i want to
define all these functions
that i have in my main.com file
which is basically get leads get lead
new lead and delete so let's do that
quickly
so first function will be
get leads
second function will be get
just lead
third function will be new lead
and fourth function will be
delete delete
now they'll have they'll accept some
things and then they'll have their own
uh function definition
so just do that for all of these
[Music]
now what are they going to accept right
they're going to accept
c
which is basically your fiber dot
context
fiber rcdx
in case you have no idea how context
works don't worry
i'll have another video and the basics
on explaining context
but this is a very basic concept of
golang and in case you know already know
that's really good but if you don't know
it just remember that
to all these functions that are uh
being driven
from these apis right from the apis you
hit it out
and you call a particular function there
you have to pass your context to your
fiber okay
so
i'll just give you a very basic idea
what this is doing is that this function
now can start
to work with the data that's coming from
the user
so for example in my get lead function
in my delete function
i'll need to use id
right
and i can use that i can find that id in
my c dot params basically c will have
all the data that's coming from the user
so let me i'll show it to you with an
example you understand it so for example
in my func get lead
now i want a particular id right i want
to read off particular id
so that means i need to define a
variable called id
and
i can now get access to the params that
the user is sending the user is going to
say that from the postman or curl that
hey i want the i the lead for this
particular id
so that id
you'll have
access to that id using c dot params so
this is why
c which is of type type fiber dot
context is important
so uh what we'll do is we'll just copy
this
and paste it everywhere
make sense
now um
let's just finish this function off
first
so here i'll have
a variable called db
which will be of type
database.connection
and i'll have
a variable called lead which is of type
lead
now i have the id that the user has sent
to me that's saying that hey i want the
deal of this id and i'm now going to my
database to fetch the data for that
particular id
and what i'm saying is that db which is
my database or dbconnection right which
is the instance of the database
session that's going on right now
i will find in it
the lead
with the particular id so i'll say lead
with the particular id is what i need
and we'll say c dot json lead
so we are able to also respond using c
the fiber context will also respond we
are able to send the response
right so we are able to work on the
request we are also able to send the
response using c dot json and we'll send
the lead in the json format okay so this
kind of
saves our effort from marshalling and
marshalling
now with the get leads
we'll do the same thing we'll say db
is equal to database dot daily
connection
and
we'll define
available leads
which is of type lead but it's a slice
now when we say get leads we are
basically saying that get all the leads
that exist in the database you're not
saying that get a particular lead with a
particular id we're saying get all the
leads in the database to do that you
need um
something called as a slice which is
almost like an added you need a slice of
all the leads
right so
lead in this case is the struct that
you've defined and when you say slice of
leads that means that there can be
multiple such leads with this particular
struct
right um
or in short uh in if you're from a
javascript background you would
understand that it's a
it's an array of objects it's not just
an array it's an array of objects that's
what a slice is
okay
so you have variable leads and you have
the slice
of type slice delete
and
you'll do the same thing you'll say
db.find
and you can say db.find because db is
the
instance of the session
for database connection right
so you'll say db.find and you'll
get all the leads and you'll response
send the response you did just see.json
will say it needs
to send all the leads
similarly you want to also have
uh the code for new lead
and again you'll start with db is equal
to database dot
db connection
and you'll define a variable called lead
which is new
lead
and if
uh
is equal to c dot
parser
lead
header
or equal
c dot
status as the three
dot
send
error
return
okay so what's happening here is
you get um
you use
uh body parser that you get in your
fiber right in your fiber package you
get access to body passes it parses the
body of the lead data
that the user is sending to you
so the user is using postman
mostly postman or girl and it's sending
you the data for a new lead
this data needs to um
you know uh checked first so we'll parse
it we'll do the body parser
and if there's some problem with parsing
it right it's going to send an error
so this error is 503 that we're sending
here
but if everything goes well we'll just
create that lead so let's say dot create
ampersand lead
zero json and once you have
created that lead in the database you
want to send that lead just to show the
user that hey this is the lead i was
just created in the database right now
and uh
this is how you create a new instance of
the lead okay
so the new lead function is quite simple
is just
using body parser to go through the data
of the lead that the user has just sent
and then checking if there's an error or
creating a new lead
and then sending the response with that
same read
i hope that makes sense
now delete lead
to delete a lead you need a particular
id right because you want to delete a
particular need
and so we'll say id is equal to c dot
paragraphs
id
and you'll say database is equal to
database dot
table connection
we will define
a new lead of type lead when you when
you write something like this right you
say
var lead lead
right you've done it here also but this
is um you know um i probably didn't
realize that maybe it might confuse some
some people right so lead is the struct
that you've defined right it's the data
type that you have defined
which is almost like var lead could be
an end could be a string or could be a
lead lead is your own data type here so
lead is the name of the variable whereas
lead is the data type which in this case
is lead itself which is a start
okay
now you want to say
db dot
first
lead comma id
and
if lead dot name
is equal to is equal to none
we'll say c dot status
[Applause]
500 dot
send
no lead found
with
id
and you'll return from here
[Applause]
and say db dot
delete
never send elite
and see that send
delete
successfully
delete it
so um
we get the id
right using the same method that we did
for get lead
sorry this lead here is actually capital
l
right so i hope you can see what the
issue was there shows that there was a
small l here the red written lead
but it will always be capital l because
that's how you've defined this
lead start
okay so delete lead you got the id using
the same method that we did in get lead
you got the id right from c dot params
then you have db which is the instance
of the database connection then you
define a lead of type lead struct
and then you find the first lead that
you find with this id
now if you
if you uh if the name of that lead is
nothing which means that lead is not
there that means that no lead was found
with that id
but if that was found then you'll just
go ahead and delete it
and you'll say lead successfully deleted
that's about it that's it that's your
lead.go
uh file
and then
there's only one thing we are left with
okay
and uh this is the thing that sometimes
throws people off uh
mostly people who are coming from a json
background or from a javascript
background is that javascript
understands json by default right so
whenever javascript developer goes to
another programming language like golang
or
python or java or anything else rust
ruby whatever
they get confused with this idea of that
how can a language not understand json
right it's because json is javascript
object notation and obviously only
javascript understands it natively but
all other languages like golang we have
to massage uh the data the you know the
language to be able to understand
json
so what you need to do out here is
with name you'll have to say
json
name
and you'll say json
company
so json
email
json
phone
what i have done is i have used these
backticks
and inside that i've used uh
said json and i've used
in double quotes name company email
phone number like that
and what's happening here is that
um
we're telling golang that in json
this is what it's going to look like so
for your reference uh hey golang for
your reference you're saying that it's
name with capital n company with capital
c
email with capital e
but the json that you'll receive
will be with small n small c small ds
small b right
this is how the the json is going to
look like uh going to look like and
we we're expecting
uh golang to understand the json
right so this is what i basically wanted
to show you
and when you say um
you know
that c dot json and in bracket leads
you're basically saying to go like that
hey whatever you've received from the
database now you have to convert it back
into json and select to the postman or
the terminal whatever
okay
so what i'm trying to say here is that
golang
does not understand json and it
understands one's constructs and it can
only function or
perform operations on that struct that
it understands and then it then again
has to convert something into json and
then only it can send it to the response
which we will understand
or our front end will understand
so this was basically your lead.
go file
and
database your dot co file is complete
as well
and your main.go file
is also complete
and i'm just checking uh just to see in
case there are any issues
um
in my main file i need uh
gorm as well
so what i'll do is i'll just
go ahead and i'll get the
gorn fiber and sqlite all these three
packages i'll get into my
if i already have so i'll remove that
from here
i just needed these two packages here in
my
main.co file as well
okay
so i think we are ready to be able to
build this file now so you want to uh um
before you run this file you want to
build it so what you'll do is you'll
head back to your tunnel
and you'll say go build
name
as soon as you build it
you see this file called just main it's
just called main
and what that means is it's an
executable file it's a dot exe file it's
executable and uh like dot exe
uh
if it was windows it would be dot exe
file but whatever uh
operating system you're using you'll
create and create a
uh operator like an executable file for
that operating system so that you'll be
able to run that program
and now all you have to do is uh go run
main.go and it'll run the program for
you
as soon as as soon as you do that you
need to see these two things connected
connection open database you have to see
that
database migrated in case you don't see
any of these that means your program is
not working properly and you need to
check the code i'll push the code to
github as well
so
this means that our project is working
like we see this nice fiber uh
you know text here and then you have
your port 3000 on which it is working
so everything seems to be fine
you have four apis for hunters
okay so now all we have to do is go to
our postman
and this is the collection that i've
created for my go fiber basic
uh project
there's an add lead here as you can see
right so i'll create this ad agree this
lead
so this had an id it has created ad
updated at delta and then you have your
name company email phone
now these three time stamps right
created updated deleted these can be
added automatically uh when you add some
data and these are optional right now
you don't have to add them but
but you may have seen that in many
programs it's added automatically and
i've shown how to do that
using the time package in my other
projects since this is beginner friendly
project i have not used the time package
i've not shown you how to use those
timestamps okay
and i'm sending it manually from the
front end or from postman
so here
i'll just change the id i'll create
another
record i'll call this
alex
clinton
let's call him alex clinton
we'll call the company name microsoft
and email would be alex at
microsoft.com
and we'll change this phone number a
little bit
we'll send
and you can see that let's create
another lead for us
if i want to get all leads i'm uh you
can see that i'm in the same apis that i
have defined here right so if i go to my
main.co file
um
api slash v1 lead
so you come here localhost 3000 and api
slash v1 that's the apa you're on
you send and you can see we have created
these two leads so it's working
perfectly you created two leads you can
see those two reads
now you want to get a particular lead
right so you'll come here
and you will now look at the api
uh which is the get
api
for the particular id in the end you
want to add an id right so in the end
i've added two
i do that i get my ramsay beaters and if
i add one
i get my other guy
and if you want to delete a particular
lead
it's the same right same api
as in same route but the method is
delete so you want to change your method
here from here to delete and you want to
delete the lead tool so it says lead
successfully deleted and now when you
check get all leads
they'll show you only one lead make
sense that means your entire project is
working this is your simple lead magnet
system this is a very simple
beginner-friendly project we'll be
building an hrms which is a human
resource management system
and we'll be using golang go fiber and
mongodb
so essentially you'll be learning how to
use go fiber along with mongodb but um
in a in a format of a small project so
it's very it's a very good way for a
beginner to get their feet wet and
actual uh you know up applying what
they've learned till now
now since this video is very uh beginner
friendly uh i won't even be having
different files i'll be having
everything in the same file may not go
file so we won't be learning about
project structure here because it's ugly
again for complete beginners
and but in case you want to see more
project complex project structures and
design patterns and all that i have a
lot of projects already on my playlists
without further delay let's get started
and
i'll just open up my terminal now
you can see i've opened up my terminal
now i'm using powershell on windows for
this project
and it doesn't matter how you've set up
your go path or how you've installed go
we'll be using go mod and that means
that we can have the project anywhere
and go mod will handle dependencies for
us
so i'll create a new
directory for myself for this link
project i'll call it go fiber
[ __ ]
hrms
and i'll cd into it
and i'll open up uh so before i open up
this on on a vs code or any other code
editor
i'll go ahead and say go more in it
which initializes your mod file
and
you'll give it an absolute path you'll
see github.com
and the name of the project go fiber
[ __ ] hrms
okay and now you can go ahead and open
it up in a code window i'm using vs code
vs code works out really well for golang
so in case you're using something else
just drive your code once
so as you can see there's uh already a
file called co dot mod
that exists for me right and it mentions
my uh
name of the project
and also mentions the version of golang
that i'm using so that if anybody else
takes up this project they can easily
install all the external packages that
i'll use using this file
and all the external packages that we'll
install in our project for example the
drivers that we'll use to work with
mongodb
you'll see them listed out here
[Music]
so as i said we'll have only one file in
this project
and
um so main.go is the file the most
important file usually in the golang
project
and what you want to start off with is
you want to say package main
and you'll want to import
some things here
okay
and
after importing those things that we'll
talk about in a while mostly around the
things that we'll import will be mostly
packages around mongodb
uh we also want to create a [ __ ]
instance instance of a session with
mongodb so that we're able to interact
with mongodb and
it will be basically a struct
so [ __ ] instance
struct
and you'll have a client and you'll have
a database
[Applause]
so a struct is basically your own data
type
so you get some data types with golang
like int string uint you know all of
those float and all of those different
uh data types but what if you wanted to
create your own data type right uh you
can do that in golang using something
called a struct almost like an object
with javascript
and so it will have two different things
one is client one is db
and
uh here we'll have to write some things
which i won't write
as of now because we have not installed
those packages
but
to be able to work with this struct i'll
need a variable
called [ __ ] instance
now this is how you define variables in
mongodb in golang
you have this variable mg and subtype
this is the data type so it could have
been string it could have been end but
right now for this uh
for what we're doing right now it's
[ __ ] instance among which longer sense
is our own data type that we've just
created right it's a struct it has a
client it has a database
okay
so
i also want to define two uh constants
so the first constant will be
the db name
name of the database that i want to work
with db
sorry
name
and it's going to be called let's say we
call it fiber
hrms
and
don't define a constant for [ __ ] url
now in this video i'm going to be using
the localhost
mongodb that means that mongodb is
installed in my local computer
and it'll be running on a port and
mongodb usually uses 27017 as the native
port now you could be using mongodb on
your local machine like i am using to
keep things simple but if you are using
a fully managed service like mlab they
will give you a link to embed in your
program and that's the link that you put
here in the mongodb uri okay so in my
case i'm using localhost so this is how
i'll write the
link so it'll be mongodb
and after these two slashes you'll put
your own actual link that you got from
your
managed service in my case it's just
localhost
and my port is 27017
the way you have configured up your
mongodb also makes a difference here
because you might have to write your
username at the rate your password and
then uh your localhost
so in my case the way i have configured
my mongodb i have not kept any username
or password for my admin user to uh as
an
activity with mongodb without recording
any username or password
uh in case uh you don't know how to set
it up like that there is a video on how
to install mongodb uh i think it's long
i uh put it up long long back so you'll
just have to search red bit on my
channel and you'll find it
it's very simple it's very
straightforward right you just set up
mongodb without any users or passwords
it's just
you know easier to work like that
especially if you're building very
simple projects right
and here
you want to add the db name
the dv name is fiber hrms and that's
what will be added so when your mongodb
gets connected we'll get connected to
27017 and by default to this database
called fiber hrms
now comes an important part which is
basically how you'll define your
employee
now in human resource management system
means it's a company and they have a
database of their employees that work
there so the employee
will be a struct
now um
you can you can manage
name like name as a string or
you know salary as a as a string or as a
number but how do you manage all of that
together for one employee right so
that's why you create a struct right so
there are these data types that golang
understands then there are these data
types that you can create called structs
that you can make go like understand
because they have these uh different
fields like for example there'll be a
field called id field sorry
field called id field called name
just name
and field called
salary
field called age
and all of these fields will have a data
type like string for example
name will be string
salary
is float
and age is also float
right so now these fields like id name
salary h there are data types string or
end or float whatever so that means
golang can understand what we're trying
to say right
but all of those
combined
make up a struct
and since golang understands those
individual things like id name salvage
it will also understand this whole start
right which is now a new data type that
we've treated for uh argues
okay
now uh
there's there'll also be something else
that i'll add here but not right now
and i'll explain to you what it is but
uh just keep this
like this keep this as
just a struct for now okay
now you'll
have a function for connection
which basically helps you to connect
your
co-link to mongodb so you'll have the
connect function here
and every function basically takes in
something and returns something so error
is what's returned by this function if
things go wrong and it takes in nothing
basically so this so there are these
empty brackets right
and inside this will be a function
definition that we'll write in a while
and at the end
will be funk main
so funk main is an important function
usually the main file funcman is the
most important function and that's where
the control of the program uh usually
begins
okay
and um here
you want to first define your app
now if you've used
um node.js by any chance
uh and if you use express because you
have to use express with most days right
mostly
so if you've used express that then you
know that you have to define the app
variable in the beginning which is
basically an instance of express and
that's how you interact with express
and exactly that's what we're doing here
because fiber is the equivalent of
express so express is for with node.js
and fiber is with collage it's an exact
equivalent but fiber is like i think
they say it's 10x faster or something
like that it's really fast basically
that's all i need to know okay
so um
now when i say fiber dot new that means
i should have had
the fiber package
so this is how you install or
sorry
in the import statement
this is how you
import
an external package so you say go fiber
slash
fiber slash
v2
sorry it's a small v okay so small v
and
um
you also want to get some mongodb
related packages
but for now let's uh let's just keep it
this much
and what we'll do is we'll go over to
our terminal and whenever you import a
new package right you have to say
go mod
typing so that
golang will
go online and find the model package for
you
and will install it in your program
now after
your fiverr definition
you want to have
the standard functions
so which are also your routes right so
the first route that you want to define
is slash employee
and this is the get route
then you'll
so this this the first route with the
get method is going to help you get the
list of all the employees that are there
in your database
then you will have a post route
and then you want to have
a put route
and
a delete route
okay
and for
post route
the route will be the same
for put there will be just
an id
after employee
for delete also
there will be an id
and the way you start off a function is
basically
when something lands on this route or
some or somebody calls this route you
want a function to get called
and that function basically
can return an error if something goes
wrong
and it will have a definition right the
function will have a definition
the function usually takes c
which gives you fiber dot context
you know c which basically is type of
fiber
which you get access to from here from
the library fiber
dot context
now um
there's something really important here
for you to understand is that um
whenever you have a function like this
like a route function
you want the request you want to be
working with request and you want to
have the ability to send out a response
a json response
by request you mean whenever the user
sends let's say from his post manner
from curl whatever the user sends to the
program
and it could be an id it could be uh
like in the in case of the post request
where you want to add a new employee it
would be the new employee data right the
data for the new employee
so that will all come in the request so
you need the ability to be uh to work
with that request and you want to be
able to process that like let's say you
added a new employee or you depleted
an employee using the id or you updated
an employee using the id
and you need the ability to also send
out a response back to postman or to the
terminal
so uh both of this can be done using
uh fiber.context and c is how you're
going to be accessing the response and
request okay
so this is what was important for you to
understand now uh before you start with
all this right you also need to be able
to connect with the database so you'll
call the connect function here
and connect function exactly the same
function which you're going to define
out here
[Applause]
so
um
what's happening here is you'll have f
error you'll handle the error here
itself
and error not equal to nil
then your
log dot fatal
here
so the log library helps you to log out
errors
and we have not imported it here so we
have to import the log library
right here like this
all right and um
what you want to do now is we want to
start creating our connect function
so
convert your connect function and we'll
say [ __ ] dot
new
client basically going to create a new
client for mongodb
now this word [ __ ]
basically comes from the [ __ ] library
that we have not installed or imported
yet
so let's go ahead and get the mongodb
libraries
the first one is go.mongodb.org
[ __ ]
driver
slash
so firstly just get [ __ ] actually just
get longer
right
and the spelling here is uh wrong so
just make sure you write the right
spelling which is mongoose [ __ ] and
driver
okay so that's the main important
library now this library has a few more
things that you can get right the so the
first thing that you can get is are the
options so let's say go dot
mongodb dot org
slash [ __ ] driver
slash [ __ ]
and then you'll get some options
and then [ __ ] has some bs on the
primitive that helps you to create that
id right
so we'll have to import that as well so
you'll say
go.mongodb.org
slash [ __ ] driver
slash vsan
this will help us to create
the id for every single record
there will be a ps1 id
and we'll have again mongodb.org
[ __ ] driver
slash nissan slash
primitive
now if in case you're worrying that
you'll have to remember these four legs
you don't have to you just use it once
here and every time you now connect with
mongodb you just have to copy those four
links i didn't copy them i could have
copied them and any other tutorials will
see online they will copy them but i'm
just showing it to you you know so that
uh you you understand that you go to
go.mongodb.org website then you go to
the mongodb which is the main [ __ ]
driver which is like the main apparent
library then you have like [ __ ] uh
which is the package the orm that you
use and then you have your options then
you also have your psalm primitive okay
so that's why i i just wrote it for you
to see that they're all linked and all
related so that you're not just blindly
copying all of that okay but mostly from
now on uh once you've done this project
you just have to copy and paste these
four lines every year
so what happened is when i when i just
uh
pressed ctrl s to save it uh there are
some plugins or extensions that i'm
using for golang that basically
recognize that i'm not using those
packages right now so they have removed
those packages for me so i'll control z
and not save it as of now but if i try
and save it it'll remove those packages
that i'm not using so it basically helps
with error solving
and you can also go to your um
what you call it your extensions and you
can just write golang and the first
three four packages that come just you
can just install them they just make
development little easier
um
now
now that we have installed or imported
these packages now it's going to be very
easy for us to
work with our connect function okay
so you say
mongod.net client
and then you say options.client
dot
apply uri so this function right the
options dot client dot apply ui you
already get from the [ __ ] package that
we're using and apply uri is a function
where in that function you pass
basically your [ __ ] uri that you've
just created so all it's doing is it's
going to apply that url and basically
going to connect
and you know
create a new client
for you and for that
url that you've just created or just
given to this program
um
you'll get access to this this whole
thing as in the complete connection
instance
using the client
right so whenever you want to work a
client you don't want to keep writing
this all the time right you want to be
able to uh you want to get all of that
in one variable that you can use later
on so that's what the client is in this
case
and in case you don't know what this is
this is the walrus character this
basically um you know
defines a variable and also declares
declares and defines at the same time
so here you also want to have something
called as a timeout now there are some
functions with mongodb that are blocking
functions like insert right and you
don't want it to block the entire
program so you want to always have a
timeout and timeout basically with this
mongodb package for uh specifically uh
it gives you it uses the context package
that already [ __ ] has to give you this
ability to have defined timeouts so this
is how we define timeout so you say
context
dot with timer
so in case your mongodb is not
responding or something goes wrong or
insert is taking too long you have a
timeout you don't want to block the
entire program
and uh now this is not compulsory but uh
this is a good practice i mean you have
to it's not like without writing this
the program won't work it will work
without it completely fine but uh you
know i recommend always writing this
down okay
so you'll see backgrounds comma
and you can give any time here you can
give a time of 10 or 20 or 30. now
what you'll notice here is that um
time as soon as you write time
it's not
recognized by golan that's because
golang is so modular that golon doesn't
doesn't even have the ability to print
things or uh even the time package is
not is even the time ability to
understand time is also not inherently
available inside co-language so this
basically makes golang very lightweight
and very fast
okay
that means that time um
is not understood by golang that means
it's a different package altogether so
you'll have to come up here and you'll
have to install time package on your own
now uh the extensions that i'm using
were able to get the context package for
me automatically so when i used context
out here even context is not understood
by golank but somehow the extension
decided to get the context package for
me automatically i didn't have to do it
anyhow
there's a quick line here that means
context there's no function called with
time out and that's because
uh the o should have been small
and now golang starts understanding it
very quickly
you get a squiggly line here with client
and error that's because you have
defined these and you have not used
these as of now and golang has a problem
with that so in case you define
something and you don't use it golang
has a big problem so we'll quickly uh
we'll use it we'll basically use these
two variables
okay
now um
you want to run this cancel script at
the end of this program and that's why
you use differ
and now you want to say client.connect
and you want to pass this context
here
so here um i forgot to show you that
ctx and cancel are the two things that
you'll get here
right
so when you say control c whenever you
run your program right and determine you
say ctrl c will basically cancel this
it'll have that timeout here directly
it'll just cancel the entire operation
whatever is running out there
so um now you have client.context cdx
the context is what you will pass here
to be able to connect the database with
the right context
and you will
again
get that in the error if there's an
error there you'll get that in this
error
variable that you'll handle now and
you'll also have a variable called db
so we'll say client.database
and you'll pass the db name here
so you've connected to the
database
uh to the you know mongodb but you also
want to go into the right database right
and this is how you do it and uh
you can you'll be able to use this now
um
the database using this db
variable
so this error that we have received that
we may have received if things went
wrong while connecting
or while creating this new client
those errors will handle right now so
let's say if error or equipment and by
the way this is a common
theme with the golang that always when
you write something and then you might
expect an error there you will always
handle that error just there itself so
here we will handle the error and we'll
have return
errors
now you might remember that we had
created our
uh mg here right our instance mg
and here we'll say
mg
is equal to
[ __ ] instance
then you'll have client
comma
db
and you'll return
nil
from this function
okay
so if you created your mg which is your
[ __ ] instance which is a flight start
and the way the values here for the
client and database right have now been
set so this is what we did here in case
you didn't understand is that for the
client
it comprises of two things remember
struct is basically your own data type
and in this case it's longer instance
which is a struct and has two things one
is the client the other is the database
so client means the client mongodb and
database means that database name that
you want to connect with
and that's why we created this db and
that's why we created the client these
two variables here
so that we're able to define our own
start complete sort and mg is basically
what we'll
be using to you know further on if you
want to work with the database
so that's what your instance consists of
now here
you want to say that client is of type
mongo.client
and db is of type
members
make sense
right
now i know i said i won't use pointers
and this star is basically a pointer so
what you're saying is that it's a
reference to [ __ ] dot client and mongod
database if you don't understand
pointers right now it's not a problem
you don't have to uh you know really
worry about it i'll have really basic
videos coming up on what pointers are
and how they work and why they're used
for now here this is the only place
where you'll be using it so
uh and also the other place where
uh we're passing a pointer to the fiber
dot context so just have to remember
that you have to put stars in front of
these for now and we're just passing
these by reference about pointers i'll
create like a 20 30 minute video just
explaining pointers so don't worry about
this right now okay
and there's no advanced pointers getting
used here just just for
this part so don't worry
uh anyhow
now coming to your uh employee start now
there's something that i want to do here
and i think right now is the right time
to do that before we start creating all
these
handler functions for our routes
so um one important thing that i want
you to understand is that um golang does
not understand json natively
on its own
just like if you're coming from a
javascript background you might feel
that
you know json is always is basically
understood by all languages and
javascript people have
uh this confusion because they feel that
javascript understands co-lang json so
that means all
languages will understand json but it's
not like that is because json is
javascript object mutations only
javascript understands it natively all
other languages have to
use some packages to be able to
understand it in our case we have to use
um a package called json
we have to do a lot of encoding
encoding and marshaling and marshalling
basically for understanding and working
with json and but in this case since
we're using fiber fiber takes care of a
lot of things for us automatically by
default and it's all happening under the
surface like all a lot of marshaling and
marshalling is happening under the
surface so fiber makes things very easy
for us
uh but otherwise uh by default uh golang
does not understand json right so that's
why we in whenever you define a struct
and the struct is going to actually
represent uh the data in the database in
your mongodb which understands json by
the way it's a javascript database and
uh the data that you're getting going to
get from
the user as a request
is also going to be json right so when
data comes from the user as a request to
golang it does not understand it because
it's json and when data comes from the
other way from the mongodb uh to golang
and then golan has to send it to the
user again golan does not understand it
because it's coming as a json
so this is why
you have to tell
golang that hey
you understand id as string
and this is what it's going to look like
to you right id is going to be string
and names interesting but in json it's
going to look a little different so we
just have to tell we just have to help
uh just go like here and we have to say
in json this is going to look like this
man
id and we'll also write omit empty for
id
and as you have may have worked with
golang it also sorry with the mongodb it
also needs pson for the id
and this is how it represents id at the
database level id
comma
format
now when i i'll show you name also and
then i'll explain the difference here
okay
so what's happening here is
name
is understood by postman is understood
by your terminal when you uh or by the
user when you send a girl request right
name is understood as
in json as name with small n
whereas golang understands it as name
with capital n and for column it's a
string
right but when it comes to id
um the postman stands just as json id
whereas mongodb stores us at as bson
which is underscore id so this is why we
have written bson again right for this
for mongodb
i hope that's
understood
and then you have your salary which is
again json
and your age
which is
agent json right so all of these fields
they have small n small s small a
whereas for golan to understand and go
like to work with this information it
will be capital n capital s capital a
so now we want to start working with our
main functions the main handler
functions like get
and post would delete
all of these functions right and the
route handlers
so we'll start with get that means we
want to get all the employees from our
database to do that you need um like i
told you golan does not understand json
right and you'll get something from the
database golang needs to understand it
and go language to send a json response
to the front end or to postman
now to be able to work with that
i need my
a variable called employees
and it's of
type employee right so this is how you
define a variable you say this is the
variable name
this is the type
and you see these two brackets here that
means it's a slice so it's okay if you
don't know what slices slice is
basically like an array but
instead of containing just numbers it
contains actual objects by objects you
mean basically all of the things the
multiple things that this
area will contain will be
an actual uh employee the whole employee
right so this means that if you're
coming from a javascript background this
would mean that it's an array of
multiple objects
so now you initialize it using
the make
command
[Music]
and employee
so um
you've defined your
employee variable right this will help
you to work with the records that are
fetched by the database from the
database now to get something from the
database you have to use um the find
command that mongodb already has right
so the find command you usually send a
query
in our case since we want all the
employees from the database that means
the query that we have to send is
completely empty or just two empty
brackets
okay so we'll have to define the query
here so query is equal to the sound dot
t
and inside these two curly braces you'll
define the
query usually in our case the query like
i said are just two empty brackets
because it's an empty query so this is
uh the query basically so we define the
query now
you want to use the find function that
mongodb will give you and inside that
find you will pass query right the query
that you've defined here but you'll also
pass
the context
right so you'll pass e.context and
you'll pass
query here
so i hope that's making sense
now um
this
find function
is available to you inside mongodb you
know that already and how are we talking
to mongodb in our program we're talking
to it using the mongodb instance that we
have defined here right the [ __ ]
instance
and the [ __ ] instance has something
called as db so we want to uh target
that [ __ ] instance and we want to talk
to the database exact database inside
that we want to talk to a collection
collection is like a table so with
mongodb you have collections and with an
sql database like post like postgres or
mysql you will have tables so if you're
familiar with tables it's the same thing
this is a collection so you want to go
to that instance you want to go to the
database and you want to go to the
collection and then you want to
basically uh run the find command
that means you'll go to the instance mg
dot you'll get the database
inside mg right so it's mg and this
database you've already defined the
variable there already it's all be set
and dot you want to get the collection
so the collection
so it's c capital and everything else is
small collection is
employees
and you'll say dot find and you'll find
the query
and here what you get back
is usually the cursor
basically it'll have will have all the
uh employees records
or you'll get back the error
so
now you want to handle the error so
you'll say error
and for the error you want to return a
status of
500 which is basically your internal
server error
you want to send a string which is your
error string basically sending the
entire error itself
you've defined your employees already
here
okay one small mistake that i see here
that i've made is that this bracket is
not here it's actually here the closed
bracket because it's a slice right it
implies the slice this is how you find
the slice
there's two brackets and then employee
all right now what you'll do is you'll
use this cursor
and here also i see one small mistake is
that d is going to give you capital we
will be small and now go language
understand it so that's why the
squiggly line
quickly goes away
all right
so
now what you want to do is you want to
say
cursor
dot
all
c dot
context
comma
ampersand employees
when i say ampersand employees i'm
basically passing a reference to this
variable employees that i have
sent
and
what's happening here really
is basically whatever data we've
received in our cursor right and from
this function that you've done here
cursor
which is all the
data of all the employees from the back
end that has been received
and this is going to basically convert
that into
a format into the structs that are
understandable by coolant so that's why
you pass these employees right so in in
the end you'll get um employees
right
but that will be basically a slice of
multiple different employees
and we did this because
gold line cannot understand json which
mongodb understands and when mongodb
sends some data from by running that
find function you don't need to convert
it into something that golang
understands right and this is how you've
done it
so
you'll say if
error is equal to
sorry in front of this you want to say
if
error
and error is not equal
and you want to return c dot status
500 dot
send
string
error dot error
right
and here you wanna return
if everything goes well you want to
return
the employees that you just
you know now converted
employees was that variable that you
defined which was a slice of employee
right that means multiple employees will
be there
and that basically is what you got from
the database you converted into a nice
uh you know understandable and
understandable format and in json you
sent it in json to as a response to the
front end
okay
so i hope all of that makes sense now
we'll move towards our post function
so we'll make some space here for for
post function we'll have our func
and similarly this function will also
accept
a pointer to fiber dot ctx which gives
us access to
our
response and request this is how we're
able to talk uh use response request and
it also does a little bit of marshalling
and marshalling for us like here we did
c dot json so it can do some mastering
and marshalling for you by default
it does take a lot of work away from you
and gives you some abstraction
so here you want to find your collection
so we'll say collection
is mongodb dot
database dot
collection
and employees
so instead of
uh saying this again again
mgb dot db dot correctional employees
i've defined it and i can now use it in
a variable called collection
and i'll create an employee now um
when creating
something in a database right you have
to use the insert function that mongodb
will give you and also you will get just
one employee that one employee data that
you're getting from the postpan that as
in the user will send the data of a new
employee and that that new employee
uh right variable is going to basically
go to the database
and this is how we'll define that
employee
variable
is equal to
mu
so when we say this
right um
you can define it like this or you can
say var
employee and employee you can say like
that or you can say implies equal to new
employee
all that's doing is that it's defining a
variable employee
which is of type
employee you know the employee structure
that you want to define which has id
name salary image
right
so now you have defined your employee as
well
and what you'll do now is um you'll get
some data in the request you'll get the
data of an actual employee as in the
user wants to add a new employee so
you'll send a new employee data like
name
and all those different things
uh your name and salary and age
to
this api
and this api
needs to now read that information and
it does that using
c which is basically your fiber context
dot body parser so you'll say worry
parser
and when you say
employee here
that means all that data basically
becomes formatted in the format that you
need and you get it into this variable
called employee
right so it basically passes the body
which is json you're sending from json
into post from postman to this guru lang
program into struct
that golang now understands
and after you've done that you want to
handle the error so you'll say error is
equal to c dot
body parts are implied
and if error is not equal to nil
uh there can't be any space between
exclamation mark and is equal to
and here you return
c dot status
400 dot
send
string error dot
error
okay
now we always want mongodb to create its
own ids and this is why what we'll do in
the beginning is we'll say
employee dot id
equals zero this force is mongodb
creates one id
and now i want to take this collection
that you have defined here
so it's good that if i define this as a
variable because i can now start keep
using it i don't have to always write
this again again so i'll say collection
dot
insert one now insert one is a function
that i get with mongodb so if you're
familiar with mongodb and the functions
that you get mongodb it's really easy to
understand you can insert one insert one
basically takes data and inserts that
into a database just one data
into that insert one function you'll
pass c dot context
comma
employee
so you received some data
in the body you used body parser to
convert that into employee which is your
employee struct and that employee stack
basically is your is what you're sending
to the insert one function
along with the context
and
whatever i get back from this function
after inserting right i'll keep that in
a variable called
insertion result
and also an error so if the the error is
there then i'll handle the error if
error is not equal
that is
return c dot status
500 dot
send string
error dot
error
spreading the return is wrong
now after it gets inserted it will come
in this variable called insertion result
while you'll get an error and this error
will handle it right now itself and we
want to do something with this insertion
result
what we're going to do is we want to um
get the id from this insertion result
that you get right then this id we'll
use that to search the actual record
uh that has just been inserted in the
database and then after finding that
record we want to return that to the
front end okay and this makes us doubly
sure
that whatever we
did the post request for right now it
was inserted into the database and we
can make it make that short by actually
going and searching for that record
using the id and then sending that
record and this makes it very sure that
uh this data was actually inserted in
the database make sure yeah that makes
sense all right so um
here first i'll handle the error okay
quickly
so if
error is not
i'll give some space here
then you wanna do something you wanna
return
c dot
status
500 dot
send
string
and error dot
error
all right now like i said you know we
want to take the insertion result which
is insertion result and we want to get
we want to we want its id right so we
want the inserted
id
and using this id we'll create a query
and then we'll find the
record that has this id
to check if
what we just inserted right now using
insert one was actually inserted in the
database or not okay
and
so let's say value
is equal to insertion result inserted id
and
basically we're building up a query
right
so the key is id
and for that key which is id
the value is this inserted id that you
just received
and close it with
inside another pair of curly brackets
and say
filter
is equal to this one dot t
just like you had created a query here
for get
which was um
bs on the d and it was the query was
empty right
now you have vsan.d
it's called sorry it's called filter not
filler filter and based on these and the
query has key which is id
and the value of id is basically in
session result that you just receive
right now and the inserted id of that
and you want to get the created record
that you just created how do you get it
you use collection dot
find one
and you pass c dot context to it
and you pass this filter query that you
just created
you pass it there
and that's how you get the created
record so i'll repeat again
you uh inserted the employee
data that we just sent using postman
then complete empire data and you used
insert one
query to insert that data of employee
and you got that uh you know whatever
you got back from this function was
stored in insertion result
and that insertion result also has a
variable called inserted id which
basically has the id of the data that
just got inserted and you keep that um
you know to to build a query and you
keep that in this variable called filter
and this filter is basically what you
send to find one function and we're just
rechecking that
this data was created and then you get
that into this
variable called created record so this
is the record that was just created
right now by you and this is what you
want to send
to the front end
so you will
create
a variable called created employee
now want to structure and format that
data right so you
say
that created employee is a variable
of type
employee
which is your own struct
right so created employee will have id
name salary
type employee
and you want to do you want to say
created
record
dot decode
and you want to decode the created
employee
okay we are doing this decoding because
as you know go line does not understand
json
so we have decoded that into a created
empire
right the whole json that we just
received from mongodb
and now you want to send that json
as response to the front end so you'll
say return
c dot status 201
dot json by the way 200 201 203 400 500
these are standard uh
you know statuses uh http statuses
you can read more about them in case you
don't know which status is used when
so you'll send the graded employee
make sense
now um
i've actually used insertion result here
so
let me make sure if this is the same
spelling i've used here
here's the scenes wearing
now uh a lot of these packages have
these quick lines so what i need to do
obviously is i need to say
so it gets all those mongodb and [ __ ]
driver options since i have not done
that for quite some time now
and if i go ahead and save it
it removes one package on which package
it did remove
any let me actually
um
so yeah just save it actually for now
and you can see that all the issues have
gone away right we don't have any issues
now
now we want to work on our
uh put function but let me first check
if everything looks fine with
the post function if there's no
big thing that we're missing as of now
yeah everything seems to be all right
so now we want to work on our put
function put is basically your update
and then you have at the end you have
delete so i'll just create some space
here just for some
you know uh
clarity
and here
as soon as somebody hits this
route you want to call a function you
want to call the function and this
function
is going to take c which is of type
fiber dot
cdx
returns an error
yeah
now the thing with ids is that
you get them very easily you can access
them pretty easily
using the c which is the context c dot
params so the parents will have the
parameter which is id that you just
passed
and i'll capture this in a variable
called id param
and also
i will create it uh
from hex so i'll say primitive
the primitive package that we're using
let's say object
id
from x
id parent
and i'll store that in employee id
variable
[Music]
or we'll get an error so either it'll
get converted or we'll get an error so
it's giving us quickly line for
primitive that means
yeah so that means
when i saved it last time i did remove
the primitive
package here
so i'll copy this paste it here
and i'll stay slash
all right
showing me three
issues in the file
i know there are two issues from here
because these two we have defined but we
have not
yet
used
anyhow
so now we'll we'll go forward we'll
handle this error that we might receive
here so if error
is more equal to nil
you want to return c dot
send
status
400
okay
and just like you did with post right so
update apis are usually very similar to
the post apis so just like you defined a
variable called employee and it was of
type struct which is employee start
similarly we'll have it here right and
similarly the data you need to get from
the body parser and you want to get it
into this variable called employee
so very similar so you will define a
variable called employees of type
employee
and
you can define a variable like like i
said you know where employee employee or
you can just say is equal to new implied
there's two ways to define a variable in
golang
many more but uh these two are the most
most widely used
so here you'll say c dot body parser
and employee just like you did in the
post api
and you'll handle the error here
error
not three are ours just two hours if
error is equal to
less than error or equal to nil
then you'll return c dot status
400 dot
send
string
err dot
header
now i'm going to start building up the
query okay
so because uh why do we want to build
the query because uh the id that we've
just received in this api right from the
request
for that id we need to find the exact
record in the database and then with
this new data that we've received to
update we want to update or replace that
data with this new data make sense so
first we need to find the data for that
id how do you do that you create a query
you say based on d
and you'll say key
is
underscore id
comma
value
is
employee
id
that you just defined out here
okay
then
you'll say bsn.d
and now what you want to do is you want
to build the update quit
how do you build the update query
you uh want to have so when you do an
update query right you have to have
dollars set as in set this new data for
instead of the old data
so in case you already are familiar with
mongodb will be very easy for you to
understand if you're new to mongodb just
remember that dollar set is the operator
that you have to use inside mongodb to
set this data
for the data that you are replacing
so this is how it's going to look like
it's going to be sunday inside that
you'll have a key
and the key will be dollar set like i
just mentioned
comma
there will be a value for that and the
value
is defined like this this one dot
d
inside that you have three things you
have three things inside here
a few things about the three
fields to it one is the name
comma
value
employee dot
name
and here you'll have key
h comma
value
and employee dot
h
then you have
k
salary
comma value
employee dot
salary
makes sense
here you'll just put a comma here and
then here also you put a comma
so now that you've built this query you
to
capture this and read it in this
variable called update
now you can see all the squiggling score
went away quickly
and you want to write the
update function
so the function update function that you
get with mongodb is called find one and
update so let's say find
one and
update
you pass c dot context in
you pass the query
and when i say query i mean this query
that i just created with the id so you
find that video with the id and the
update basically is the query where you
set
the new data for that particular id
right so you pass query and you pass
update both of these things
you say dot
err here
and where you want to run this you want
to run this very similar
to what you've done before right
you want to run this query in the [ __ ]
instance like this the instance that you
have
right among instance which is mg
dot database dot um collection just like
you did here with your app.get right
so the same thing you want to write here
you want to say mg
dot
tv dot
collection
inside that collection will say
employees
[Applause]
right
and error is equal to
all of this
now you'll handle the error so guys i
just need some
uh energy drink because i'm getting
you know it's a long video
if you don't mind
all right
so if error is not equal to nil
that means that
the filter did not match any documents
so you want to say if error
is equal to [ __ ] dot
there are no documents
right
so there's an error and an error
is that mongodb does not have those
documents
then you're going to return
c dot
send status
400. so 400 status you mean you know
it's for not found that means whatever
id that you're trying to find and
replace the data for it does not even
exist so
there's something wrong so that's what
you'll do otherwise
if there's a regular normal error then
you just want to return
[Applause]
500
all right
and uh you want to set the employee id
so inside employee
dot
id is equal to id
param
and
uh if everything has gone well
you want to send 200 saying everything
is okay you want to send the employee so
let's say return
c dot
status 200 dot json
and employee
cool
now the only function that's that we're
left with is
uh the app.delete function
but you may have realized that till now
we have not actually started our server
right we've not done anything to start
our server
so to start our server we'll just have
to do just this app.listen
on port 3000
and if there's an error you want to
enclose this
whole thing and you want to say
log.fatal
so if the star server does not start you
do some issue like the port is already
taken or there's some other issue
we'll just basically be able to log out
that fatal error
now you want to start building the
delete function
the process is very similar you want to
as soon as somebody hits this
route
or api you want to call this function
which accepts c
you'll have fiber dot
ctx
and it returns an error
inside that you'll have
now you obviously want access to the id
right which
is inside parents so it says c dot
params
inside that you have your id
and you want to enclose this whole thing
into
object
id
from hex
and let's say
bring the dot
so instead of doing those those two
steps that we did earlier like perimeter
object id from hex id param and then
doing this we have done both of those
things in just one step so if i did this
earlier in one step you would have been
confused
so this is why i showed you
how to do it in two steps and now how
you can do it in actually just
one step
and you get access to employee id
directly
this means
you don't have to do all this
part with id param and then employee
right you directly got access to
the employee id
anyhow
now you can handle this error so you'll
say if
error is not equal to
you'll return c dot
send status
400.
that means that probably the id that you
got here is not valid so that's why
we'll say it's not found 400.
now uh what you want to do is you want
to find the record with that id and you
want to delete that record
okay how do you do that
you will first have to always like
you've been doing till now you have to
build a query because mongodb
understands queries
and the queries are in psalm format
and this is what the query looks like it
has a key
and this key
we're going to pass the id
has a value
and the value is
employee id
okay so it has a keyhander
value
and i've put a
double quote here by mistake so that's
why everything looks off
you know it's kind of fixed
and now i want to do the same thing i
want to
call the delete
one function but where how do i get
access to the defunct function i have to
access the [ __ ]
instance
i'll have to access the database i'd
have to access my
collection
the collection is called
employees
and inside delete one you're going to
pass
context
comma
ampersand
query
just make sure the spelling of context
is correct
and whatever you get back from this
right from running this query
whenever we get back you stored in
result
or you get back an error
and you can handle the error now if
error is not equal to nil
then you return
status um
service
internal server editor so let's say
return
c dot send status
[Music]
500 and
[Music]
if the result is dot
deleted
the count is less than one
so that means if it didn't get deleted
then you want to return c dot
send
status
folder for not found
yeah so
gonna say you wanna say that's basically
not found okay
uh if uh
nothing got deleted or if the related
count is less than one so obviously that
means there was no
um
record like that
i think uh earlier by mistake i said did
i say somewhere that 400 is for not
found sorry uh my bad it's actually 404
uh that's not found i got confused for
400
here's your other type of server error
all right and here now if
the record gets deleted so you want to
say
c dot status
200 dot
json
record
deleted
okay
and that's your entire delete function
so in about 16
8 169 lines you are able to write the
entire program
things look good to me and now i think
we should start um
testing it out and start seeing if
everything works all right
so what you want to do now is you want
to head over to your terminal
not this one sorry
this one
and you want to say
go
build
main dot code
now what happens is
you see this main.exe file right so and
since i'm using windows it creates a dot
exe file for me which is an executable
file and uh that's what build does it
creates a build builds a exe file for
you
and what you want to do is you want to
now run this program which is recorded
let's see if it works
okay so we get some
uh issue here
so let's try and fix things fixing it
so we've received this error right and
what do you make of this it says there's
something to do with
mango driver mongodb client
right so it's quite apparent that
something has gone wrong with
[ __ ]
and if i go to my code
and i see that the drivers look fine to
me
and i know the code that i've written is
quite all right
and the only mistake that i see right
now
is with [ __ ] obviously is that i've not
put a slash here at the end and maybe
when it's trying to add this with the
database name uh the whole thing is kind
of fading maybe right that's my
hypothesis
and i save it and i run it again
and i'll have to build it obviously
first
and then i'll run it again
if you don't build it sometimes it runs
the old
uh executable file so just build it and
now i can see that it's running the
program so that was the mistake right so
uh with golang you don't have to be a
genius to
solve errors so that's why
i am very comfortable writing a lot of
code and not testing it again again with
other languages right you have seen
other like instructors they have to keep
showing you how just build a small part
of the code and then they test and check
check it out if it's working or not
with golang you don't have to do it just
write everything
all at once and then
easily you can debug it you don't have
to be a genius we will tell you the
exact issue where the issue is right
anyhow so it says uh fiber is working on
port 3000
there are five handlers processors is
one pids to one three zero
all right so now you head over to your
postman and you
come here i've created a collection set
of collections so get all employees
which is basically
localhost
3000 slash employee
and i get all the employees i that i
have
and right now it's saying that i have
zero employees right it's an empty added
obviously we have uh no employees that
means i'll start creating employees so
firstly i'll create an employee caller
that's created so it's created it for me
i'll create another employee
called rupert
uh now i see that there's another issue
there's a duplicate key error issue okay
so this means there's something wrong
happening with our id and i kind of
suspected that when i was reading
it didn't send didn't show me an id that
means there was something wrong there as
well so now let me try and fix this id
issue back in our code
in the post function
everything looks all right to me
that means there could be some issue
here yes now i see the issue there's
just one small space between id and omit
empty so let's remove that
and now i think it'll work because this
format that i had gone for it
probably
mongodb did not understand it
so let's
cancel our process
buildmain.gov
and runway.go
and now i'll allow access on my firewall
and so let's
try adding some employees let's try
adding
robert
cool you get an id here now
and you add
alex
right so you're getting these ids here
you get all employees
and you'll see so many employees right
now what you'll do is you want to edit
an employee so let's edit rupert so i'll
take this id go to edit employee
just see that it's local 3000 slash
employee slash the id of the employee so
the id of the employees are what i want
to replace
and i wanna and i can send any data here
that i want
i'll change his name to
peter
when i do that rupert's name has been
changed to peter so if i get all
employees
that second rupert has been competed but
this first and third rupert are always
still there but the second rupert has
now become peter okay
you want to delete an employee now so
you just copy and paste his id again for
delete employee
when you paste it here
send record deleted
now when you get all employees you'll
see that peter is not there so the first
rupert is there second looper is there
and peter can't be found so you can see
that right the issue that we were having
earlier was that id was not being
generated for the first record
and if i was trying to add more records
i was saying that that same idea already
exists so it's an error for mongodb but
now the ids are being generated because
i removed that small space so all the
apis are working perfectly here's your
little
human resource management system you can
create employees delete uh and updated
employees you have learned how to work
with go fiber which is a very nice
library learn how to
uh connect a program which uses go fiber
with mongodb
it's a complete serverless stack
right so you're using dynamodb
serverless you're using lambda
serverless again
and then we'll be using api gateway
again serverless now api gateway helps
us uh enables anybody across the world
to interact with our lambda function
right so we'll be deploying all these
three things
uh from the aws console right we'll be
using the aws console and then we'll
make settings for all these three things
and we'll deploy all of this
and anybody across the world can use our
lambda function so this is more like a
real world scenario
so i'm in my terminal now and you don't
really have to keep this project in your
go root because since golang 1.12
anyways they had you know go mod in it
which we're going to do anyways out here
go modern it takes care of everything i
mean you don't have to really uh do
anything manually all right so here
we'll say
we will make a directory first we'll say
go
serverless
and yt all right and we'll see into this
go serverless stack yt for yt is
basically youtube i'm making this
project for youtube specifically all
right and here i'll say
um
go mod in it
and which is basically github
dot com
slash akil
slash go
serverless yt
so that's my project it's initialized go
mod for me go mod is basically like my
package.json file if you're from a
javascript background it'll have all my
dependencies for me you know easily
listed out
so
um
now what i can do is i can just open
this project up and
code editor which is vs code in my case
um just as a pointer
right i'm using
windows inside windows i'm i have
something called as wsl inside that i'm
using ubuntu 20.04 and i use multiple
different versions of ubuntu right and
this for this particular video i'm using
ubuntu 20.04 and in my ubuntu 20.04 uh
instance i have vs code set up all right
now uh i don't want to install a lot of
extensions uh for golang because i know
when i'll start typing uh i'll start
writing a lot of code i'll make some
mistakes right with golang i'll make
some mistakes but i will fix them so
don't worry i don't have extensions
because i don't want to like start uh
you know ballooning up my instance
because this is just one of the
instances that i use uh on my windows pc
for ubuntu i have
like 10 15 different versions of ubuntu
right
so
uh if you're new to golang by the way
main.go file is your main
file right in the project
and this is how you start domain.go file
you say package main and you say import
and because you'll import some packages
right not everything you'll have
inside golang golang is very modular uh
you have to install a lot of external
packages and a lot of uh you know
packages that come with golang you have
to specifically tell that you know i
need this package from coolant
and uh so the
the third party packages that we'll be
using will be mostly around
lambda all right so we'll talk about
them in a while
and then uh
the most important thing here will
always be funk main because that's your
entry point into the program right the
funk main uh now before i start writing
anything in main.go file what i'll do is
i'll just try and create
like a very simple
project structure
i need the build folder right because
i'm going to keep my build of this
entire project in my build folder and
that's i'm going to zip it up and then
i'm going to keep take that zip file to
my lambda uh sorry my aws lambda console
all right so that's why i need the build
folder
and i need my cmd folder because that's
where i usually keep my main dot go
sorry not in the
build but in my cmd folder i use keep my
main.co file
all right
and then you'll have a package folder
so uh if you've worked with golang
before this is like the very standard
kind of uh
structure right nothing nothing new so
package will as you already know will
have handlers
right handlers to handle the apis
and then you will have i'll have a
folder for user
i'll explain to you why i'm doing that
and then i'll have a very simple
validation function so i'll keep that in
a folder called validator write daters
sorry
uh that's it yeah so in validators i
will have just one little file
of badly like
five six lines of code i think
it's just going to be as email valid
just to check if my email is valid for
the user
and here in my user
i'll have a file called user.go
all right and my handlers that's where
my main logic resides so this is a very
short very small project handlers i'll
just have two files i'll have
api response dot go because i need this
uh
file for uh my api gateway i'll build it
you'll understand what it is
and then it's handlers.go
right
now my user.go file
is kind of
a combination of my models
and my
almost like my controllers as well you
know so i have handlers uh but you know
user.go file will have a lot of code
which kind of which talks to my database
all right directly talks to my database
so i'll have those models like those
structs as well at the same time i'll
have model functions uh those uh sorry
database functions at the same time i'll
head over to your main.co file in funk
main i think what i'll do is
i'll start with this place right i'll
say os dot
get environment
pws region so aws region is very
important because that's where your uh
lambda will go and sit right so with aws
if if you've worked with aws a lot you
know that it has different regions right
so my particular aws is configured with
india which is asia pacific south once
uh if you have uh been using cli and
it's set up it's uh it'll be amazing uh
otherwise also i don't think you should
have a problem
right
but just try and
uh just try and set up awcli it's very
easy it's just a five minute process and
it will be very simple for you to follow
along with all of my other videos as
well because uh in my other videos it's
a prerequisite
so um
how do you create a session
so you'll say session dot new session
now
if i'm calling this os
here right so i need to have os here
that's the package right and if i'm
calling session here session is
something that aws lambda gives me aws
gives me sorry so i'll say github dot
com
slash now i'm looking at the
documentation for the aws packages at
the same time you can do that otherwise
in case you're you're the type of person
who wants to like know uh exactly which
package you are installing because i am
that type of person i don't want to
install any extra packages right so if
you like me you you might want to open
up um just like i've done you might want
to open up the
aws sdk it's called so i'll say aws aws
sdk for go you want to you want to open
up the documentation and here you'll see
it will be slash session
all right
and to create the new session
you'll see
aws dot
config
and the bracket
which will be curly braces bracket
you'll say region
aws dot
string
inside that you'll pass the region
all right
all right
and then
as you know with all everything to do
with golang whenever we haven't
uh we get two things usually right we
get the thing that we're looking for
which is the aws session which will come
from the session function
right sorry the new session function
which is a part of the session
package that we have here
and
we get the error so
with golang you have to like keep
handling errors and this is a very neat
and clean way of handling errors because
at every stage you know where there is
coming from and you can handle it there
itself
so if there's an error just return all
right
and i want to create a variable called
dynaclient which for my dynamodb
and
dot new
and
uh how do you create a new client you'll
say aws session
perfect which you've just created out
here
so you've created the session and then
you'll say lambda.start
and handler
so this you may not understand right now
not a problem
so firstly we want dynamodb how do you
get dynamodb you get it like this it'll
say github.com
aws slash aws
sdk go slash service slash
dynamo
db
all right
so you have session you have dynamodb
and
you want aws itself in the first place
so you'll say github.com
slash aws
sdk go slash eight plus
to get this lambda function
uh sorry the lambda package which has
the start function
you need the start function
what you'll do is you'll say github
dot com
slash aws aws
lambda go slash
lambda cool
so far so good that's what i needed you
know
and
i need something called as the handler
which we'll talk about in a while
okay
for now
i am creating a constant
called table name
stable name is
lambda user
i'll say lambda in
go user
and
now it's time to create my handler which
is this basically
so i'm passing my handler there
in my handler what i'm doing is
i have a request
basically i accept some things right in
this function and i turn some things and
it has
some
definition so what does it accept except
accepts events dot
api
gateway
proxy
request so you're wondering what's
events right so events is basically what
uh
golang lambda will give us so
i'll come here
and
i'll say
github.com
slash aws aws
lambda go
slash
events
perfect
and
the other thing that this accepts is
star events dot api
okay to a
proxy response
sorry i meant that this it accepts a
request
returns a response
i'm not sure what i said actually before
that what i'm trying to say here is that
you know this is a function that accepts
something and it turns something
obviously accepts a request obviously
returns a response right no complication
there that's what you wanted to do
and what you'll do here is you'll switch
uh with the
http method so you'll say switch
we'll say request dot
http
method so what are the htm methods that
you have you have get post put and
delete that's all you have so for
every single
different
uh hb method you want to call a
different function
how do you do that so you'll say switch
sorry we've already switched right we've
already switched uh it's like um
it's 8 30 here some kind of sleepy uh i
usually get sleepy at 11 pm but somehow
today i'm sleepy earlier because i woke
up really early
i have joined this martial arts class
that that you know
gets me to wake up at 5 00 am these days
so
so you'll have something called as
handlers
right
and where will those handlers come in
from it's basically these handlers that
you want to
import so which are basically your own
uh creation your you know the handlers
are your own creations you'll say
github.com
[Music]
handlers
cool
so you're saying to go lank is that uh
this is my project
github.com go serverless yt
inside that i have a folder called
package instead of
a
package called handlers
right
and handlers the file
uh on top of that file will say package
handlers and it belongs to the handlers
folder then golang understands okay that
this is what we're talking about all
right that's the format i mean the the
folder name and the package name have to
be the same
just letting you know in case you didn't
know that i mean
um
i mean i'm pretty sure you knew that but
i'm just making sure right so you have
request table name and diana client
right so you send this to this function
called handlers.getuser which we'll work
on in a while
so that was your case get now you have
more cases right you have depending on
the http method so you have post
you will have
put
and you'll have
delete
post you'll set it on
handlers.create
user again you'll pass request comma
table name
comma dyna client for put you'll pass
return
handlers dot
update user request comma sorry
request comma
table name comma dinoclient
and for delete
we'll just do handlers dot
delete
user
and same things you'll pass the same
things comma dyna client
and after delete you will just
give it a default
if you work with case search and case
statements you obviously know there's a
default right and try to keep the
identitation same
it won't affect it but just it's just a
good habit you know
i mean i don't do it many times but you
know
i
try to do it
these days
all right
so by default you want to call this
function called unhandled method
which is again in your handlers
file or handlers package and this is the
entire picture i mean uh i don't think
we're missing anything we have the os
package down here we have events lambda
aws session dynamodb
yeah there's one more package actually
if you look at the aws sdk
document
then you want to import
h sdk go slash
service slash
dynamodb slash
dynamo
dvi face
just keep these packages
and what i think we should do is we
should just say go mod diary
so i'll get us all the package that
we've just uh talked about
and usually like many times i do this at
the end of the
end of the video right but this time i'm
just doing it beforehand itself because
many people they can start freaking out
hey you're you're installing all these
packages if not you've not run the
command go my go mod id or you're making
so many mistakes man while typing why
don't you install some extensions i've
explained to you why i don't install
extensions right
so so with golang i mean what happens is
that you know we usually come from
javascript kind of a background and then
we think that oh you know if you're
making all these mistakes then the
complete program will crash and uh it
will be difficult to solve it but with
golang golang is very different from
other programming languages right
make as many mistakes as you want
and once you run the program golang will
really handle everything for you it'll
tell you which line what's the problem
it's quite intelligent
right it's not like your regular uh
other programming languages like
javascript
so here one thing that we missed out was
to create the dyna client in the first
place right so the then a client has in
the variable
and
defining the type of variable the dyna
client is so what type of dynam uh there
it will be
that's where we'll use this thermodb i
face right we'll say dot
dynamo
thermodv
api
just make sure you get this right all
right
so that's your main file your main file
is complete
and
now you want to
start handling handlers so here
so since these two files belong to the
same folder called handlers we want it
to
both to be
package handlers
right so we'll say
package
handlers
right that's clear till now i'm hoping
and
after writing the package you say import
and then you have your
main func you know for in this case this
the main function of this
file is
called
api response
accepts some things
return some things and has a function
definition
what does it accept accepts status
which is end
and body
which has an interface
what does it
return it returns
event start
api gateway proxy proxyresponse
comma error
right
for importing you will say encoding
slash
json
and github.com
slash aws
slash
address lambda go
slash events
okay
all we're doing with this is basically
defining
the response right so
we'll say response is equal to
event start
api gateway response
the response you're just setting the
headers
pretty standard
because the way we're going to set up
these headers
are something that you've already seen
so many times which is basically content
type and application json so we're
saying that
we're returning json from
our lambda function
right nothing
uh out of the ordinary so we'll say
response dot
status code
is equal to status
and
so i will be basically your like 400 for
300 uh something like that
and then you'll say string body comma
json.marshall
sorry so you are uh if you've been with
golang you already know what's matchling
and d marshalling unmarshalling sorry is
golang doesn't understand
json on its own so it needs the help of
json marshalling
which is part of this encoding slash
json package
and uh yeah so whenever you send some
json from postman into
um postman or maybe terminal wherever
you send some uh json
uh it basically we we want uh golang to
understand it also and also the
information that golang produces for it
to become json uh
and send it as a response that also
needs uh you know help a goal i need
help with both so that's why it's called
mastering and muscling there are
hundreds of videos about it
on youtube you can check it out nothing
fancy or nothing
complicated
you have to do that in uh you know
almost all the other languages right
which are not javascript which is like
basically java and python all these
languages you have to do something like
that right
because any language that's not
javascript does not understand json by
default because json is javascript
object notation
so this is your api response dot go all
right that's it i mean there's nothing
much going on here in this file
but
the other file in handler's package
handlers this is where we're going to
spend some time because
obviously there will be a lot going on
here right
uh so the main functions that
usually will be there will be
based on our main.go file so main.go
file requires get user function create
user update user delete user and unlock
method unhandled method sorry so these
are the functions that obviously that
you need to create right so you say get
user
and
you'll say create user
you will say update user and delete
users func
update user
and delete user
alright so here
the last function that we want to keep
here
is
unhandled method
right so
for let's say if somebody uh uses the
patch method because you're handling get
post put delete if somebody uses batch
then we'll say that hey
it's not handled right so we'll say
unhandled method
accept some things return some things
and has a
function definition
all right so this is uh in general this
is how your
handlers file is going to be like
and
what we can do is we can work on our is
email validated uh valid file
so we'll say package validators
and there's a package that you get with
golang it's called regular expressions
and we're just creating a simple
function where we're just saying if the
email is valid or not
right really simple
all it does is accepts
an email string
and returns a boolean like yeah true or
false
we'll take a variable called rxemail
we'll use the reg expression regular
expression package
and if you look at the regular
expression documentation like i have in
front of me go to the golang official
documentation and check out the regular
expression package
um i i highly recommend you to open it
if you want because that's what i've
done out here in my other screen
we'll use
the
function called must compile
and i'm going to copy and paste a
regular expression string here
you don't really need to understand what
this does you just get it directly from
the
documentation but if you really want to
know basically uh you're just checking
if you know the numbers are between a to
z a to z
and zero to nine that kind of stuff
right that's all it's doing and it's
also checking for at symbol
right that means obviously if it's an
email it needs to have an ad right
so those kind of things just basic email
validation check is happening out there
do check out the regular expression
document if you want to really
understand what this regular expression
does all right
but if you want to save time just copy
and paste it like i did just did
and
now we want to check the length of email
female if length of females less than
three or
length of email
is more than 254
or
our rx email
variable
dot mat string
then you'll just return false
right so this returns either true or
false
if these conditions are not met
then you return false otherwise you
return true that means everything is
fine and email is valid right obviously
if this is not uh proper it's not
working properly if uh length is more
length is less
we'll say the email is not valid
otherwise we'll say it's true you can
change these numbers as you want but
i've kept them to be 3 and 254. all
right you can change it on your taste
so uh now we'll go to our user.go file
and we'll just add a very 10 000 feet
level i'll just set up this file now
what i want uh should happen is that
from my handlers
like the main control you know that will
go to the main file
to our uh you know to this function
basically and this function is calling
the get user function and create user
function update user and all these
functions are as you know mentioned in
the handlers right and from the handlers
from the handlers you'll call the
functions in your user.go file and these
functions will be actually the database
functions that actually talk to the
database right so every function that
you have here
except for the unhandled method because
it doesn't do much uh these four crud
functions that we have they have an
equivalent function in your user.go file
a complete like one is to one function
in your user.go file that
talks to the database all right so let's
do that let's create those functions so
firstly as you know when we start off a
file
we import some things and then
here i also want to find some variables
some errors that i want to define
so the functions that i want to have
here in my user.google file which will
have one is to one relationship with
these four functions
the first function will be
called i'll call it
fetch user
so that means is
uh
my get user function gets called in my
handlers and this function will call in
my user.go file the fetch user function
which directly gets uh the user from the
database itself the database in this
case being dynamodb right
so it accepts some things returns some
things and it has a function definition
simple
the second function that i want to have
is for
getting multiple users actually so i'll
say funk
fetch
users
similarly it'll look very similar
then i want to have
a create function
so i'll have create user
and then
it has update user
okay you just have to keep looking here
and then creating these functions
and then you have the last one is delete
user right so you'll come here
right if it doesn't get deleted then you
don't have to return anything specific
so especially you can just return an
error that's why
from the return here is just an
error right
and
that's about it so we have one into one
functions all of these but one extra
function is there which is fetch users
all right so we'll see where to get
where to use it
so from a 10 000 feet perspective this
is your user.google file and this is
your handlers file so what we'll do is
we'll start working on our handlers
function and then at the same time we'll
start working on our
uh user.go functions
and here you'll obviously import some
things right
um
the first thing that i need is net slash
http
then i need my lambda event so i'll say
github.com
aws
lambda go slash events now it's possible
that i'm importing these but you're not
understanding why i'm importing these so
you might get confused so
uh now there are two ways to do it one
is when i'm actually writing the code
and then i use this events
packet somewhere and then i come and
come up and you know import it or i know
um you know which ones i need so i'll
just import them right in the beginning
itself so that i can use them later on
so i'm just doing this so try not to get
confused because we'll actually be using
these packages in just like two three
minutes
don't worry you know why we're importing
them where will we use it so
please be patient
slash aws
right so these are the same packages
that we already use in our main.co file
and we'll say github.com slash aws
slashing plus
okay go slash service slash
turnover db slash dynamo tv i face
[Applause]
great
one thing that i need here
because i would want to call these
functions like i told you right i won't
call these functions so that's why
i want to import this user package in my
handlers file how would i do that i
would say github
dot com slash a kill slash
go serverless
writing
slash
package slash user
so inside package
inside the user package
we've imported it here
all right
and then before i get started these
functions i want to define a very a
variable called error
method not
allowed
[Music]
is equal to method not
allowed
and
why do i need to create
this because
firstly we'll be working on this
function unhandled method right so
that's why we want to call this function
so here
this returns an
event
api gateway event so it will say api
gateway proxy response comma
error
right so we'll just send response from
here
or we'll just send an error and here
you'll say return api response the
response that you want to send
is http dot
when we say http we are talking about
the http package net http package all
right status
method
not
allowed comma
header method not load which we have
just defined
together right
that's what you're saying so we're
saying that
uh we have uh you know something for get
post but complete but we don't have
something for patch so patch or any
other method that somebody uh plans to
use
so if you get something like that like
an unhandled handle method so you'll
send a response saying that hey
this method is not allowed
all right
and
i want to create
another variable
but it's actually a struct right so it's
an error body
and i'll be using it a lot so just bear
with me as to why i'm creating it
this struct
has a variable called error message
chat string
error comma
commit
empty
cool
now for your get user
[Music]
you have
you accept something and you turn
something here
for a get user what do you accept what
do you what does the function get you
get a request right from postman the
request that you get is
um
part of this events packet so you'll say
event start
api gateway request
comma table name which is string
comma
diana client
dot
dynamo
db api
and what is return
it returns a response obviously so we'll
say events
dot api gateway proxy proxyresponse
comma error
straightforward
and actually
this
these two things right well it's going
to accept what's going to return
it's going to be used by all of the
functions so what you'll do is you just
copy and you'll just paste it here
for create user
for update user as well
and
for delete user as well
awesome so we've done a lot of heavy
lifting
now we want to start working on the
function definitions for these all these
functions
right so the first thing that you'll say
is email
request dot
query
string parameters
email
so if you've
guessed what's happening here is you
want to get the user but by using the
email id of that user
so from a request you'll have your query
string parameters which we'll pass as
email
and that we're going to capture in a
variable called email
and then we'll check
the length so we'll say if length
of email is greater than zero
then you'll get a single user so you'll
say user dot
fetch user which we've just created
together right we've not created the
definition but you know which function
i'm talking about it's in my user
uh package which have been imported here
already
so fetch user is going to take the email
table name and die in a client
and i'm going to capture this in
the result
or they're going there's going to be an
error and if there's an error i'll
handle the error so i'll say f error not
equal to nil
return
api response
http dot
status bad request
comma
error body
so error body is a struct that i've
already defined and in error body i want
to pass
aws dot
string
error dot
error
[Music]
and otherwise you'll see hdb dot
everything is okay so we'll say status
okay
if everything goes well
and you'll pass the result from this
function
now if
um
if you want
multiple users
you'll say user dot
fetch users
same thing table name
and a client
and
what you'll do is you'll again use
result and error to capture the values
coming from this function
and if there's an error and you'll check
if error is not equal to nil you'll
return the api response
saying
http.statuspad request because there's
an error right
and you'll send the error body just like
we did earlier error body is the struct
that we've already defined
that's the error body that we are
sending which is basically json
and here the error body
uh inside that we're going to
send you're going to send aws.string
header dot
error
got it
but if everything went well and there
was no error then we're going to return
api response
and http dot status okay
comma result
so basically that's your get user
now what you can do is we can
work on our fetch user and fetch users
both of these functions in our user.go
file or we can work on our create user
function in our handlers so i think i'll
do the former
i'll work on fetch users and
i'll work on fetch user let me just
check if everything is recording yes
everything is recording perfectly
and i just i need to keep making sure
otherwise you know i end up making a
long video when nothing has recorded and
that leads to a big problem
all right so before i do anything with
users
i want to first create a user right so
like i said this file is a mix of that
model file that you usually create where
you define the struct of how the user is
going to look like so i'll say user
struct
email
now since this user struct is small and
we don't have multiple structs like if
this was
a um
e-commerce for example then you would
have had users and orders and you know
all those different like products and so
many different structs right so you'd
have to have like a model separate
models folder for all these different
models and then you'll have you'd have
you know database
functions separately and controllers or
something like that
right
but since we don't have that
we have a very small project which just
has users and users all itself it's a
very small struct because you just have
email first name and last name
you don't have too much here right you
can
combine controllers and models into the
same file
now email is going to be
a string
which is going to say json
and you say like this json email because
for golang's purposes it'll be emailed
with a capital e whereas when json where
it's stored
uh it's going to be emailed with a small
e so you need to tell golang that you
know there are two versions of it one
the json version the another here's the
version that golang understands because
golang does not understand
json as i've already told you so that's
why we'll also you have to use some
marshalling and unmarshalling
uh to get it to understand
and interact with json all right so
you'll have first name and last name
and then what we'll do is we'll create
our fetch user function
what does it accept so if you actually
go to handlers you'll see the fetch user
function
accepts email table name dynaclient so
we'll say here email
and table name which is string
and your dyna client which is of type
you already know that more
dbi face dot
dynamodb api
and it just returns a user
obviously i mean you fetch user you
return that particular user or you turn
error if nothing works out
you define a variable called input
and it's of type dynamodb dot
get
item
input
so we'll have to define the key based on
which our
database function will run to find that
particular user and you already know
that the user will be found from the
database based on the email id so we
take an email id we're taking an email
id and then we want to find the user
that's associated with that email id all
right so
straightforward
we'll say dynamodb dot
attribute value
and
we're going to say email because we want
to run a query on email so email is
equal to
s is equal to aws.string
dot
sorry inside that bracket will pass
email now the string
is a function that is given to us by aws
package aws packet is something that
we'll have to import out here all right
uh and similarly with the dyno db so
we'll have to also import the dynamodb
package
so come here on your import and uh
firstly called encoding
json because like i told you golang does
not instant json by default so you need
uh encoding slash json package to uh
use the marshalling and unmarshalling
functions and i need the errors package
also
then i want to
uh get my hands on
the events
and i'll be using it soon
to send responses and
the usual ones uh as you can see i need
dynamdb and i need aws so let's
get those ones
so i'll say aws slash aws
sdk
go slash aws
and i'll say github.com aws slash aws
sdk go slash
dynamo tv
um and what i'll also do i'll also get
this
particular package
um
yeah let me do that for now
so i'll say github.com aws slash aws hd
case
go
slash service slash
dynamo
db slash
dynamodb
i face
all right
now coming
here
you've already
passed this and
after this bracket
you need to specify the table name in
which this
function is going to run so
we'll use the uw string function again
to pass the table name
and after this bracket
you want to use your dyna client to
finally
start getting the item
input is this basically the query that
you created right and get item is the
function that you get in a client
and
you will capture that in result and
error
so
standard practice if there's an error
we'll have to return the error so we'll
return nil
for the value and
we'll return errors dot new
error
failed
to
fetch
record
so um
you must be wondering where is where
does this error come from you've
probably never seen this error right
because this is a new error that i've
created on my own
how can i create my own errors i can
create my own errors like this so error
fail to fetch record
is equal to
fail to fetch
record
and similarly i can define any errors
that i want in this variable uh
defined as a variable right
so you've uh you know created a query
very similar to mongodb write you've
created a query based on the email
because you want to search for that
email so that you can retrieve the user
and you've run the function get in get
item for dynamodb
and you've passed the query to it and
you've received that in something called
as result or you received an error so if
there's an error you handle the error
but if the result is fine and nothing
really happened then you would do
something right
but before that
we'll create a variable called item and
it'll be basically a new user
and here you'll say error is equal to
dynamo
db attribute
dot on marshall map
okay so
dynamodb attribute is another uh by the
way if you have not opened up the dyno
db uh and aws sdk go documentation do
that because i have it open on my other
screen
you can do that as well and then
everything will make a lot more sense
because these are actual packages inside
that main package right
so i'm using those and once you go
through the documentation you'll
understand
where to use uh
which one
or you or if you really don't care about
that you can just keep following along
with what i'm doing but i just recommend
that you just read it because
you know everything will make more sense
here i need
this package right then would be
attribute
this is helping me unmarshalling the
user
so first let me write the whole code
so i'll say result sorry not here
here upper bracket will say result dot
[Music]
item comma
item
and this error if this error is not
equal to nil
what we want to do
we want to return nil comma errors dot
new
error
failed
2
on
marshall
record
so you must be wondering what's
happening here right
so when you get the
data from your dynamodb using the get
item
function into result
you want to unmarshal that into an
actual user
which the front end can understand
as a json basically
so you use the user struct
and you uh you know
take that in a variable called item
right so item is basically um
a variable of type user
and then uh you know you want the data
that's coming from your result dot item
you want that to be unmarshaled and
brought into item so that now whatever
has come as uh json
uh becomes
uh you know the type which is user which
is understood by golang but and it's
captured in a variable called item
right
um so i've tried to explain to you every
single line in case you don't understand
it do check out what's marshalling and
unmarshalling all right
and if you have any error like if you
still have any confusions you can just
put it in the comments below
i'll sort it out for you but it's
nothing very difficult right you're just
um taking what's coming from dynamodb
the json and you're unmargining it to uh
make it into a struct right
which is of type user which has email
first name last name something that can
be understood by golang and you're
capturing that in a variable called item
which is obviously of type user right
that's stuck that we have defined
this is standard practice i do this in
all my other videos as well in case
you're new to this channel i have
hundreds of videos on golang you can
check all of them out
like literally hundreds of videos on go
like right check them out build projects
with me and you'll understand very
everything very easily so if everything
went well
if there was an error obviously you sent
nil and you sent the errors but if
everything went well you would return
the item and then you will return nil
for the error
now you'd want to also work on the fetch
users function the plural fetch users
function
how do you do that you
are passing table name there
as you can see here you're passing table
name and nano client
so table name has been passed which is
obviously your type string
you passed denmark dyna client which is
of type
you already know dynamo dpi face dot
dynamodb api
and you return multiple users
how do you run multiple users you return
basically a slice
of
users
wherein users is the struct that you've
defined right so you're using a struct
you're making a slice of all those users
and then that's what you're returning
i hope that makes sense
if you don't know basics of like of
course like slices and structs then i
highly recommend you check out the basic
tutorials before uh
you get more confused
so
um
i want to use a function but that
dynamic db gives me it's called
scan input
to get access to table name which is aws
dot
string
and
table name that we are already passing
here
got it
and you will say dynaclient
dot scan and you want to scan
the input the query that you just
created
right so here as you saw
uh we had a more elaborate query because
we had to get a particular user with
email
but with fetch users you're just getting
all the users you don't have a specific
query that okay you know for this email
i get a particular user saying get me
all the users
so you don't have any query as such
you're just passing the table name so
that's when your dynaclient.scan you
just pass the input that's it
and
scan is like get all you know you can
say that so if you've used
uh that mongodb it's you have find find
all something like that here you just
have scan
find and find one you have in mongodb so
you just have
scan all right
scan and get item so you're doing scan
to get all the results and you're going
to capture that in a variable called
result and then you'll obviously if you
have an error you know that standard way
to handle errors is like this you'll say
return
nail for the value and
you'll return an error so you'll say
errors dot new
error
failed to fetch record
and
again like we did out here
item
we'll define an item right
the item here is
not just a user it's a slice
of users multiple users because we're
getting all the users from our database
and
again the same thing that we've just
done here we'll do the same thing here
so we'll say error is equal to
just copy the whole thing actually
copy and paste
but there's only one small little change
instead of result.item
you'll have result dot
items
because obviously from your database
you'll get multiple items multiple users
that's what you're getting
and you're returning
your item
and for the error you're turning nil
makes sense
so
we've done quite a bit right we've
already done the get user function and
get user function had fetch user and
fetch users two functions from your
user.com file
now there are three functions left here
and
three functions left here because we've
already taken care of the unhandled
method function you don't have to do
anything more here so just three
functions left here
three functions left here
and all the other files are kind of
complete
right so if you've reached this far
congratulate yourself because
you've come you've come a long way right
um
so now let's start thinking about
how our create user function is going to
work
all right
so for the create user function let's
let's start building that
there's actually not much happening
there
all these functions right uh create user
update user delegator
they're all going to look very very
similar so
i'm going to say user because you know
uh you want to call the create user
function the user package so you'll see
user dot
create user which is
this function that's what you're calling
right and you're passing it three things
request
table name
and a client
make sense
now whatever response
this function returns you want to
capture that in a variable called error
sorry result and you'll get an error
which will be captured in error
and you know the process from here if
there's an error
which means error not equal to nil
you'll return
api response
http dot
status bad request comma
error body and what will be in the other
body everybody in this case by the way
is
sorry the struct that we've already
defined right
so what's there in the everybody it's
aws.string
with a single r sorry string
err dot error
and comma
okay
and you'll return api
response http dot status created
comma result
so if that means if there is no error
everything goes well then you'll say
hdb.status created
all right
and
that's about it that's it actually
that's your create user function there's
nothing more to it
all right and then for your update user
function
very similar you'll obviously call the
user just like you did here user dot
create user here you'll call user dot
update user method so you'll see
update user and you'll pass three things
request
table name and dyna client
and
you'll capture that in result comma
error
and then you'll check again if error is
not equal to nil
you'll return an api response http dot
again
status bad request comma
error body inside the other body
again the same thing it resource string
error dot
error
all right but if everything went well if
the user did get updated then
you'll return api response
and you'll say http dot
status okay
that everything went well and you'll
return the result
so that means what's happening in these
two functions create user update user
is that
these two functions are being called
that means a lot of the logic the main
logic is going to happen in these two
functions right because not much
happened in the in the handlers
similarly let's work on our
delete user function
here you'll say user dot
read user you'll say request comma table
name comma
diana client
here also
though
the only thing you'll run from here is
the error right
if
the user didn't get deleted you'll
return the error you don't need to
return the result any result from the
delete function
so if the result is not equal to nil
you'll return api response
it you know by now what we're going to
say we're going to say status bad
request and we're going to also send the
error body
which will have aws.string
[Music]
and
the error itself
but if everything went well you would
want to return
the response with
status ok
and
ultra nil
for the error
okay
so that's
um that's about it
and
um yeah that's it i think
the entire file is complete now
we don't have anything else to do
i've also gone through the aws uh sdk
documentation i don't think anything
else need to be done in the handler so
everything looks all right to me
uh and now we'll have to work on our uh
user.go file and all these different
functions that exist on our user.com
file
for your create user function
what all it's going to accept depends on
what you're sending from here which is
requestable and nanoclient
so here you'll say request
event start api gateway proxy request
comma table name which will be string
and
data client which will be you already
know then mdbi face
dot nano db api
so what is it going to return it's going
to return
the user that has been just created
or
an error
so here the first thing that we'll do is
we'll create a variable u which is of
type user user being the struct that we
will define that means you will have
email first name and last name all right
so let's start from there
now we'll use u
why did we create this variable u
it's because we want to capture what's
coming from
postman so from postman or from let's
say the terminal wherever we'll send the
json of the user with
the
email first name and last name and that
data needs to be unmarshaled into you so
that golang is able to understand it and
also perform any operations on it
so what you want to do is we want to use
the json encoding json package to call
the unmarshall
function
[Music]
and what you want to do is you want to
pass the request dot body to it
comma ampersand u
[Music]
if error is not equal to nil
and also here
we'll fold the right syntax
for the if statement and if error is not
equivalent then we'll return
nil and we'll return something for the
errors
we'll say error
invalid
user data
but we don't have this error here right
so we don't have
uh this error error fail to and marshall
record
we don't have error in values of data we
just have error field to fetch record
that's all we have defined
so now let's define all the other errors
let me define all the other errors that
i'll need in this entire
file
in the beginning itself
so we'll say error failed
to
unmarshal record
is equal to
fail to unmarshal
record
an error run
and
i'll add
error and valid
user data is equal to
invalid
user data
invalid email also will be there and
valid
email is equal to
invalid email
then we'll have
good
not
marshall
item
and could not delete item so
then we'll have could not
put item so we'll say error
could not
dynamo put
item is equal to
code not dynamo put item
and
user already exists
user does
not exist
user.user
does not exist
so why do i need all these errors
obviously by now you would have
understood i'll just give you an example
that
uh when creating
a user right
if we check if that user already exists
then we don't need to create that user
so that's why we need this kind of an
error
and if you want if you're updating a
user then or deleting a user we can use
this that user does not exist so why are
you trying to update that user right
that's why um i'm just thinking about
all the type of error functions i'll
need error statements i'll need
so depending on that i've just created
them
so coming back to your create user
right
here
now we will start validating
uh the email so we'll say
validators dot
validators is the package that we have
created together right this one
and the function that we created in that
package was is email
valid
and you is
the variable that you defined and now
after unmarshaling the request that you
uh in the body body is of the request
that you got from let's say postman or
from the terminal as json you captured
that in you
so now you can now golang can easily
understand you because it's unmarked
right it's not json anymore so you can
access u.e mail
and
you can run the validation function on
it so here the spelling is wrong
so it should have been
is email valid
and you'll return
nil
errors
dot new
error
invalid
email
right and
now the reason why i created this
uh error is because
i want to
see if that user already exists
right so if that user already exists
then you don't need to create it so we
need to throw an error
so we'll check
if the user already exists right so i
won't put that comment actually i was
just trying to show you
so
to check if the user actually exists you
have to run the fetch user function you
will say u dot
email comma table name comma diana
client
and
you'll
capture whatever
comes from this function in current user
and we won't handle the error so i'll
put a
blank there
so if current user is not equal that
means there is
this user exists right
if current user is not equal to nil
and
length of
current user dot
email
is not equal to zero
then you return
nil comma
errors dot new
error
user already exists
and so all of this if the user exists
but if the user doesn't exist you will
just save that user right so how do you
save that so first to save that
obviously
uh whatever you now have in you you want
to start
um
you want to start marshalling it right
so that dynamodb can understand it now
so you'll say dynamodb
attribute dot
marshall map
you
and you'll capture this in av
and you'll check for the error
so if there's an error we'll return nil
and errors dot new
error could not
marshall
item
which we've already defined we've
already defined this error right
and
now
you want to start creating your
um
data that you will be sending to
dynamodb
so how would you do that you'll say
dynamodb
dot put
item
input
item is av
comma
table name is aws dot
string table name
and finally you'll say
dynaclient
dot port item
and you'll send
this input that you've defined here so
yes missed the is equal to sign by
mistake
similar to fetch users right you created
this input and then you call the dyna
client function similarly you're doing
that the same thing here you're calling
the put item
function
and you'll capture that
in a blank character blank variable or
and or you'll get an editor from here
and if
error is there then you'll just handle
it very easily you'll say return l comma
headers dot new
error
could not
time output item right you've created
this error already
but if everything went well you just
want to return
the user
awesome
so this is your create user function
and now you're
left with update user and delete user
everything else you have taken care of
right the handlers.go file is complete
api response is complete as as
email validate is complete and main.go
is complete
and i think for our user file we have uh
imported all the packages except for
validators so you need validators so
you'll say
github.com the validators package that
you've already created we talk i'm
talking about that one so we'll say go
serverless yt
slash pkg slash
validators
let me also check what else am i missing
for handlers i think i've already
imported user
and i don't need any more packages
for api response
um
i don't need more packages
for is email valid i don't need anything
else
my main.go file probably i might have
missed something so it has handlers it
has os
events lambda aws session dynamodb
dynamic dbi face
so everything is proper based on the aws
sdk go right check out this
documentation you'll know why i'm
importing these packages and how i've
used these functions you already know
that because you've been
building it with me all right
um
then we'll come here again back to our
user.com file
and let's start working on the update
user function
so what does it accept accepts request
which is of type events
dot api gateway request comma table name
which is string comma
dyna client which is of type dynamodb i
face
dot dynamodb
api
returns a user the updated user
and
or i mean i mean r it sends back an
error
and we're going to do a lot of things
which are going to be very similar to
the create user function which is
basically we create the user
first we create the user right which is
the variable u which is of type user
and we're going to unmarshall just like
we did
uh we're going to unmarshall the
request body that you get so request dot
body
comma ampersand you
so by mistake
um yeah so i have to close the bracket
here because
this is together
and
this is this variable u
okay
and
here are not equal to nil
if you don't want to follow along you
can just copy and paste this part right
i'm not copying and pasting because uh
this syntax might be new to many people
because it's dynamite kind of working
with dynamodb
so i'm uh writing everything by hand
but if you want to copy and paste if
you're very comfortable with dynamodb
go ahead and do that you don't need to
you know practice along with me
then you want to fetch the user and see
if that user even exists so you'll say
u.e mail comma table name comma
then a client
and you want to capture that in current
user
and you want to check for that current
user so
if current user
not equal to nil
this is exactly what you did in the
create
function as well
and length of
current user dot email
is equal to equal to zero
then you'll return nil comma
errors dot new
error
user does not exist
so for the create user function we were
checking uh for the user associated with
that email because we wanted to see you
know if that user only exists we don't
want to add that user but for update
we're doing the reverse we're checking
for that user because
only that user exists we can update the
data for that user makes sense
and
exactly the same things we'll do because
now we want to start so now that the
user uh you know um
if the user doesn't exist we'll throw an
error but if the user exists then you
want to start
updating
the table with the new data how do you
do that whatever you've unmarshaled
right now from json to you know
unmarshalled to something that golang
understands now you want to start
marshaling it to something that animaldb
understands
so you already know what you want to use
you want to use the marshall map
function
i want to pass you to it because you've
just unmarshaled
and
which package is a part of so it's part
of the dynamodb
attribute package
we'll capture it in a variable called av
or we'll get an error
and now we can easily handle the error
so we'll if error not equal to nil
return l comma
errors dot new
error could not martial item this one
really really straightforward now you
just want to create your input item and
then you want to just call the dyna
client function
only two steps remaining so you'll say
input is equal to ampersand dyna
modb
dot put item input
and the item is
equal to av
comma the table name
will be equal to aws dot
string
table name
and the last thing is you'll use dyna
client
dot put item
and you'll pass the input
and if error not equal to nil
nil comma
errors dot
new
error
could not dynam output item
return ampersand u comma nil
so now even my update function is
complete everything looks okay
and all i want to do now
is
um
run the
gomot id command
to get all of the packages that
are
you know not there
so i think it's taking a while
i can't find my phone anyways
so um
while that's happening in the background
we can start working on the delete user
function
so as you can see it's all
installed
i had a couple of issues actually
um as you can see
and most of the issues were because i
had a couple of spelling mistakes here
instead of sdk i did an skd you know so
a small small few mistakes i had made
just make sure you get these right um
you can easily get them on aws sdk go
um you know
documentation or if i put mostly i'll
put this code on github
so you can just pick it up from there
all right make sense
just pick it up from there instead of
typing it all yourself because i made a
couple of mistakes so it was taking a
while
but now it's installed all these
packages
so in your user.go file everything works
perfectly right
like we don't know if it works perfectly
but everything looks perfect to me
and all the packages are in place
all you need to do now
is work on your
read user function which is actually the
most
actually the like the easiest function
so it takes request
event start
api gateway request comma table name
which is of type string
done a client which is a type already
know you already know that
dot
dynamic api all right
so what do you want to put in the
function definition you want the email
of the user right
so request dot
query string parameters
and the parameters
email
then you'll create your input to the
function which is of type dynamodb
and dot
delete item input
item
input
star
dynamodb
dot attribute
value
basically you're passing the email and
then finding the user and deleting that
user with it associated to that
particular email right
nothing complicated
so you'll say aws dot
string
and you pass email to that
after this you'll say table name
here ws dot string
pass the table name
and now that you have your input ready
just like we've done all other functions
you take the dyna client
you call the dynamodb function which is
delete item in this case
and
you pass the input to it
input basically has your query for
deletion which is
the email id
and you get the error
and if there is an error
you'll return
errors dot new
error could not delete item
perfect
otherwise you just return nil nothing
basically that means that the user has
been deleted now i'm sure there are a
lot of errors
because i'm not using any
type checking extension or any golang
extension right so there will be a lot
of errors here
so i need to start solving them one by
one before i deploy it to the cloud
so to find those issues and to fix them
i'll head over to my terminal
and i'll head over to the cmd folder and
i'll say go build
main.go
and
starts giving me errors right so it says
on this file
line number eight
um yeah i can see the issue it has to be
double right that's what makes it the
or operator
so
you'll run the command again and now
you'll get all these nice
errors that we were expecting right and
now you want to go start solving them
one by one
so starting from line 37 all the way to
line 145 too many errors so when it says
too many errors that means that even
after you solve these it'll give you uh
many more errors right
so this is why i don't really you know
use
extensions because
because golang takes care of everything
it tells you which exact line which part
what you're missing you don't like
it's a no-brainer right you don't have
to apply a lot of brains just solve
these issues just like woodland wants
you to and everything will run so that's
why i'm so chilled out all the time man
so if i can go back to your
code
on line 37 what could be the issue it's
that i have not put comma here and comma
here
basic syntax issues right that's what it
says it says basic index issues
here also you need to put a comma
and let's keep putting commas wherever
you know i think
um
it will
uh need commas so this needs comma here
which is line 58 in my case you can
check it out where
you know it is for you
for create user again
i'll just put a comma here just to be
sure
and i'll put a comma
in the input part which is
this
all right
and in the update user function
again let's go to the input
area
here i've put the commas so i don't see
any issues here
and for delete definitely you need to
put a comma here as well as here
as well as here so
now if we run it
a lot of the errors have gone away right
and now you have
some other errors
there are some syntax errors also like
four syntax errors and one
this one also that you're not able to
refer to this function so let's try and
fix those as well at the same time
so let's hover over back to our code let
me see the line first line says 88
line 88 blah blah blah blah blah yes
m is small whereas m should be large
what was i thinking am i stupid
you know that i was not able to
that i didn't make the m uh you know
large because obviously the
function is martial map with
the capital m right so this just means
that no matter how stupid you are golang
takes care of everything right so you
don't need to be the smartest guy on the
planet
so let's look at other stupid mistakes
one zero eight
comma missing it's a syntax error super
simple right it's even telling you
expecting comma right i mean
how obvious can
error statements be and then people you
know tell me download this extension i
don't have downloaded any extension man
golang does everything for me
and uh missing statement after label 125
125
missing statement after label blah blah
blah blah blah yeah obviously
the is equal to sign is off
and then 147 147
put a comma here auto after 147
and then
unexpected
yep
found it
now let's run it now let's see some more
errors
yes so it found us some more errors
and now you have to go to line number 66
76 and 140
but these are not
syntax errors so here you'll have to
think a little bit as to why there's an
error there
so head over back to your code on line
66. line 66
yeah so it says
let's look at the error it says
cannot use results dot disorder items
and something something something to do
with this function called unmarshall map
that is because you're receiving items
not item you're receiving multiple items
right so you can't use that marshall map
function here you'll just re use
unmarshall
list
of maps
super simple man super simple 76 line 76
all right it says blah blah blah blah
blah
request our body see it says request dot
body undefined
and it also says does not have body with
capital b
right
i mean you don't you can be the
stupidest person on the planet and fix
this issue because you just had to make
this b capital right
so that's how intuitive go language and
then you go to line number 140 line
number 140 i mean i can guarantee you
that you can't do any like something
like this with any other language right
it says there's a problem with this
function obviously because there's a
spelling mistake here
parameters so everything is fixed now
and now let's see
so it gives me another error that says
unmarked list of map is wrong yeah
because i made a mistake again it should
have been
unmarshalled list of maps
not map
awesome
so now
now that your user.go file is
sorted as in it first shows you the
syntax errors you've solved them then
you solve the logical errors and now
it's giving you some issues with the
handlers file right handler.com it's
giving you all these syntax errors we'll
solve them then we'll give you some
logical errors we'll solve them as well
and then we're good to go all right so
we're on the right path
and now let's
go back to our code
so open up your code and start from line
19 line 19.
put a comma here
line 42
42 per comma here it's because saying
it's exactly expecting a comma from you
right
and line 54
put a comma
line 59
blah blah blah blah blah blah comma
line 66 and 72 96 for a comma 72 for a
comma
all right
now you start getting the real
errors right the real errors
so um line 22 we just solved this issue
on the other file line 22
because the spelling of parameters is
wrong
and now you want to worry about
line
nine
line nine
so one thing to notice is that it's line
9 but of another file api response would
go so
open up the api smaller go file and here
i can see there's an issue
all right
i have fixed the issue it was basically
to do with
uh those brackets and now it's starting
to show me
issues with main.go file which is what i
want i want to fix the main.go file
issues but on line 44
line 44
let me see what's happening
okay yeah i can see it i can see the
issue it's basically
all the cases have to be together
and by mistake i'd written this outside
the bracket
also the switch bracket
and i've included inside
so that error should also go away
and now when i do this it's created the
go build may not go file for me so let
me see if it has yeah i can see the main
file i just have to
move it here
to my build folder
and i've created the build file without
any issues no errors right
so now let's start
uh the deployment process
before you do anything else you need to
first
create a zip file so you'll just
come here you'll say zip minus jrm
build
slash main.zip
from build
slash main so build is your folder main
is the build that you've created for in
your folder and
build slash main.zip will be the zip
file using the zip function maybe in
your linux you don't have zip you'll
have to install it using sudoku apt-get
zip
so
now if we check here
we can see the main.js file in my build
folder
and now we're ready to kind of start
uploading it on lambda or aws lambda
but as remember as you remember i told
you that i have windows installed on
that i'm running the wsl on that i'm
running this
ubuntu and on top of that i've built
this
folder right so i need to be able to
access this main.zip file from my
uh windows
from my windows to be able to install
like upload it on my hero player school
and lambda aws lambda
dashboard so for that i'll do something
[Music]
so to in order to help me to do that i
have to run
this command explorer.exe
dot
and now hopefully it should open yeah it
has it has opened up the
explorer at this location for me and
i'll copy this
i'll put this on my desktop
awesome
and now i can start to deploy this on my
aws console
so you want to start deploying
but there's one thing i wanted to change
is this
table name
so i'll keep this table name same as my
other name of my
program
go serverless yt
okay just for consistency's sake
because we will have to create this
table in dynamodb
and
let me just search
uh if i was using the other table name
sorry i'll just ctrl z
and i'll just see if i was using this
table name anywhere else in any other
file
oh it's this only place there's only one
place i was using it
so here's the table name has to be
changed
you will say go
serverless righty
okay
and now is when we start deploying
so
log into your console
and head over to lambda you have to just
create function
go
serverless
right
so we're using golang one point x i
think we'll have to change the uh
execution rules create new role
from aws policy templates this option is
what you have to select
and the role name
go
serverless
righty
executor
from the templates you have to choose
simple microservice permissions create
function
successfully created right
now you want to change the handler
so as you know our main uh the file that
we'll be uploading is called the main
file that's what our build is called
right so we'll have to change the
handler to main upload
the zip file and upload it go back to
aws
and go to dynamodb
and you will click on
create table
table name so table name is what you
selected here go server syt
simple right because we have kept
everything
with the same name so
and primary key so it says enter the
partition key name i think this is the
primary key
yeah it's the primary key so the primary
key in our case is email
which is string obviously
and everything else is same and we can
just create the database active it's now
active so now you can proceed to the
next stage
which is
configuring your
api gateway
so head over to your api gateway
create api
you want to build a rest api
protocol is test
select new api here
and now you want to put the api name
which is go
serverless
yd
and
you then create the api
from the actions
select create method
select any
and here you'll select integration type
lambda function
and
check this use lambda proxy integration
and give the name of the lambda function
here which is
go serverless yt
and you have to also have to ensure this
is checked default timeout
now we need to deploy our api so
from actions
deploy api
select new stage
stage name is staging
and
deploy
so this is
your url that you get here
which you will be using right now to
test
so let's test it out i'm
expecting some errors to be there
but not a problem
let's clear our screen
and
um
first we'll have to build this command
so just give me a second
so here are my four commands
and obviously uh this is
post which is creating a user this is
get all users get a particular user by
email id
and this last command is for
update
now we can use postman or you can you
just use curl which is the same thing
right and you set your header and you
tell it what's the request which is post
and the data that you need to send which
is email which is my email address my
name my last name
and
this is the the unique link that i just
got
this
link is the unique link that i just got
from my
invoke url okay so
i'll post these comma i i'll post this
command somewhere how do i post it now
okay so i'll what i'll do is i'll upload
this project on github and then in the
description i think i'll just post these
commands so that you know you can just
copy and paste them directly
uh i think that'll be the best option or
you can just use postman i mean you have
to use these commands if you don't want
to all right
and similarly for uh the update
you say it's request put you give the
new data is going to find email based on
that because emails are primary key as
you already know
and this is my api link
these are the four commands i need one
more command which is
the delete command
so i'll change that
to this
so you'll get all these in the um
an api gateway documentation on how to
call these apis you can get that also
and so i'm just copying those and i'm
just changing
uh those commands all right
so what we'll do now is we'll try and
test it
i'm pretty sure there'll be some error
it'll fail
but
let's do it anyway
oh so it worked it worked all right so
it created this user
which is amazing
let's run the second command
sorry this command
and now it's not copying and pasting it
now we're running the get all users
command
so we'll get all the users so only one
user is there so it's getting that
and
then we'll get the particular user
the particular user has this email id
it will get that user also for me
because there's only one user right now
yeah so that's also working and now we
will work on our
put
function so
it's taking my
email address and changing my first name
to la la la and last time to blah blah
blah blah blah right so it's done that
so even update is working
and now we have to work on
the delete function
so if the delete function works
it won't
return anything so we'll check
if that user is still there so we're
getting all the users
so that means delete work because it's
an empty array right the same user is
not there anymore
perfect
so that means everything is working i
hope you enjoyed uh this tutorial
uh it's a it's a long video i know
there's a lot to follow there's a lot to
learn there and i hope you really
enjoyed it i hope you learned a lot in
this uh
project
and um very soon i'll have i'll have one
more project coming up with serverless
stack but it's a little more advanced
we'll have multiple lambda functions
we'll have cloud formation we'll have
you know those cloud formation scripts
so and everything will be through
uh you know yaml files and then aws cli
and we'll also use aws sam for the
entire setup so that's going to be
really complicated um so make sure
you've done the aws lambda uh you know
that video and you have done this
serverless video and then you read up a
little bit more about how serverless
works and all the aw technologies and
that will really help you in the next
upcoming video that'll be slightly
longer actually much longer and they'll
have like way more complicated project
right so the point of that is where this
is like a monolith serverless project
right that will be serverless
microservices project there will be api
gateway cloud formation
uh there will be a lot more technologies
i will use aws sam for all the writing
all the
configuration files
anyhow so i hope you're enjoying it and
do subscribe to this channel if you
haven't already and there are hundreds
of videos on golang on my channel check
them out and i also keep sharing some
nice advice on uh you know your
development career so you keep watching
that as well
all right so see you uh and connect with
me on linkedin there's the linkedin uh
link in my description box below thank
you in this video we're doing something
very interesting we're building an
intelligent chatbot so till now we've
built many slack bots but most of them
have had a hard coded
command and response but in this case
we're building an nlp aware completely
intelligent slack bot so we'll be using
four different technologies one is
obviously golang because we'll be
writing the code in golang then we have
slack to interact with the bot
then we have vit dot ai to understand
nlp responses and wolfram to actually
run the computational models and can get
the responses from the internet okay so
vid is a technology that facebook has
developed it's very similar to
dialogflow by google or lex by amazon
and you can basically train it to
understand different um
sentences so for example if i want to
find out who the president of india is
uh so you can have uh different type of
queries right you can ask him uh you can
ask the what who is the president of
india or
who is the president of india now or
who's currently who's the current
president of india so all of these
things right all of these statements
they uh
they basically mean the same thing that
who's the president of india right now
right but then uh
slack doesn't understand it golang
doesn't understand it so vet is the
intelligent nlp part where vic can be
trained with all these hundreds of
different statements to understand that
you're basically trying to say the same
thing so it so it basically uh creates
like a confidence score to uh tell you
that okay i've understood the query now
and uh you know i understand your
question so what is that nlp
intelligence engine right and then once
you have once it has understood the
query you can send it to wolfram
world fam is the competition and so
wolfram has the answer of who the actual
president of india is it doesn't have
that answer wolfram has that answer so
so vit basically can be trained with
hundreds of different sentences to
actually understand uh what your query
means and then it will send the query uh
to wolfram and then we'll get the answer
and then uh you know we'll get the
answer to slack so let me take you
through the entire diagram of how we're
going to do it so the user will enter a
message it goes to slack
and slack then sends the message to us
go lank server golang server then sends
it to vit
whit then sends it again to golang
server and from there we can again send
to vol from because there's no
connection between width and volt ram
and slack and width right so our golang
server is going to be the connection
between all of these things from wolf
wolf ram we want to send the response to
slack so it has to go through our golang
servers right everything i'm sure makes
sense now
and there are going to be some packages
that we'll have to use to interact with
it to interact with cool uh wolfram to
interact with slack so slacker is my
favorite package if you've done my other
previous slack bot tutorials i'm sure
you know that there are many on my
channel so you can go ahead and do those
as well so slacker is the package that i
often use so you can look at this somali
slash lacquer right on it go on github
so i've kept these tabs open because all
of these uh are important to us so
that's why i've kept all of these tabs
open right i'll take you through all of
these one by one so slacker is the um
wrapper on top of the slack go package
uh which is a wrapper on top of the
slack bear uh api right right so this is
like a third level abstraction of uh how
we can build a slack bot and this makes
our job very very easy so that's why i
always use slacker so now that i've
shown you this i can cancel it out i can
you know close that tab then we'll be
using uh with our commands that we get
from slacker the user that he enters the
command it we process it and are using
our slacker and then
uh we send it to witco right uh using
vidgo vs into vid and that's how of it
will process it
so with go you can think of it as a
wrapper uh around wits apis written in
golang so you can use this as functions
you all you have to just call these
functions that are written in with go
all right
and now uh
with gives us some response that we need
to we need to send to wolfram right but
the response that vid gives us has
uh it's a really big uh
json
and to process that json
it's uh it's quite challenging in the
sense that uh
if
if you know how to work with json with
golang you know that it's not very
straightforward you have to use struct
sometimes you have to use unmarshalling
and all that
so uh i found this package called gjson
so first let me close fit go so i found
this packet called g json it helps you
query json very very easily so for
example and now this guy is a genius
obviously so i have to give him that so
ted wall
or actually there are so many more
contributors in him so these guys are
geniuses because they have built a
package that helps you
take a json like this and then just
access them like you would in something
like javascript right which is so simple
so you if you wanted to get name uh so
inside this entire json object is this
uh key value pair called name which is
an object itself so you can if you
wanted name and last you could just say
name dot last right and you could get
access to anderson
and if you have worked with golang you
know how difficult it is to actually
restructure
a json object like this and then get an
actual access to something like this
right
so uh so this library makes it very easy
and i'm going to use this in this video
and also in the future videos i'm
trying to use this a lot more uh so that
that will save us a lot of time right
building all these structs and then
unmargining and marshalling it and then
trying to access this value and it's a
lot of work so we'll use this ge json
right so now that i've shown this to you
i'll just close it off
and
uh to work with wolfram now wolfram is a
big uh technology right it has a lot of
apis it's quite complicated
so there is somebody who has written a
go wolfram
uh package for us
now this
looks simple but as you can see there's
so many structs right all these
different stocks are there
that help you to work with that help you
to basically translate or unmarshal the
data coming from the apis and then it's
a big file it's just one file but it's a
big file
right so somebody has done it for us
they're calling the wolfram uh api
and then getting all the data for us all
right
so all we have to do is just call the
functions inside
the go over from package
like so
right so you can create a client you can
get query results
simple and straightforward
so we'll be using google form like i
said and we'll just close that off right
now
and the other thing that we need to use
uh
you know uh so you know that the way i
manage uh environment so i don't uh so i
since i make very beginner friendly
videos i don't try and confuse you with
uh you know trying to set your
environment so i just use os dot set
environment and os dot get environment
that's i do something very very simple
and straight forward but
this is the right way of uh setting that
environment so
i'm uh if you might also know that i'm
also a ruby developer i've been a ruby
developer for many many years and ever
since golang
you know i started using golang i
stopped using ruby uh many years back
so uh so this is a go uh you know
implementation of
very famous and rupees.nbc very popular
ruby gem right dot and here you call
them libraries but in ruby you call them
gems so this is very very popular and
this lets you manage
uh and your environment variables very
easily right so all we'll have to do is
we'll have to create a dot and file and
we'll put all of our
uh you know keys there and then we'll be
able to just uh load it simply with go
dot invert load and then we can easily
use them with os.get and environment
variables right
so
this also means that i won't be pushing
my environment file into github so you
need to create your own environment file
with your your own apis api keys so pay
attention when i show you how to get
your api keys
uh
because that can be confusing to some
people right
so this is the golang sorry the wolfram
uh portal
uh
now one one uh thing that i have to tell
you about wolfram uh website is it's
very slow uh it can be a frustrating
experience to work with it because the
website somehow is stuck in the 19 uh
sorry the early 2000s it's not
it's not a new website it doesn't work
like a modern website would and the api
is also kind of shaky so obviously the
the wolfram go package makes it easy for
us but uh but i'm just telling you
because
if you can see this it's still lowering
since yesterday actually so
don't get frustrated just try to you
know be patient and also it gives you
only 2 000 requests
per month so and it you can make only 20
apps uh at one go otherwise you'll have
to upgrade so just make sure you stay
within those limits if you don't want to
uh pay a lot of money to upgrade all
right
and
i have created these two projects here
so
if you want to create a new project
you can just go ahead and say get an app
id
and before that obviously you have to
sign in to you have to create an account
in wolfram alpha you have to sign up and
then you have to head over to
developer.wolfram.alpha.com
and uh as you noticed i clicked get an
app id a long time back and sometimes
you have to refresh it
and sometimes very weirdly it would have
logged me out but no not today it has
not logged me out now so anyhow so i'll
just click it again so now it's asking
me for my application name so i'll say
uh new
nlp all right so i'll send you an lp
what
this is the youtube
demo
bot
if you don't give a description it won't
let you create a new app so i'll say
create an app
so it has given me this app id but but i
won't be using this app id i'll be using
my old app id the the one that i had
created yesterday which is the nlp what
uh sorry the wit ai one which has uh
already has 13 total queries the reason
for this is very simple uh with wolfram
uh if you have not uh if you've not
waited for 24 hours uh it won't let you
use uh
as in it gives you a lot of error
sometimes and unpredictable type of
error so it says
uh you know invalid app id or some some
editor like that so i looked it up on
stack overflow and the answer that i
found was that you have to wait 24 hours
sometimes or at least 12 hours for the
api to work correctly so
uh if you create an api right now api
right now chances are you won't be able
to
run this program properly and we'll say
error app id invalid or something like
that okay
so that's the thing with wolfram alpha i
know there are a lot of quirks with this
so basically just remember to get
your uh
app id from here and that's all that's
all you need to do at wolfram also
website
all right so just copy and paste it with
yourself
and then let's come to vid ai so here
you'll have to log in using facebook
because it's a technology built by
facebook so we'll say continue with
facebook
it takes a while
so i have all these bots built up and
now we'll create another app called new
app
and let's call it then
i already have a new llp so i'll just
say with ai
i'll just call it
youtube demo all right
so
remember to keep it open and we'll say
create and language is english
and now it has
a couple of things on on the left side
right so you have your intense entities
so we'll go to intense we'll create an
intent
and we'll call it
uh
let's see if there's a
wolf ram intent already
so there's no old friend intent
so we'll just call it
wolf
ram
and next
right so we have this
uh intent
now we'll have to create entities so
we'll create an entity
and we'll
find a built-in entity so we'll
look for wolfram
so the integration between wit ai and
wolfram is so deep that they actually
have an entity called wolfram search
query so
vdi would come to know that this is a
wolfram search query and needs to send
it to wolfram
so it'll give us a relevant format so
we'll say next
and now we have our entity setup and
this role is added by vitiai themselves
and now whatever uh you send it to uh
with ai right these will show up in your
utterances so we won't actually write
utterances and train our vti right now
this is that's not the scope of this
video you can find thousands of videos
that train your vti or your dialog flow
bot right we won't be training it we
will be sending it very straightforward
questions that will just identify as
uh
a wolfram uh
query and send it forward so for example
if i said
what uh sorry
who is
the president
of india right
so with 92 confidence it is understood
uh this question right so we don't have
to train it right now that means
so um but if you wanted to train it for
this sim same query with multiple
different uh statements you could do
that right so anyways we won't be doing
this like i said we won't be training it
we're just sending it straight queries
which are directly sent to wolfram
so now that i've shown you the go dot
end package i'll just delete that i'll
just close that tab as well and i've
shown you this video
uh which doesn't work anymore so we'll
close it so we won't be using any of the
packages that have been used in this
video we're completely rebuilding
everything from scratch
so we'll close this as well
and we just need to keep our uh
you know these videos tabs open just in
case you need your uh
app id so yeah i'm not showing you how
to get your app id and video right so
all you have to do i think um i don't
remember correctly you go to settings
and you will take your server access
token this is the one that you want to
take
all right so just copy and paste that
copy and keep it for now at least
then let's go to our slack so
slack
i'll have to go to
dot com api.slack.com apps
and here
uh
if you have done my previous uh slack
bot tutorials which there are plenty of
you have built all these bots with me
and today we are building another bot
from scratch
and we'll call it the youtube
demo app all right and i'll select all
tech as my space
so it's called youtube demo and you have
to switch on the socket mode so that it
can catch up messages in real time so
we'll say enable
and we'll call it the socket token
generate
and you need to save this somewhere and
keep it
and but i'll come back for all of these
api keys uh you know but you can keep
them somewhere safe if you want
and then we'll go to our event
subscriptions
we'll have to switch these on and we'll
have to give it some events to subscribe
to so we'll say app mention because
we'll mention our bot
and then we'll say message.im
so these are the events that the bot
will subscribe to so that it comes to
know when something is happening so like
let's let's say somebody mentions the
bot and sends it a message it will come
to know right
so i'll just say
message.groups as well
and
i will say
messenger npm i am
and i think that is about it i don't
need to add any more
uh events
so always the trick with the slack is
add more events than you think you'll
need and add more oauth permissions so
we'll come here and we'll add some oauth
permissions so for now i'll just save
these chinese changes
exchange is saved let's go to oauth
permissions
and
here we have to
add some more scope so these scopes were
added based on the events that we
subscribe to but we have to add more
scopes right so again with scopes the
trick is to take more scopes from your
from oauth of slack than you need so for
example i need uh this one here
called channels read and
chat
right
because i wanted to be able to write to
a channel right
and i will say
i am read and i am right instant message
i am basically stands for instant
message
and i'll say mpm i am an npm read and
write as well
i might not need most of these
permissions but i'm just going to keep
them anyways like i said you know you
uh they're so if you've seen one of my
like my previous videos of slack you
know that a lot of uh errors happen
because you don't have enough
permissions and slack the problem with
slack is it won't even give you errors
uh the right errors right so you'll keep
struggling with the error for a long
time and you won't know what happened
because you won't get the right error so
and most of them are to do with uh
permissions
in the sense your bot just won't work
and you won't come no why it's not
working
so i think i have all the permissions
that i needed and
that is about it for me and i'm going to
install it to my workspace
and asks me
if i can give it these permissions i
said allow
so now it's given me a bot user token so
this is important and in our
basic information the slack the socket
token educated and that's that's
important right
so it's called the youtube demo just
remember that so we'll have to
uh
refer it right
we'll have to mention it in our slack
channel
so if we go to our slack channel and i
say
youtube
demo
so uh it's his youtube demo is not in
this channel yet so do i want to add it
i'll say yes add channel so add youtube
demo to this channel
only then we'll be able to
interact with it right
now
what we'll do is we'll actually start
creating that project
so i'm not sure if you can yeah i think
you can see my power shell so even if
you're on windows or uh which is which
is i am i'm in windows and i'm using
powershell even if you're on ubuntu and
using terminal or mac using terminal the
commands will be exactly the same
so what i'll do is i'll say
mkdir
and youtube
demo
nlp
all right
so i'll just
go inside that
and here i'll say go mod in it and
github.com
and it'll be what
so uh the mod file is initiated like
this so if you're from a javascript
background this is very similar to npm
in it so it creates a mod file which
contains all the package that we'll be
using in this project
and this is the direct
the absolute link that we'll use to
access other files in our project so i'm
not sure why the enter is not working on
this maybe something to do with my
internet
yeah so it has created a mod file let me
just check
now what we have to do is we have to
start getting our packages that we need
the external packages
that we'll be using in our project
so you can give these in commas or you
don't if you even if you don't give them
it's not a problem so you'll say
github.com
slash
uh if you're from a javascript
background this is exactly the same as
npm install and this is the name of the
package and this is the github link for
it
so
like you have uh the npm library the npm
website nbmjs.com where all these
packages decide uh golang doesn't have
something like that so you have to get
everything from github.com
right
and
what we'll also do is we'll get go get
github.com
slash
dot env
and when you also get go get
github.com
slash
uh the
the slacker
slack bot uh library that we need
and we need
the g json the one that allows us to
query
json with golang
json
sorry you have to write go get in front
of it
and then the last one we need is
[Applause]
vidco
the one created by alex
so we have all the packages in place
and all we have to do is
open up our vs code
and start writing the project
right
and here obviously the file that you'll
create is main.go
on top you'll write package main
you'll write import and import all the
packages that you need
and here you'll have to
write the main function so we'll say
funk main
and the funk main will have
quite a bit of a code
and at the same time
we will have our dot and b file
in the dot envy file you'll have four
things one is
slack
bot token
then you have your slack app token
then you have your bit
ai
token
and your wolfram
app id
right
so volfam app id have shown you how to
get it right from where to copy it
i already have it copied in some place
in my laptop so i'm just going to come
and paste it here
with ai token i've already shown you
where to get it from
copy and paste it here
and then we have our slack bot and slack
app token
for the slack
bot token you'll get that in your
oauth and permissions you'll get your
slack bot token and in your basic
information
you'll get your slack app token here in
socket token that we created the one
that starts with xapp is your slack app
token the one that starts with xp is
your slack bot token all right
so now that that's clear i'm going to
copy and paste my
uh
sorry i forgot to copy my
tokens so i'll just copy this i'll say
copy
and
this is my slack app token
and slack what token
i have to go back
to oauth and permissions
and copy it
so our environment file is ready
now we will have to import some packages
that i know we'll use when we
will use context
and coding slash json
we'll use fmp to print out stuff
and json to you know work with json log
and os for our environment variables
and as of now i need
slash shoho slash
go dot environment
right
we we need uh other packages as well
with for working with slack and wolfram
and width but i'll
introduce them one by one
so
in our funk main
the first thing that we write is go
dot environment
and here we'll use the load function to
load
the environment file
okay
then we'll create a bot
so we'll say bot
is equal to so here we have to create a
new client for our slack bot
and that can only be done
if you have the slacker
package so we'll say github.com
okay so let's create our bot
the bot basically will have
slacker dot
new client
os
dot get environment
and slack bot
token
comma os
dot get environment
slack
app
token
so these are the two things required for
our bot
so let me see if the brackets have been
properly closed
so we have
we have an extra packet here by mistake
to remove that
and there's one more extra bracket here
by mistake so we have to remove that as
well
so all the squiggly lines have gone away
and uh there's a squig line here with
bot it's saying
it's declared but not used but we'll use
it soon so you do not worry about that
and then there are squiggly lines with
all these packages
you will be using all these packages
soon
so you don't have to worry about them as
well
okay
now uh since we are in the process of
creating these
different variables
i think it's uh a good time to create
our with ai client and our
wolfram client as well
or
[Music]
maybe i'll do that after a while anyways
so
one thing that i have to do is i have to
create a
function
called print command
events
if you followed my other
slack tutorials as well slack slack bot
tutorials then you know that
this function is simply to print out the
events
that the bot uh
subscribes to so whenever we put a
give a command to a bot
uh it acts as an event and it uh
publishes to the
command line we want it to be open to
the command line so that we come to know
what's happening so we'll create this
function now
so this function will be created above
funk main
and as you know we'll call it print
command events
so in one of the previous videos i've
already
explained
uh the inner dynamics of this function
basically your
passing command event here
and we'll save for event
we'll just range over this analytics
channel
and we'll
print the
timestamp
of the command the command itself
the parameters that it received
and the event name
so let's say fmt dot
println
we'll say command
events
and fmd dot
println again
event dot
timestamp
fmt dot
print ln again
say event dot
command
fmg dot brilliant render
and event dot
parameters like i said
and the event itself
[Applause]
and just an empty line
so our
print command events function is ready
now i had a couple of packages here and
when i pressed
save
since i'm using this uh
golang
plugin it removes all the packages that
i'm not using the code right
so by mistake don't press ctrl s because
it will remove all the packages that we
had uh you know written here but it's
not a problem so what this uh golang
plugin does also does is that when i use
a package here it also adds it here on
top so it's a two-way street
anyhow so we have written our command
for printing the uh the events the
command events
and now we'll start working on our
uh
pod.com function which basically handles
the command that we'll send to the bot
but before that we just have to write in
some code
that will help us
stop the program and we wanted to so
we'll say context dot
with
cancel
again this is standard code that we've
written in
all of our previous
uh
slack bots right slackbot codes
so in case you're new to this channel
there are hundreds of i won't say
hundreds with here at least tens of uh
slackbot tutorials do check take a look
to check them out
is equal to bot dot listen
ctx
and if there is an error that means
error not equal to nil
we will say log dot
fatal
and we log out the error all right
so like i said this is standard code
and i'm using the log package here and
now it's installed the package for me
it's imported that right
earlier it was giving this quick line
here
so we have uh the
outlines of our function ready and now
comes the main part which you need to
pay a lot more focus to
attention to sorry it's the bot.command
function which basically helps us to
uh
you know understand the commands
that we give to the slackbot and then
work with that so we'll say bot dot
command
and here we'll uh you know put the
command that we'll send to the plot
and here we'll say slacker dot command
definition
and inside command definition is where
all the magic will happen
all right
so
this function obviously the command
function is part of the slacker library
and this is the syntax
the requirements of the function itself
and it has
uh
a description
so we'll say let's say
send any question to wolfgram
and has an example
again like i said you know this is
coming all coming from the slacker
library it's not something that we are
building up
uh all these are requirements of the
slacker library
so this is an example right example
question
these are uh both are static variables
these are just the description and the
example of how the spot will be used
right these are not dynamic
so we'll say handler handler is our
function that helps us to
work
with the bot or with the
different uh you know commands and when
i pressed enter it
it filled in all these things for me
automatically
so in case you're not using a golang
plugin and it's not filled in these for
you just make sure you
get this right otherwise this code will
also be on
github and you can easily pick it up
from there
so we'll say query
which is a variable and we'll say
request
so handler functions if you've seen my
rest api videos of golang you know that
you have
requested response objects right so
request is what the user is sending to
this function to our golang program
and in the request you will have
parameters if you've ever worked with
rest apis you know what parameters are
so the parameter that you're looking for
let's say it's called a message right
and here that means we have to uh give a
query something like that so we'll say
query for
bot
right put a dash here
and to pass a param in a function
uh to to slack when you pass a param you
have to pass it like this so we'll say
message
and so what you're
telling to go language is that in the
request there'll be param called message
so when we
send a command to our slack bot it'll be
like query for bot and then we'll put a
dash and we'll put the actual uh
statement and the statement itself will
be captured inside query
and then this query is
going to be sent to
uh you know
wherever like uh wit ai and wolfram
now there is a
there seems to be an issue here i think
we have to put a comma that's what the
vs code is telling me so i've put a
comma here and the
squiggly lines have gone away
so everything looks good and query
there's a squiggly line here because it
says it's declared but not used right
now
what we'll do is
we'll come here we'll say
client
dot parse
now client is going to be our with ai
client which we have not we've not
created till now
so i think before i create my client
what i'll do is i'll show you what the
query looks like
in
the
uh command line so i'll say fmd dot
print line and i'll say query
so when we send this uh query to the bot
it's just going to print it out
and then let's also
keep a response here
and the response will be very simple
just be
received all right
now reply gives us a squiggly line
because
r has to be capital
and now everything works
except for this i don't know i could not
import this package
i think we'll have to just run go more
tidy and
reinstall it back again
so i'll just go to my
terminal and i'll say go mod
diary even i have if i had installed the
package i don't know why it wasn't
recognized here
so anyhow
uh
this is what uh
the code looks like as of now and there
seem to be no errors so what we'll do
now is we'll start this program
so we'll say
go run main.go and let's see what
happens
okay now we'll head over to our slack
and
to our youtube demo app we'll say
query for bot
and we'll say
what is the capital of india
so all we need to know is
that yes it was able to
get the message so message now is what
is the gavel of india so it's able to
read it it's also able to print it out
right
so everything works as expected
and
this means we can
now start writing the code
so now we'll create our with ai client
to do that you need to create a variable
called client
out here
so let's say client
and the walrus operator and then we'll
save it ai
we don't have ati in our project so
let's get fit ai in our project so we'll
save it
ai
and the package will be github.com slash
weight ai slash
wait go
slash v2
now we had installed this package but
there's a possibility that uh
golang wasn't able to get it it's okay
we'll again run go mod id no problem
so coming back here
we'll save it ai
dot
new client
we'll say os dot
get
environment
and with
ai token
now again the reason that
why
golang is not able to get this for us is
because
because there's some issue with my go
path obviously
and since this is my windows laptop i
won't try to fix it
i use my linux laptop most of the times
so just bear with me when i run go mod
in it
uh don't worry it'll install it back
again for us
so here we have our client with ai
and it uses the vti token in our
environment file all right
so so far so good
now it's giving us a sweet line here
because we have not used our client
package and that's what we'll be using
here so we'll say
client.parse
and inside parts we'll write
with ai ampersand with ai sorry in small
what's wrong with my caps
wait a i dot
message request
and side message request
you will have to send a query
and the query will be
what you get from here from
uh your slack bot so let me show you the
diagram again all right
you the user sends a message it goes to
slack slack gives it to golang server
and now we have to send it to it right
so slack has given it to
golang which is query and query has to
be passed to vdi
so i hope everything makes sense now
and here we're going to print this out
so we'll come here and we'll
take these values in a variable called
message
comma blank
and we'll print out the message here
so now we'll run that program again and
i'll show you why i've done this
uh i'm not sure why it's telling me to
get this package when i
need the v2
and if i say command s and i run go more
tidy i'll just stop this program for now
i'll say go mod
tidy
and it has got the v2 for us
right so everything works now no errors
here
so we'll run the program again
oh yes sorry sorry sorry sorry
i'll run the program again i'll say go
go run main.go
and
here we'll say
at youtube demo
query for pot
what is
the capital of india
and it's able to get the message
and now this is the reply that's coming
from
vta
this needs to be structured i'm sure you
agree with me that this needs to be
structured because this is not something
that
world ram will be able to understand
so we'll stop this program here
and i'll just open up
the vs code editor
again
so
the message that's now in msg
we have to do something about it right
so we'll say
we'll create a variable called data
we'll put a dash here
and the walrus operator and we'll say
json dot
marshall indent
basically want to convert that whatever
response that you saw you want to
convert that into json
so this adds the right
spaces and everything
so about four spaces is the right
one two three four
all right
and uh this will add those uh if you've
seen json objects you'll you'll see that
all of the
key value pairs they're covered in these
type of
inverted commas right so that's what
the double inverted comma sorry
so that's what the indent function does
so json is giving a squiggly line here
so if i put ctrl s that should give me
the encoding.json package yes so i get
that so there's only one error left
which is data which is basically saying
that i'm not using
data
and i'll create another variable called
rough and i'll say
convert whatever data i get into string
format
and we're going to print out
basically
this rough variable
now let's see what happens
we'll run the program again
and here we'll say at youtube
demo
uh query for bot
what is the capital
of india
it does says it'll say received and here
we can see that we get a nice json
object that now we can work with
and uh the thing that you need access to
is basically inside entities inside this
wolf ram search query
and inside that array inside that object
inside the array and inside
value
that's what you need
the
reference to right
and this value this is the thing that we
need to send to
wolfram now there is also a confidence
score which is of 92 percent so
uh 92 divided by 100 is 0.92 so so it
gives us a range between zero and one so
anything above 80 percent or even 70 is
good
and we could have
you know taken our program further and
we could have uh checked the confidence
score and then uh given the query to
wolfram but it's not a problem since we
have not trained our bot to understand
these queries as of now we won't uh and
and our vita ai is directly going to
forward these queries to voltram we
don't have to worry about the confidence
score right now okay
so you'll stop this program now
and it does give a little error a
problem time to you know stop it
and here you'll come back here again
and
uh
now like you know you need access to
this thing right
inside entities inside this inside the
area inside the
object inside
value now to get access to this ngo line
is very difficult it's not like
javascript you just you know start
accessing this uh working with this
object directly because golang does not
have native support for json
because json is javascript object
notation so only javascript has
native
access to it
so what we'll do is
we'll create a variable called value
because we need that value right inside
entities
and we'll use our package the json
package
and with the json package you can just
run these get queries to get whatever
you want so we're
going to run the get get query on this
variable called ref
and
we want to say entities so i want access
to my entities
and i want access to this width dollar
wolf ram search query
and uh you know colon wolfram search
query right
so let me write that here with
dollar
wolf ram
search
query
colon
wolf
ram
search
query
okay so just check if the spelling of
wolfram is okay looks good
and now we want to access
the first value of this array right this
is an array so we have access to this
now we want access to this first value
of the array so we do that in an array
do that by dot zero right because that's
the first value so with this package
with the help of this package you can
easily access
the values inside an array so you'll see
dot zero and dot
value so let me show it to you again
so dot zero which is this object and
inside that is dot value and you'll have
access to what is the capital of india
it's just as simple as that
now what we'll do is we'll actually
print out this value so that
you'll see exactly what i'm talking
about and now we'll go here again we'll
start the program again
okay so it's telling me to get this
package so
let me go back here
okay again i'll run go mod id
and we'll run the program again
[Music]
okay
and here we should say
again the same query
query for pot
what is the
capital of india
here you can see
we got the value the exact
string that we want to send to our
wolfram we have it here we were able to
access it
using
our
uh
gjson package
makes sense
so uh with the help of uh this bot right
we'll be able to send it send these kind
of questions like who's the president of
u.s who's the president of india who's
the president of the u.s what is the
capital of india who's the governor of
china it'll give us the exact right
answers
uh because wolfram has the ability to
process that kind of information give
the right answers
so let's see how it does that
now create another variable called
answer
and this basically converts
the value that i just received here into
string
okay because string is what we have to
send to our
voltron client
now that means we'll have to create our
world front grant right so we'll come
here we'll say
wolf ram client
is equal to
ampersand
wolfram dot client
inside that here in this case there will
be these quickly brackets
and we'll say
app
id
os dot
get
environment
and we'll say wolf
ram app id
all right so
it doesn't our golang program doesn't
have access to this
so let's fix that
so it's added that already actually
good
and then it's giving me error here
okay i think i'll have to create a
wolfram
uh
client actually
a variable call voltron client so this i
have to make sure the cs capital
c has to be capital here
and here i'll have to create a constant
wolf ram
plant
and wolf ram
dot
client
all right and the wolfram client comes
from here
everything looks good
right
now there seems to be an error here i
don't know why
missing constant value syntax
sorry it has to be a variable actually
or a constant
so it's a variable
and
here so it has an error here it has an
error here in this place
and it has an error here
because we are declaring it but not
using it
so now i'll come here
to answer actually before that let me
just
stop this program
and
go more tight again so that we get the
word from package
and now the errors mostly have gone away
except for
these two errors right the word from
clients so this the volume 10 we have to
use right now
so i have the answer here in a
which is
basically string in
the value in string format and i'll say
world ram client
dot
get
spoken answer query
now there's uh there's a confusion here
that many people have is that
uh the person who's created this library
it should have said get spoken on
security but it says get spoken in t
there's a small t here so just make sure
you write that t otherwise
you will face a lot of problems
so here we'll pass
the answer
comma the answer that we get here
and wolfram
dot metric
comma 1000
all right
and we'll assign this to two different
things one is the response and one is an
error
and
if there's an error which means if error
not equal to nil
we will print out
there
is
an error
and the response
we will send our
response object
rds right
and to me everything looks okay
and there seems to be no error as of now
but only when we run the program we'll
come to know
so yeah everything looks good
and what we'll now do is uh let me check
if there's any uh
more packages to be installed i don't
think so
okay so let's run this code go mod sorry
go run main.go
and
to our youtube bot
we'll say query for bot
what is the capital of india
so it can reply to us the capital of
india is new delhi india
and youtube
bought query for bot
what is the
capital of china
it takes a while because it goes to wait
and then goes to voltram see colossians
beijing china so as you can see our bot
can understand anything you know it's
really really powerful
so let's say query for bot
who
is
president of
india
at youtube
query for pot
who is the president
of brazil
so as you can see
our bot can do anything
it can basically
uh find the answers for all of these
very difficult questions uh that and uh
difficult in the sense not for human
beings or sometimes even for human
beings because i didn't know the
president of brazil is right so yeah you
can get all of these answers from using
your wolfram
api
so i hope uh you learned a lot in this
video today and you built something
really exciting and this is a very very
powerful bot so if you're by the way if
you're somebody who's looking for a job
in golang uh i don't think there's a
project that's better than this to show
off your skills right because you're
using golang you're using slack you're
using
uh and these all these awesome packages
right environment packages and the json
package
and you're using um vid you're using
wolfram and then the sky is the limit
with it right you can i didn't show you
how to train your vid bot but you can
you know you can basically watch any
other video on vid uh there are many
videos on that focus on just how to use
fit and you can
actually you know scale this spot up to
a whole new level right
so
i hope you learned a lot in this video
and
uh
we built a board that can basically do
anything right it's an nlp what and it's
connected to wolfram so it can
understand anything it can do anything
so i won't say you can sign anything
because we are not trained of it with
api
but if you trained it really well it
would be able to do anything